Intro/Outro
So der echte Wolfgang mit echter Cola light wie man ihn kennt wahrscheinlich wenn du ins Kino trinkst oder auch Cola light.
Ich trinke gar nicht zum Kino Denn ich habe im Kino ja schon mein Notizbuch in der Hand mache mir dann eifrig Notizen und denke auch man kann dann mal 90 oder 120 Minuten nichts trinken nichts essen und sich ganz auf den Film konzentrieren.
Brauchst dann auch nicht im Kino. Hast du schon mal im Kino während eines Films geraucht gab es schon mal die Gelegenheit.
Das gibt's ja nicht mehr. Es gab wohl in den 80ern noch in Koblenz ein Kino in dem man rauchen konnte.
Aber da sagte mir mal der Kinobetreiber Er ist selbst starker Raucher dass er das nicht ausgehalten hat das sei so ekelhaft gewesen.
Ich kann es mir auch nicht so gut vorstellen Ich rauche zuhause ja auch nicht wenn ich mir den Film ansehe sondern eher danach.
Ich habe das noch nie erlebt dass jemand im Kino geraucht hat. Auf der anderen Seite will man sowas ja auch nicht erleben weil er ja zu Recht abgeschafft.
Man haben ja zu Recht.
So hier sind also die neuen Zwanziger im Juni. Corona ist noch nicht vorbei.
29. Juni. Nein Lola steil nach oben würde sich Amerika angucken.
Tatsächlich geht Corona steil nach oben wenn man sich Amerika anguckt. Man könnte immer über Corona reden wir machen seit glaub ich gar nicht bis fast gar nicht. Ich habe auch heute und morgen mein Tweet gemacht.
Man hat ja immer noch mich gar nicht. Ja aber,
in Amerika ist die Zahl wieder hoch Wir bleiben auch extrem gefallen..
In Amerika gehen jetzt die Zahlen wieder hoch wie im März. Aber die Todeszahlen bleiben nach unten und die sind auch extrem gefallen. Es scheint große therapeutische Fortschritte zu geben und wer weiß vielleicht ist das Problem gar nicht mal so groß wie man immer glaubt.
Vielleicht ist das Problem gar nicht mal so groß.
Naja ein anderes großes Thema das ist dieses ganze Protest Black Lives Matter und so weiter.
Ein anderes großes Thema.
Das liegt auch ein bisschen zu offenbar irgendwie da. Da es jetzt gar nicht.
Wir streifen es später weil wir werden über Sprache und Gewalt sprechen über das was man nicht mehr sagen soll oder nicht mehr sagen darf sagen dann manche.
Und da kommt es dann noch wieder. Da ist ja auch nochmal durch Black Lives Matter eine neue Debatte entflammt aber ich habe dann doch auch festgestellt dass es schon sehr weit wieder zurück liegt.
Es ist so eine Welle die kommt und dann sprechen alle davon und hätten wir jetzt vor zwei Wochen den Podcast aufgezeichnet.
Wäre das dann das dominante Thema gewesen.
Es ist aber dann auch schon wieder etwas was zum Teil jetzt kritisiert wird oder was angesprochen wurde Wir haben ja auch einen Text.
Da geht es schon darum dass man immer dann gerade gesagt bekommt Das ist jetzt das Wichtigste und über nichts anderes lohnt es sich zu sprechen und plötzlich drei Tage später ist es passiert.
Nichtsanderes.
Zeitdruck ist ja ein bisschen anders.
Ich glaube es findet noch extrem viel statt wenn auch nichts auf der Straße aber es gibt ja total auch durch den Wahlkampf angetrieben große institutionelle Veränderungen beispielsweise bei den ganzen Tag Giganten und so.
Beispielsweise bei den ganzen Tag Giganten und so. Aber es ist zu sagen Es ist nicht viel zu analysieren.
Aber es ist zu wie soll man sagen Es gibt jetzt nicht viel zu analysieren oder so sondern es ist einfach da und verändert hoffentlich einiges und man steht so daneben und drückt eigentlich die Daumen und hofft irgendwie so ein bisschen frei nach Steinmeier ist es ja so ein Arbeitsauftrag an alle Mann.
Da verändert sich einiges und eigentlich geht auch ein bisschen mit nach Steinmeier als Arbeitsauftrag an alle. Es reicht jetzt nicht kein Rassist zu sein.
Es reicht jetzt nicht kein Rassist zu sein sondern man muss jetzt Antirassismus sein.
Antirassismus sein so dass das beste.
Irgendwie versucht jeder das Beste draus zu machen aber es wäre dann mehr so ein Thema bei dem man dann später mal Bilanz zieht irgendwie beispielsweise nach so einer Wahl oder so. Was ist geblieben.
Thema aber man wird später mal Bilanz.
Aber ich glaube es ist ganz gut dass man nicht gleich auf den fahrenden Zug aufspringt dass man jetzt sagt wie das geschehen ist.
Jetzt sind diese Proteste und die werden überall sein und bleiben und das hat sich ja gerade gezeigt ist nicht der Fall.
Es gab dann sehr schnell in Berlin und in anderen großen Städten auch in Europa diese Demonstrationen und die waren auch wahnsinnig gut organisiert,
und gingen schnell dann auch so vonstatten wie man das gedacht hat es gab auch so ein einheitliches Branding kann man fast sagen dass es auch in gewisser Weise eigenartig zu sehen also wie professionalisierte es dann wiederum ist.
Aber man muss dann wirklich mal schauen was sich institutionell am Ende tut.
Und das ist dann nicht das was irgendwie ein paar schwarze Kacheln bei Instagram sind.
Ich meine schwarze Kassen bei Instagram aber es gibt bei Google jetzt die Veränderung Man spricht nicht mehr von Blacklist Whitelist was ja sehr technische Begriffe sind sondern da gibts.
Ich weiß nicht genau aber mit einem benutztes Begriffe ein bisschen besser prägen aber nicht ganz so griffig sind wie Blacklist Whitelist um Sachen zu erlauben oder zu verbieten.
Gibts da soll die eine oder andere Veränderung Freds.
Jetzt kommt der Regen über den Wolfgang gerade auf der Autobahn erlebt hat stört uns aber nicht weiter Wir können ja das Fenster einfach zumachen.
Wir haben eine Mail bekommen von Andreas der schrieb nachdem ich darauf hinwies dass ich im nächsten Salon schon Boltons Buch lese.
Ein mega Narziß der über den Narzisst ein Buch geschrieben hat.
Hallo Stephan super Schachzug anzukündigen dass du wenigstens solange das Bolden Buch liest.
Das muss man ja unterstützen da ich aber schon ein Abo habe muss ich jetzt wohl noch ein Stiftungs Abo abschließen also ein Gastgeber Abo.
Ich habe also auf ein Gastgeber Paket erweitert und überlasse die drei anderen Tickets die er jetzt hat gibt sie nach deinem Gutdünken weiter.
Brauchst du dafür noch irgendetwas von mir schöne Grüße Andreas. Ich brauch nichts weiter von Andreas dafür denn dieses Gastgeber also jemand der,
für 57 im Monat bucht kann ja drei Gäste einladen und jetzt hab ich mal nachgesehen Wir haben 12 von diesen Gastgebern die könnten also 36 Kassenmitglieder mitbringen aber es gibt nur 14 sind also noch ein paar auf der Liste offen.
Ich hatte ja auch schon mal gesagt Leute die es Talk Radio schon mal unterstützt haben vor einem Jahr oder so. Die kommen natürlich auf eine Liste und ich werde die Liste jetzt mal anlegen allerdings nicht gleich zur Veröffentlichung dieses Podcast sondern es wird dann irgendwie so ein Google Dock geben.
Um dann wahrscheinlich nächste Woche oder so.
Und da auf dieser Google Liste stehen dann E-Mail-Adressen von Leuten,
die wir schon begutachtet haben sozusagen sodass man als wenn man ein Gastgeber Abo abgeschlossen hat sein kann aus dieser Liste hole ich mir jetzt ein zwei drei E-Mail-Adressen und lade die sozusagen ein dann auf mein Ticket mit Salonen Mitglied zu werden.
Wolfgang und ich hätte noch überlegen ob wir vielleicht die nächste reguläre Ausgabe auch mal zu so einer Salon Ausgabe machen zumindest drei vier fünf Tage vorher.
Und dann nachher im Anschluss für alle frei aber dann gibt's für die Abonnenten die können ein bisschen früher hören.
Genau. Die bleibt frei für alle. Aber sie mal einen kleinen Benefit schaffen und noch ein bisschen Anreiz diesen Podcast finanziell zu unterstützen.
Stecken wir mal in den Juni. Es gibt eine Verschiebung auf dem Kino Kalender und.
Wir hatten ja gedacht Christopher Nolan kommt Ende Juli aber jetzt durch Mitte Juli Ende Juli aber es soll wohl nochmal verschoben werden.
Das letzte Mal hieß es noch Juli Nee es hieß Mitte Juli jetzt Ende Juli.
August.
Durch die erhöhten Coruña zahlen jetzt in den USA. Darauf hat man jetzt nochmal reagiert und damit verschiebt sich ja dann auch der Filmstart vermutlich in allen anderen Ländern.
Man wird jetzt ja wieder neu disponieren müssen das ist ja auch gar nicht so leicht auch für Kinos Man muss,
auch bedenken Es gibt nicht nur Multiplexe Es gibt auch noch Kinos,
die populäres Programm spielen aber nur zwei drei Leinwände haben und die sind dann überfordert auch wenn sich das zu sehr bald aber andererseits momentan hat man genug Luft um zu verschieben.
Jedenfalls als aufgefallen denn es hieß ja immer mit Tennet verschiebt sich der ganze weitere Plan Wenn Tennet verschoben wird werden alle anderen durch Lücken suchen Wann passt denn und so weiter.
Walzers aufgefallen denn es ist ja immer mit Tennet verschiebt sich der ganze Beitrittsland Wenn Tennet verschoben wird werden alle anderen Flüchtlingsgruppen.
Jetzt hab ich ja eine kleine Liste gefunden. Ich trage jetzt die ganze Liste vor wie ich sie gefunden habe irgendwo einer deutschen Google blabla Newsseite.
Habe ich eine kleine Testkunden.
Also verschoben wird. Wonder Woman 984.
Also verschoben wird. Wonder Woman 984,
um zwei Monate dann Matrix 4 um ein Jahr 2022 im April kommt es und als drittes Godzilla Böses Cong.
Dann Matrix 4,
Vom November auf Mai wenn man sich die drei Filme Wonder Woman 1984 Matrix 4 und Godzilla Kong auf.
Dann,
das Muster aus dass es nichts Neues wäre und vielleicht ist das alles nur eine große Zeitschleife inszeniert von Christopher Nolan.
Genau das ist ja nichts Neues.
Genau das ist die Vorahnung auf die hinauswill Wonder Woman ist eh schon eine Person die wir schon kennen eine Figur die kann man jetzt natürlich nochmal bringen im Sinne von Sequel da kommen die Leute es beim ersten Mal toll gewesen.
Matrix 4 Matrix kennen wir seit 20 Jahren.
Das ist jetzt der vierte Teil von nochmal angeschlossen an den erfolgreichen Brant und Godzilla Kong ist nun mal die ganze Kinogeschichte irgendwie und wir haben ja sowieso nicht nur durch die Erfindung des Internets,
vielleicht reicht das Argument schon mal gemacht weil ich finde es so goldig dass ich es nochmal anbringen möchte.
Wenn man schon durch die Erfindung von YouTube z.B.
Eine Konzentration von Kulturleistungen aus vielen Jahrzehnten geballt in,
ein Video mal so eine kleine Welle für 2 Monate so Miriams die durchhalten und dann hab ich ja in Redaktionsschluß schon das Argument gemacht wir haben jetzt zwar neue Verbreitungswege aber die Kulturräume die das erschaffen die gibts eigentlich nicht.
Man kann jetzt nur das was schon da ist nochmal machen dann ist das ja durch Corona nochmal schlimmer geworden.
Corona produziert ja nichts Neues sondern wir können es nur uns nochmal anschauen was es alles gab und dieses Argument hat er Josh.
Dingsbums aus dem Podcast mal gemacht nämlich zu sagen Stranger Things also diese Netflix Serie die war ja eigentlich die ganzen 80er zusammen gekocht auf irgendwie 100 Stunden pro Episode pro pro Staffel oder so.
Und die 80er waren ja gar nicht so wie man es da erlebt sondern man muss sich ja wirklich einmal richtig durch kondensieren alles raus kochen was an Langeweile auch in den 80ern stattfand.
Und dann kommt man zu so einer sehr genau.
Das Ganze Kinoprogramm scheint mir genauso ein Kondensat nur noch zu sein.
Absolut und es gibt ja auch in der Musik ähnliches zu beobachten.
Es gibt dieses Buch das sehr erfolgreich war international Retro Mania das genau davon handelt dass nichts mehr Neues entsteht sondern dass wir eigentlich in einer permanenten Sample und Recycling Kultur sind.
Und das ist schon erstaunlich. Während wir uns noch ein bisschen schwertun ökologie und Recycling wirklich in der Wirtschaft anzuwenden haben wir das in der Popkultur in einem unglaublichen Ausmaß und,
das ist selbstverständlich auch etwas was,
sich dann beim Kino zeigt dass.
Wir jetzt mit großen Produktionen zu tun haben von denen aber eigentlich auch gar nicht mehr etwas Großes erwartet wird,
sondern man sagt Na ja dann verschiebt sich halt aber es ist ja eigentlich auch egal weil es schon da ist und die Frage ist dann Wo entsteht dann überhaupt etwas Neues oder entsteht es dann vielleicht gar nicht in diesem Medium entsteht es woanders.
Also entsteht es zum Beispiel bei den Computerspielen.
Aber auch da sind ja wieder ganz viele Bezüge rätoromanischen Bezüge auch vorhanden.
Das ist schon sehr sehr eigenartig es gibt ja von Francis Fukuyama diesen Essay Das Ende der Geschichte.
Dort malte er so ein bisschen aus dass uns doch eine Kultur der Langeweile droht weil nicht mehr das Ereignis das dann eigentlich da ist.
Und das wird sich zeigen ob die Popkultur auf Corona nochmal reagiert in einer Weise verarbeiten wie war das mit der Familie im Look down sondern wirklich diese Ereignisse Heftigkeit vielleicht nochmal transformiert in eine spannende Geschichte.
Ja es ist auf jeden Fall eine große Zäsur in der Welt bei der man sich fragt Was kann man jetzt kulturell daraus machen wenn die Botschaft einfach nur ist. Damals als alle zu Hause waren ist natürlich auch wenig inspirierend.
Und Wer Netflix geschaut haben.
Aber es ist auch wirklich krass dass da in dieser Lage. Christopher Nolan kommt und sagt Ich mache mal während alle in einem endlosen kulturellen Loup drin hängen ein Film über Zeitreise und das ist dann der einzige der wirklich neu ist inhaltlich so.
Was in dieser Lage,
manchmal wären alle.
Sehr schön. Du siehst es ja auch im Fernsehen Du guckst ja nicht normal noch Fernsehen.
Gar nichts. Ich beobachte ja gerne mal die Unterhaltungs Formate gerade auch in den dritten und dort haben wir jeden Abend irgendeine Show die ein Revival nochmal bringt.
So war die ZDF-Hitparade,
mit Dieter Krebs und Harald Juhnke lauter solche Dinge die werden ja in Endlosschleife immer wieder neu zusammengemixt immer wieder der große Sketch,
noch einmal Wolfgang Lippert erzählt wie es damals war wie er schon damals erzählt hat wie es damals war und das ist eigentlich das was permanent eigentlich das Senioren Fernsehen ausmacht und ich glaube dass,
die Senioren auch in so einer Zeitschleife da vor dem Fernseher gefangen sind und da auch nicht mehr rauskommen.
Während doch eigentlich das politische nah wie selten an so einer kulturellen Aufarbeitung die Geschwindigkeit von YouTube-Videos behandeln und so weiter das ist ja doch eigentlich einiges los aber kann da nicht abgebildet werden.
Naja bleibt jedenfalls bei der Pointe Wir warten allemal. Warren Christopher Nolans Zeitreise Film kommt die Wahrheit liegt in der Zukunft.
Und dann reisen wir halt mit ihm zurück.
Kleine Nachtclubs noch Aussehen zu den letzten Themen.
Thema Nummer 1 Einsamkeit während wir ja alle wissen was eine Epidemie und eine Pandemie ist,
hat Karl Lauterbach den ich ja nun auch sehr kritisiert habe dafür dass er immer nur Corona Corona Corona und sonst nichts schrieb er tatsächlich am 9.
Juni jetzt einen Tweet bisher größte internationale Studie zu Einsamkeit,
Risikofaktor für höhere Sterblichkeit Demenz und Krebs zeigt überraschend klar dass mittlere und jüngere Altersgruppen sogar mehr betroffen ist als ältere.
Einsamkeit ist eine stille tödliche Pandemie.
Ach.
Hat sich den Begriff noch einmal genommen und er verweist auf die BBC Lonely Ness Das BBC Loni Experiment.
Wir wissen ja von den Engländern die haben ja auch ein eigenes Einsamkeiten Ministerium und die sind.
46 000 Teilnehmer im Alter von 16 bis 19 90 aus 237 global unterschiedlichen Orten also nicht mal eine richtig große globale Studie.
Und dann ist mir aufgefallen Für Lauterbach ist das Einsamkeiten Thema gar nicht so neu.
Man muss jetzt gar nichts sagen. Im Juni 2020 hat das entdeckt dass nicht nur Korona gefährlich und Pandemie ist sondern auch Einsamkeit,
sondern schon am 5.5 2019 schrieb er auf Twitter mehr Studien die zeigen Doppelpunkt Einsamkeit so schädlich wie übergewicht oder 110 Zigaretten am Tag Facebook,
und so weiter großer Risikofaktor.
Auch junge Menschen gefährdet in Großstädten wird das zur Epidemie immerhin schon.
Wir müssen bezahlbare Quartiere mit sozial Angeboten schaffen und ganz erstaunlich noch ein Jahr weiter und zwar am vierten fünften 2018 also ein Jahr und einen Tag davor schrieb er.
Einsamkeit ist eine Epidemie geworden.
Sie quält die Betroffenen macht sie körperlich und psychisch krank und verkürzt ihr Leben stärker als übergewicht.
Wir dürfen nicht weiter Wegsehen sowohl Bau Sozial und Gesundheitspolitik sind hier gefordert alles genau richtig. Die Frage ist nur Warum hat er das so ausgeblendet.
In der Coruña Diskussion auf Twitter ja da hat man ja gar nichts mehr dazu gelesen und selbst im aufwachten Podcast meinte er auf eine Frage von mir hin sollte man sich nicht auch andere.
Körperliche Krankheiten Herzinfarkt und so weiter angucken oder den Herzinfarkt heruntergespielt.
Na ja das ist ja dann so ein Ziehen in der Schulter und da muss man dann mal gucken ob man es dann wirklich so weit Therapie bedürftig ist wohl wissend dass es ja zur Hälfte auch tödliche Sache in Deutschland ist.
Naja zum Thema Einsamkeit zum Thema EZB das hat man ja im letzten Monat.
Jens Weidmann der Bundesbank-Chef muss jetzt quartalsweise in den Bundestag und werden im sogenannten monetären Dialog Fragen zur EZB Geldpolitik gestellt.
Und dann muss er die beantworten.
Ist das jetzt für ihn eine Strafe oder für die Politiker einer Strafe.
Das weiß man noch nicht genau ob das jetzt ein bisschen mehr wird als ein Kaffeekränzchen wo dann wieder Carsten Schneider sagte Ich habe ihn doch noch in der Küche angesprochen wie das ist.
Im August geht's los. Wir werden es nächsten Monat sehen und ich muss mir noch ein kleiner Screenshot holen.
Sehen wollen.
Man wäre ja eigentlich da gerne dabei. Bei einem solchen Gespräch wie das dann läuft und welche du glaubst dass.
Ausschuss-Sitzung warum nicht.
Es gibt.
Das ist ja immer ein wunderbares Feld für Politiker um sich mal so richtig zu blamieren.
Ja das stimmt ich habe es gefunden.
Es gab. Das hat Stephan Detjen heute Morgen getwittert. Ist es wirklich lustig.
Die F.A.Z. hat nochmal bei dem Berichterstatter dem inhaltlich verfahrenstechnische verantwortlichen Bundesverfassungsgericht nachgefragt dem Herrn Huber Herr Huber.
Den hatten wir auch noch thematisiert und er hat jetzt wieder Fragen bekommen von der FAZ ich mal mit Nein.
Das erstaunt mich jetzt gibt es keine Vollzugs Kontrolle.
Sie hat ja gesagt alle drei Monate. Also ich habe jetzt drei Monate Zeit um die Sachen einzuholen.
Gibt es keine Vollzugs Kontrolle für dieses Urteil. Sie müssen doch überprüfen ob auch durchgeführt wird was sie aufgetragen haben.
Im Zweifel geht es ja darum fünf Jahren wieder zurück zu.
Und dann sagt der Verfassungsrichter So etwas kann nur in einem neuen Verfahren geschehen oder wenn die Beschwerdeführer eine Vollstreckung Anordnungen beantragen würden also aus dem Urteil ergibt sich gar nichts.
Man müsste jetzt selbst wenn man es vollziehen wollte nochmal nachlegen weil sie der Meinung sind die Verhältnismäßigkeit der Prüfung sei nicht vollständig.
Wenn das nicht passiert sind wir raus.
Man wollte eigentlich nur mal ein Signal setzen und das wars.
Man hat ja man hat wirklich nur ein Signal gesetzt wenn der nächste Frage einer der Beschwerdeführer der frühere CSU-Politiker Peter Gauweiler behält sich das jedenfalls vor.
Und dann sagt der Richter Herr Gauweiler kann sich das wie jeder Staatsbürger anschauen und gegebenenfalls das Gericht wieder anrufen.
Wozu ich weder ermuntern noch abraten möchte.
Klammer auf lacht Klammer zu so redet man jetzt in der FAZ über diese Sache.
Es ist grotesker. Es ist halt nochmal eine groteske Schleife genommen fast als überhaupt schon inhaltlich diese Art und Weise wie das Nein zum Green Deal im Januar behandelte also das große Programm von von der Leyen.
Wir haben es damals ja interpretiert und es hat ja auch ausdrücklich sagte Es ist die neue Wachstumsstrategie.
Wir wollen auch das Klima retten aber erst einmal geht es darum überhaupt einen neuen Anreiz zu schaffen und VP-Chef Manfred Weber hat nun vorgeschlagen den Green Deal ausfallen zu lassen weil Coruna.
Das könnte man ja der Wirtschaft nicht zumuten. Da haben dann sehr viele auf Twitter geschrieben Herr Weber.
Es geht darum die Wirtschaft zu retten und zwar mit diesem neuen Programm. Wenn Sie das jetzt ausfallen lassen dann machen wir noch zehn Jahre Kohle und dann ist aber auch finito und dann sind wir wirklich von Amerika überholt und von China erst recht.
Diese Themen entfalten doch.
Immer noch nicht verstanden was so erstaunlich ist weil man doch gerade sieht wie sich die Grünen-Spitze anschmiegt dann Friedrich Merz die offenbar aus kapitalistischen Profitinteressen an grüne Energie denken.
Das ist so eigenartig dass es dann immer noch in der CDU Leute gibt die das gar nicht verstehen wollen statt einfach zu sagen Wir machen das jetzt wir haben uns ja immer schon angepasst an solche Entwicklungen.
So wie der Kapitalismus sich ja selbst auch anpasst sehr anpassungsfähig ist.
Aber das wird immer noch so getan als sei das ein Luxus den man sich ein bisschen leisten will.
Sehr sehr eigenartig. Man versteht ja gar nicht warum so wenig Interesse eigentlich für wirtschaftliche Zusammenhänge vorhanden ist denn man könnte ja,
durchaus aus reiner Profit Logik sagen wir müssen das jetzt besonders stärken damit können wir überhaupt erst aus dieser Krise raus weil wir ja auch eine große.
Wir haben ja einen Mangel an Nachfrage. Das zeigt sich ja jetzt auch dass Geschäfte zwar auf sind aber es wird gar nicht gekauft das ist gar nicht weil die Leute nur Angst haben sondern weil es eine große Nachfrage gibt.
Diese Entkopplung von Geldmenge und Inflation ist das größte Wunder überhaupt.
Wie das zusammenhängt und das unverstandene Man muss in dem Fall hier aber wirklich dazusagen Ich habe Manfred Weber jetzt auch im Juni mal in so Semih privaten.
Er war natürlich beruflich unterwegs aber mal erlebt und bei ihm wäre es noch zu viel zu sagen Er versteht es nicht sondern es ist ihm tatsächlich einfach egal.
Manfred Weber tritt ja öffentlich immer ganz zurückhaltend auf. Also immer mit so ganz vermittelnden Sätzen und so weiter.
Vielleicht hat ihm diese mangelnde Aggressivität auch den Posten gekostet.
Dass der Wahlkampf dann einfach nicht entsprechend ausging weil er sich nicht profilieren konnte.
Aber hinter diesem Geschachere um kleinste undsoweiter Raumgewinn die man irgendwie politisch macht bei ihm.
Hauptsache in Brüssel irgendwie und niemanden zu streng aber irgendwie so. Also.
Wenn er dann solche Aufschläge macht wie wir sollten mal das wegen Kuroda verschieben und so weiter da denkt er wirklich nur einfach an den bayerischen 60jährigen irgendwie auf Terrasse sitzenden Hausbewohner der sich denkt,
jetzt noch groß die Veränderung der Wirtschaft. Es ist doch schon stressig genug irgendwie.
So ganz ganz bräsig und lustlos auch und einfach nur gucken dass man so gut durch den Tag kommt irgendwie.
Das ist nicht schlimm schlimm eigentlich solche Typen wie Manfred Weber dann jetzt wieder in solchen Rollen wollen ja nicht ganz abschieben.
Also machen wir es mal zum övp-chef wo er dann wenn das Parlament ist nicht das mächtigste muss in diesem Gefüge immer noch sagen dass jetzt so von der Leyen und Lagarde irgendwie unter sich und machen dann mal so ein Telefonat mit Merkel.
Aber dass da immer noch so Querschüssen wird aus solchen Posten FDP-Fraktionsvorsitzenden.
Es ist halt einfach.
Das ist ein ganz ganz großes Problem nicht nur in der Politik das kennen wir auch aus Zeitungshäuser ohne dass wir jetzt Namen nennen müssten wissen wir dass da genau eine solche Mentalität herrscht dass man sagt Ach ja für mich reicht's sagt man im Stillen.
Und dann sagt man nach draußen dass man sich immer über frische Ideen freut aber sie nie sich anhört.
Und schon gar nicht umsetzt. Und immer wenn irgendwo eine kleine Krise sich auftut wird das was man Neues probiert hat sofort wieder eingestellt.
Dann wird aber innerhalb der Hierarchie nochmal sich gegenseitig befördert und dann bekommt er nochmal einen Posten dafür und das geht dann immer Wer hat am längsten durchgehalten der wird nochmal belohnt am Ende.
Ja das ist so. WDR Tom Buhrow Intendanten steil öffentlich in Interviews.
Ich lasse ja ganz lange Leine die jungen Leute sollen mal testen und so weiter und hintenrum schon wieder so einen Hipster oder irgendwas mit Youtube machen will oder so.
Ja ja ja.
Da zieht man die Mitarbeiter dann wieder zurück.
Genau das ist es ja auch. Deswegen gucke ich ja wirklich gerne das Fernsehprogramm weil man immer wieder sieht wer dann plötzlich kommt man macht das ZDF an und dann gibt's eine Sendung zur Ahnenforschung und moderiert wird die von Thomas Anders.
Dann muss man schon sehen wie tief die Krise ist. In jeder Hinsicht.
Absolut. Man geht auf Nummer sicher ein neues Gesicht. Nee so ein Risiko kann man da nicht machen.
Gottstein war mal eine den Juni mit.
Wie soll man sagen so wie wir es im Januar auch gemacht haben. Es folgt jetzt ein kleiner Tech-Blog den kann man auch überspringen aber dann könnte sich in zwei Monaten wieder herausstellen.
Es gibt eine Verfassungs Krisenlage in Thüringen und vielleicht schauen wir doch noch mal zurück Was verantwortliche Politiker so,
zwanglosen dahingesagt haben damals eine Neujahrsansprache. Diesmal geht es um die Comments meines Buches also um die Abschlussfeier Veranstaltungs reden reden die da immer so gehalten werden das kennt man aus Amerika.
Da werden dann immer die höchsten möglichen.
Berühmtesten Leute mächtigsten Leute eingeladen um mal kurz den Jugendlichen noch einen kleinen Motivations Klaps mitzugeben.
Und nun gab es in diesem Jahr natürlich zwei Besonderheiten Zum einen sind alle ausgefallen diese feiern diese Reden sind alle gut dokumentiert weil online verfügbar,
und naja was soll man den Leuten sagen die sind halt in die Katastrophe rein gewachsen und müssen das jetzt mitmachen.
Ich fand es trotzdem ganz interessant wie sich so entfaltet hat. Wir fangen trotzdem ein bisschen albern an nämlich mit dem Entertainer.
Lady Gaga Oprah Winfrey Beyoncé und Matthew McConaughey die in unterschiedlichen Ramen wen auch immer Ashton Kutcher und andere ganz,
einfach die Jugendlichen adressieren einige von ihnen Lady Gaga Beyoncé Kutscher sind ja auch noch nicht so alt.
Sie haben noch so ein bisschen die wissen noch wie es war damals Oh yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Als Wolfgang ankam sagt ist das mitgebracht nicht zu viel Sonne und so und jetzt kommt ja das Gewitter.
Ein Gewitter auch von Lady Gaga. Wir fangen mal an es ist zugegebenermaßen auch ein bisschen albern.
Bei Oprah Winfrey kommt da natürlich auch Musik gleich drunter gelegt aber die ist nur ganz kurz.
Lady Gaga.
Bei.
Showtime.
Grace,
Jones.
And,
you,
never.
Ever.
Auf der einen Seite sehr typisch vor einem echten Kutscher. Deswegen lohnt sich nur drei Sekunden zuhören.
Mit einem Stirnband sieht er so aus Es hat ein bisschen viel gekifft. Ja ja genau.
Gerade aus dem Dschungelcamp irgendwie nochmal ganz bescheuert Beyoncé als schwarzen natürlich auch ein bisschen mitgenommen von der Gesamtsituation.
Aber sehr präzise.
Sie beglückwünscht zum Ankommen einer globalen Pandemie Krise und sie meint damit vor allem den Rassismus.
Noch nicht mal Krone Lady Gaga also spirituell irgendwie abgedreht da eigentlich ein bisschen.
Lady Gaga,
sehr sehr anstrengend. Ich es mal gesehen bei den Konzerten Es gibt ja einige Mitschnitte dass sie,
dann doch auch nicht diese Kunstfigur eigentlich durchzieht sondern dann immer von dieser Erweckung da erzählt und wie sie sich fühlt und wie sie sich befreit hat innerlich.
Das ist schon sehr sehr schlimm aber nicht so schlimm wie Oprah Winfrey natürlich.
Ja das ist richtig peinlich aber wenn nun Milliarden und Milliarden verdient hast dann biste halt irgendwie abgemeldet.
Ich habe mich immer gefragt bei diesen Comments wenn es spitzes Peaches Du erreicht ja ein Publikum in dem Moment wo sie sich wirklich ganz konkrete Gedanken machen müssen was mache ich im September oder so ist die Frage.
Und gleichzeitig gibt man sich selber den Auftrag so ein allgemeines Motivations Ding zu machen.
Das passt ja eigentlich nicht ganz zusammen wenn die Lady Lady Gaga dann nochmal abdriftet und so ein allgemeines spirituelles irgendwie mit.
Wir können die Zeit kontrollieren.
Es ist ja auch eine totale Disconnect stattfindet in der Hinsicht gibt es hier wenig zu hören.
Wer sich dafür interessiert. Das fand ich inhaltlich dann doch ganz gut weil sie dann auch noch dieses Jahr hier mit drin.
Ihr seid die Antwort auf eine Generation von.
Menschen die sich das nicht vorstellen konnten und viel gebetet haben.
Ihr kriegt jetzt durch diese Vorarbeit die Pflicht irgendwie sagt Ihr seid jetzt die Erben derjenigen die euch das erarbeitet haben dass wir das jetzt machen könnten.
Und sie hat es halt auch sehr adressiert an die Schwarzen war gar nicht so eine allgemeine sondern es schon ziemlich zugedeckt.
So einen gibt's die Charts sag ich mal da haben wir jetzt vor allem auch Trump.
Der hat ja diese komische Rede bei West Point gehalten wo er danach noch beweisen musste dass er auch aus einem Glas Wasser trinken kann und eine Rampe ab Werk ablaufen kann.
Also diese Rede ist und die wird aber nochmal eingerahmt von Mike Pence aber nur ganz kurz weil der redet auch von Militärs.
Also ganz interessant Die beiden haben sich wir reden vom Militär.
Es ist ja nicht zwangsläufig dass man als Präsident das macht und danach gibts aber auch nochmal in Mark Millie den Chef der Joint Chiefs of Staff.
Also wenn sich die acht Waffengattung im Weißen Haus versammeln um Empfehlungen zu geben dann ist er von denen der Wortführer also der höchste Militär und gleichzeitig wichtiger Berater des amerikanischen Präsidenten weil da gab es ja im Juni auch noch so ein paar,
naja wie soll man sagen Spin offs aus dieser Gesamtsituation.
Das ist so allgemein könne er jedes Jahr halten egal wer vor ihm sitzt da spricht er gar keinen an sondern es einfach nur allgemein um. Ihr seid hier immerhin Kanonenfutter.
Der.
Cambio.
Konnte er sich nicht verkneifen.
Ich habe auch wirklich darauf gewartet kommt noch China und es kommt selbstverständlich und es ist zugleich einfach nur so ein Grußwort. Es ist ein Grußwort was man so alles gerade ein bisschen aufgreift was da ist.
Es ist bescheuert.
So wirkt es zumindest. Und es ist wirklich so schlimm auch für die die sich für diesen Dienst entschieden haben dort sich den Kram anhören zu müssen.
Vor allem kriegen sie in dem Moment mit. Es geht zwar hier nicht um mich als Absolvent aber es geht um ihn und seinen persönlichen was auch immer er ausgerechnet mit China Endzone.
Jetzt sieht man im Bild auch schon einen Helikopter der rumsteht denn Trump hat natürlich ein Lieblingsthema vor dem Personal. Aber es gibt ja auch ein paar Sachen im Militär die ihn wirklich faszinieren.
Dass er das immer noch so mit Stolz sagt Während wir diese Serie jetzt alle schon geguckt haben und denken wahrscheinlich ist es nicht ganz so aufzuziehen.
Sodass wir jetzt nochmal Mike Penns und jetzt kommt Mike Millie. Der ist nun wirklich der höchste Militär dort. Der schickt die ganzen Leute los die dann in den Hubschrauber steigen und Amerika beschützen und so weiter.
Und wir achten Mal genau darauf welches Thema sucht er sich eigentlich aus.
Austrag.
Er beginnt.
Jede direkte Ansprache noch einmal Gott schütze jeden Einzelnen das sich auch nochmal angesprochen und rhetorisch sehr gut auch ordentlich vom Teleprompter abgelesen muss man sagen.
Und er sieht auch aus wie wie man sich das vorstellt. Das kann es nicht besser Carsten bei Hollywood. Es ist wirklich krass.
Ja.
Er entschied sich zu beginnen und die war wirklich nicht lang. üblicherweise reden die Präsidenten jetzt 20 Minuten und länger.
Das war ein kurzes Stück Das war vielleicht doppelt so lang wie es jetzt war.
Und er beginnt mit dieser Erinnerung ganz persönlich. Ich habe mit den Veteranen des Zweiten Weltkriegs gesprochen Normandy und so weiter.
Welche Lehre kann es für uns 8 Jahre später sagen Lass es niemals wieder passieren und dann betont er noch einmal diesen Moment diese historische Zäsur war der Beginn der Weltordnung wie wir sie jetzt haben.
Und dann endet er mit diesem und das ist unser Erbe das wir bis jetzt verteidigt haben und du hast dich hier bereit erklärt dein Leben im Zweifel dafür zu opfern dass du dieses Erbe dann auch weitergeben wirst.
Das überspannt natürlich jetzt schon Jahrhunderte dem Anspruch und schrumpft sozusagen seine Präsidentschaft Donald Trumps zusammen auf. Eigentlich spielt es gar keine Rolle.
Es ist völlig egal wer hier regiert und so weiter. Lasst euch nicht verunsichern von irgendeinem Typ der hier irgendwas und so weiter sondern wir als Militär Wir haben eine Aufgabe.
Es gibt eine Verfassung da steht drin alle sind gleich. Kann man ja noch mal überlegen inwieweit den Satz den er da jetzt gemacht hat auch nochmal eine direkte ein direktes Adressat sozusagen an diese Gemengelage ist.
Aber diese politische Dimension nimmt er da völlig raus und geht komplett auf die Verantwortung die historisch erwuchs sich als Erbe darstellt und dann auch weitergegeben werden muss.
Die Diplomatie so stark macht dass er das auch nochmal betont und dass er auch wenn er sagt er hat von den Veteranen erfahren dass das nie wieder geschehen.
Wir haben ja nun momentan darüber haben wir noch gar nicht gesprochen.
Kommt aber bestimmt noch. Ja auch ganz große diplomatische Verwerfungen mit Blick beispielsweise auf die Atombomben die es nun mal gibt die Aufrüstung die immer mehr stattfindet.
Und da gibt es ja ganz ganz große Bedenken dass sich in den nächsten paar Jahren noch entwickeln wird.
In den Blättern waren da ja jetzt schon zwei drei Aufsätze größere in diesem Jahr schon drin zu dieser Thematik.
Das wird hier auch nochmal angetippt und dann aber auch nochmal dieser direkte Bezug des,
Präsidenten haben der auf Ungleichheit setzt,
und er deshalb natürlich nochmal so stark herausstellt denn das wäre gar nicht so seine Hauptaufgabe das jetzt so zu betonen Das muss er nicht tun das könnte man eigentlich als bekannt voraussetzen.
Klarer Widerspruch gegen Trump dass er hier diesen Satz unterbringt. Diplomacy.
Während Trump gleichzeitig noch einmal aufzählt was sind eigentlich unsere Waffen die geilsten Flugzeuge die besten Hubschrauber und so weiter und wir machen Hunderte davon selbst Panzer.
Das ist schon interessant gerade im Hinblick was du sagst.
Nordkorea hat ja Kim Jong un jetzt tatsächlich dieses kleine Einreise Häuschen sprengen lassen was auch immer so als Foto Ort da galt wo sich die Soldaten wirklich Angesicht zu Angesicht gegenüberstanden Nord und Südkorea,
wo man sagen würde Da findet Diplomatie statt wenn sie denn stattfand hat ja auch schon den südkoreanischen Counterpart über die Stufe letztes Jahr gehoben und sich begrüßt.
Genau das fällt nämlich alles aus und deswegen legt man doch noch einmal Wert auf Diplomatie ist man jetzt Cabs in diesem Juni und zwar am ersten diesen Fotos dann von Trump.
Trump hält eine Rede im Rosengarten und sagt Ich nutze alle Mittel um mein Land hier zu befrieden.
Und dann ganz explizit würde ich darüber nachdenken das Militär reinzuholen auf dich auf die Straßen,
Szenen die wir ansonsten wirklich nur bei Christopher Nolan kennen wenn Gotham City bedroht ist und nach dieser kleinen Rede wo das Militär im Inland angekündigt hat ist er dann mit seinem Tross über die Straße,
zum Laffer Square gegangen um vor der Sankt Johns,
Episkopat Church eine Bibel in die Höhe zu halten und als er gefragt wurde Was ist das für eine Bibel der Bibel keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keinen Bezug zu dieser Bibel seit der Bibel und alle Welt hat sich gefragt was für ein Scheiß.
Was hat es damit auf sich wir kommen nachher ausführlich auf. Wollte er damit nochmal ein Zeichen an die religiösen Konservativen setzen ja oder nein ist ihm das gelungen.
Also sehr viel gerätselt was das so bedeutet und zu diesem Termin.
Der nun ein sehr politischer war denn diese Kirche steht da seit 1816 und seit James Madison dem vierten Präsidenten ist sie quasi mit jedem Präsidenten irgendwie verbunden.
Schon allein durch die Nähe des direkt neben dem Weißen Haus und Mac Millie war auch dabei.
Und mag es auch danach noch einmal durch Washington DC gelaufen.
Das ist nämlich der einzige Fleck in Amerika wo Trump tatsächlich Bürgermeister Befugnisse hat.
Überall sonst ist er außen vor und er sollte dann nochmal patrouillieren.
Also der höchste Militär Amerikas sollte nochmal durch die Straßen von Washington DC patrouillieren und hat sich dann abfilmen lassen und nochmal die Kamera gesagt,
alles ruhig alles gut macht euch keine Sorgen und ohne es mit dem Weißen Haus abzusprechen hat Marc Miley am elften am 11.
Juni diese Botschaft hier nochmal im gleichen Video Ramen wie schon diese Kommentare hier gegeben.
Zu
sein.
Also aus freien Stücken entschuldigt er sich dafür wirklich.
Es war ein Fehler sagt er bei diesem Fototermin dabeigewesen zu sein weil es einen falschen Eindruck darüber erweckt welche Rolle er und das gesamte Militär in der amerikanischen Innenpolitik hat.
Es muss nämlich unpolitisch sein.
Muss politisch unpolitisch genau und es war das allererste Mal dass wir kennen Trumps Affinität zu den Militärs Er hat sich noch bei den Militärs bedient als Stabschefs und so weiter.
Es war das allererste Mal dass.
Es ist das erste Mal dass wir eine direkte Kritik am Präsidenten über Bande mein eigenes Verhalten war falsch angeleitet vom Präsidenten sozusagen.
Es das erste Mal dass beide Ligapräsident über Bande Oberpfalz.
Und Trump hat nicht geschossen. Trump hat es erst einmal nicht auf Twitter wie er das bei.
Und Pacher nicht so geschlossen war hat es erst einmal nicht Beda. Das.
So gemacht hat da gesagt das ist ja ein ganz schlimmer Finger und er hat mich schon immer verraten sondern da hat er wirklich mal den Schwanz eingezogen und hat man ihm gesagt er reagiere nicht.
Ist ja ein ganz schlimmer. Tja da hat man den Schwanz eingezogen oder nicht schweige darüber jetzt.
Schweige darüber mag Meli hat hier ein Statement gemacht.
Und da kann man schon mal sehen dass ein paar Fäden zerrissen sind zwischen Militär und Weißem Haus also vielleicht ein ganz ganz wichtiger Monat.
Nicht nur was Präsident Trump betrifft sondern auch was das Militär eigentlich aus seiner Erfahrung nach Trumps Präsidentschaft für Lehren zieht.
Man darf nicht vergessen Wir nehmen natürlich wenn wir von US-Militär sprechen das immer so als Einheit wahr die irgendwo in fremden Ländern eine Invasion macht oder vielleicht doch eine Rettungsmission durchführt oder was weiß ich.
Aber das Militär hat auch eine große integrative Kraft in der Gesellschaft für Schwarze.
Das zeigt im übrigen sogar der schreckliche Film Paul Haber dass dort ein schwarzer integriert wird.
Angesichts der Katastrophe.
Das Militär ist nicht nur Russe sondern hätte auch wirklich eine identitätsstiftende Kraft und diese,
Homogenität die man dadurch erreicht dass man Angehöriger des Militärs ist das man,
sich als Gemeinschaft zu einem Land zugehörig wahrnimmt ist nicht zu unterschätzen das heißt wenn da bürgerkriegsähnliche Zustände von einem Präsidenten produziert werden dann kann das nicht im Interesse des Militärs sein.
Genau und das bettet sich innen in eine Diskussion die der Juraprofessor Lawrence Douglas und andere angestoßen haben,
beispielsweise in einem SpiegelOnline Gespräch das heißt auf Deutsch einfach Was wenn Trump nach Wahlniederlage das Feld nicht räumt.
Da gibt es ja auch ein Paar. Und es geht tatsächlich auf eine geführte Diskussion zurück.
Da gibt's auch Publikationen Hugo Trump an den Lemming Election melt down also man macht sich Sorgen dass es zum Beispiel ein Titel in einer Fachzeitschrift publiziert.
Hachette irgendwas keine Ahnung. New York 2020. Und da geht es richtig juristisch diskutiert.
Wie weit kann es Trump jetzt treiben mit der Ablehnung von Briefwahl zum Beispiel.
Angenommen es ist im November wirklich was Corona angeht und alle werden aufgerufen per Briefwahl zu wählen.
Wie geht man mit diesem Ergebnis dann um. Wenn dann Trump sagt Ich erkenne das gar nicht an dass ich hier mit zwei Prozent verloren habe oder so weil so eine Briefwahl gewesen,
werden da Diskussionen geführt aber ich glaube man muss keine Angst davor haben dass mag Miley sich jetzt auf die Seite von Trump schlägt oder so Die Gefahr ist jetzt im Juli gebannt das haben wir ganz deutlich gesehen.
Das war eine ganz deutliche Ansage so die Präsidenten a. D.
Nenne ich sie mal auch wenn es weiteren Vorkommen die natürlich noch Ambitionen haben.
Ganz klar Joe Biden aber eben auch Michelle Obama habe ich auch mal mit einsortiert. Wer weiß ist ja noch jung.
Vorher allerdings Bill Clinton und Obama.
Und Bill Clinton muss man sagen sitzt vor einem Regal Dutzend Bücher und auch noch CDs und es hat wirklich so etwas aus den Neunzigern.
Man könnte auch vorstellen dass da hinten so eine Best of Bruce Springsteen oder so steht es ist ein bisschen.
Nicht. Man kann sich ja nicht immer weiterentwickeln irgendwann muss auch mal Schluss sein mit diesen Neuerungen.
Obama und Clinton jedenfalls ist sehr düster Das kann man nicht anders sagen und beiden rettet es dann auch nicht unbedingt.
Dass wir jetzt die Präsidenten in einem Ton Ton indem wir sie jetzt hören hat mich doch ein bisschen erschüttert.
Birgit Achievement ist kann es manchmal sein.
Aber.
Wie.
Cronenbergs.
Wenn man sagt Charlotte Kampfdrohne,
George W.
Eben bevor die Fabrik,
in der Weiße,
Haus schon sehr.
Informationssystems.
Für ihr Nein na tdw.
Auch der Support Na.
Benes.
Das ist wirklich an Hoffnungslosigkeit nicht zu überbieten. Insgesamt.
So traurig wenn man bedenkt man ist jung und hört sich eine solche Rede an Willkommen in der Gegenwart jetzt kommt deine Zukunft die Welt wartet nicht auf dich.
Schlappe.
Ich habe herausgehört irgendwie so ich bin. Ich weiß was wir angerichtet haben.
Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht weiter. Good luck.
Ja ja genau so auch aus dem Bunker raus. Wir ziehen uns jetzt hier zurück Bill Clinton sieht ja unfassbar alt aus.
Das ist ja unglaublich wie kraftlose da sitzt und Obama versucht sich noch so an einem irgendwie.
Das kommt noch dazu.
Jugendlichen Witz einen Bezug zu Teige King um nochmal zu zeigen Ja ich bin eigentlich noch einer von euch. Aber nee es nicht.
Aber irgendwie Ja das ist schon ein Beselich trübsinnig. Jetzt haben Joe Biden und Joe Biden,
soll man sagen hat ja schlimme persönliche Erfahrung gemacht durch Todesfälle in der Familie und so weiter.
Auch kürzlich jetzt wieder mit seinem Sohn und Joe Biden gilt eigentlich als derjenige der über diese Erfahrung wenn er darüber spricht so eine Art Spieler ist der so ein Land auch heilen kann weil er den richtigen Ton trifft.
Die Frage ist nur ist er eigentlich so ein bisschen aufs Positives motivierende.
Ist das der richtige Zeitpunkt dass der richtige die richtige Situation oder die Abwägung die man diesem Team dann auch macht.
Gehen wir es trotzdem all in Was das angeht und nutzen die Situation eigentlich falsch.
Es ist ganz komisch denn ich fand das war natürlich wieder so ein berührendes Ding wie er es vorträgt aber ich fand es in der Situation völlig unangemessen.
Ein auf.
Chaos Peepshow Saville Amor Rehse.
Gürteltiere.
Eine Grabrede.
Sagt man wenn man mindestens 100 000 im Krieg verloren hat.
Dieses Framing ist wirklich bedrückend.
GWA.
Frommes.
Evil,
Lively Justus,
Jonas,
Horw.
Ecevits.
Der obligatorische Appell und ansonsten viel schlechte Stimmung.
Sehr sehr schlechte Stimmung. Es ist ein bisschen so wie das was,
mein Podcast Kollege mir kürzlich sagte seine Generation 22 hat eigentlich nie so gesagt bekommen und da erwartete ich was Tolles bald sondern immer noch reichen wird ob das noch gehen wird.
Sagte seine Generation.
Weiß.
Und das drückt sich jetzt hier noch einmal im besonderen Maße aus beiden ist extrem gruselig.
Sicherlich auch ich darf diese Bemerkung erlauben irgendwie mit diesem Gesicht zusammenhängen Ich weiß nicht was da passiert was da gemacht wird.
Ein bisschen stabilisiert. Ich.
Das hat aber offenbar noch nicht zum Thema gemacht was kommt wahrscheinlich noch.
Weiß das kommt alles noch in die heiße Phase.
Die Politiker hier sind.
Die Politiker hier sind nicht besonders. Wie auch immer auch der Satz ist das Leiden stiftet den Sinn.
Ja sagt man 18jährigen das Leiden stiftet den Sinn.
Aber es steckt da ja,
eigentlich nicht deren Sicht ist das schon ziemlich Banane. Ich habe mal zwei kleine Trekkies und zwar Sundar Pichai und Tim Cook also Google und Apple Chefs.
Die Reden waren wirklich überwiegend sinnlos auch wenn ich nochmal anmerken konnte biografisch.
Ich komme aus Indien Wir hatten nicht mal fließend Wasser. Ich kam nach Amerika das war mein erster Cumbia mit 20 und so weiter.
Biografisch kann natürlich immer was retten aber das muss man sich gar nicht alles anhören wir hören nur mal die Topspeed.
Mehr.
Tim Cook Ihr habt euch euer Schicksal nicht selbst ausgesucht. Aber es ist trotzdem euer Glück.
Vielleicht nicht ganz verkehrt Ja aber es ist halt auch.
Auch eigenartig. Da kennt man ja von Teck Gurus auch anderes die ja sonst jede App einem verkaufen als sei das jetzt die große Rettung der Welt. Und jetzt zugesagt naja schaut mal was er draus macht.
Noch einmal so fühlen sich unsere YouTube Kreiter sitzen vor einer Kamera und quatschen irgendwas.
Naja Highlight mäßig allerdings doch das Finale hier mit Alan die grandiose Scheiße abgeliefert aber das verstehe ich auch ein bisschen weil sie ist.
Das Finale hier mit Elan hier grandiose Scheiße abgeliefert aber das verstehe ich auch weil sie es halt.
Sie kommt nicht aus diesem graduierte oder so. Sondern sie ist da so reingewachsen irgendwie überdehnen was wir in Deutschland so nennen die Realschule oder wie auch immer da wo man.
Und man kann froh sein können froh sein dass es hier ein Podcast ist Man muss sich nicht im Bademantel sehen was wir tun.
Die Rede die sie gerade war so richtig scheiße und ich hab noch einen besseren Auszug der sogar noch eine ganz witzige Pointe hat aber trotzdem zeigt wie,
sie so ein bisschen an dem allgemeinen dümmeren und an einem Thema vorbei gesprochen hat das war so richtig arrogant daneben und danach war allerdings Konan und Arnold Schwarzenegger Conan O'Brien und Arnold Schwarzenegger und die haben beide,
den Ton finde ich ganz gut getroffen. Insgesamt.
Right.
He he he he he.
Birst Harry Geldmärkte Thüring.
Eine Frau.
In der Hand.
An einem Stand bei.
Einer Lawine kam in Live Gebärde You keimende Krages SNES.
Bei Tourist He,
scuola.
Wir.
Es
muss polarisieren eines Staates,
wie Generationen bei der US.
Regulations diese Glasow träumt die träumt einem notgelandet hier im Buch des Binge sich Tante Kriegsrat mehr der Hausding u.a.
Slow Erbstücke in Japan und den Young People Have Real Bikes wie sie in Amerika.
Die bekannteste Pippo happy mit der Charb Night,
Badezimmertür besonders der Biobranche wie der WüRG evidente Gildo Bourg der Happy,
Theropoden you baby part of Statistik ist die Sastre Joa die Kinskis japsen Vorkehrung.
Bei Hua wird Rises in the face of diversity eine Marchese Rojas Groves The Great empörende Gladiator Movie of the greatest Meinzer Mongole.
Markus Gladiators.
Und Ambros Wotans bekam 2 back in Dallas vor.
Am Ende des Struggle der die Venstre Käthes die Greno,
der Neides befeuerte Test der Essays der Tupac zum Kaffee,
das Tadić Clubs der Begierde und die keimende Gelde des Stade de Garde in Streugut gerne dosierter Texte die Remember manches Destillerie,
beleidigende schöne Detail Nadjas piece of paper der die hängender,
Vilma Yolo Listening God bless America in Tables O Ruderclub Hasta la vista.
Herausragend also Schwarzenegger.
Er
Bald eine Pensen.
Wunderbar und dann tritt er noch in kurzen Hosen oder in Bermudas dahinter am Rednerpult hervor. Er ist extrem gut. Alles was er sagt ist wirklich so mutig.
Genau das nämlich auszusprechen 70 Prozent der Menschen unglücklich in ihren Jobs sind dazu sagen zu sagen Ich will eigentlich nicht dass ihr dazu gehört zu dieser Gruppe.
Und das ist ja eben das was eigentlich denen allen droht.
Und das so auszusprechen und mit diesem Humor und auch das Persönliche. Besser kann man es nicht.
Ja gerade nochmal der Verweis auf Klarheit ist dieser Tage wo ich dann zu euch spreche oder euch Besucher je nachdem auf der Bühne stehe.
Aber eigentlich geht es auch hier um den Abschluss von so einer Etappe im Leben und da muss man doch mal genau sich die Details angucken was da Spaß gemacht und was nicht.
Und so wie man da irgendwie zusammen geklappt hat um sich auf Prüfungen vorzubereiten kann man ja auch.
Das Schicksal annehmen und sagen Ja dann bin ich halt nicht in dem Ausbildungsberuf den ich wollte sondern in dem anderen und da sind aber trotzdem Handlungsmöglichkeiten um das irgendwie für alle angenehmer zu machen.
Da steckt noch ein gewisser Arbeitsauftrag drin der doch ein bisschen konkreter ist dieses allgemeine motivierender Ja und irgendwann später wird sich auszahlen sondern nimm doch einmal die Herausforderung morgen schon an anstatt,
diesen großen Plan zu haben und dann baut sich halt auch Enttäuschung auf was man ja von so großen Plänen in jeder Hinsicht ziemlich gut.
Ich fand auch bei Konan diesen kleinen.
Wir haben ja beide jetzt auch hier richtige Pointen am Ende gesalzene er mit seiner Hose im Sinne von.
Für mich ist das Home-Office trägt man keine Hose. Und jetzt ist aber auch die Rede vorbei und bei Cone nochmal dieses Ja das hier ist mein Garten was ja gerade dieses große Anwesen.
Und egal wie toll ich euch jetzt motiviere. Es geht nicht so weit dass ihr mir hier irgendwann mal irgendwas wegnehmen sollte wenn ihr in meinem Garten dann steht es soweit gebracht hat wie ich dann rufe ich die Polizei und schmeiße ich wieder raus.
Und das ist ein sehr ehrlicher Punkt wie auch nochmal dieser schmerzhafte Hinweis für die Eltern.
Ja diese Ausbildung war sehr teuer und am Ende war es wie bei der Fernuni Hagen.
Die Stunden saßen zu Hause Arbeitsblatt ausgefüllt und klar Am Ende steht Hava drauf weil sonst was.
Aber ob das jetzt sich so ausgezahlt hat.
Was soll man sagen. Lieber möchte ich lieber so jemanden hier als nächsten Präsidenten vielleicht als jemanden der so um Worte ringend und dann in seinem Schema bleibt.
Joe Biden Joe Biden Joe Biden Naja das waren jedenfalls,
im zweiten Halbjahr wird sich ja zeigen wieviel Motivation man braucht und wie schlimm die Sachlage dann wirklich ist in einer Gesellschaft.
Mal gucken wen wir denn da wieder zurückblickend.
Intro/Outro
Wir wollen anschauen. Wir sind ja eifrige Twitterer.
Man findet sie dann nicht mehr wenn man etwas Interessantes zu getwittert und.
Alle 7 Tage.
Ich habe eigentlich ein Twitter Archiv über Bord jeden Tweet den ich mache und jeder Ich gebe wird da eigentlich gespeichert.
Und Magdas.
Und als Du mich gestern gefragt hast war nochmal der Tweet im Juni da anfangen.
Da konnte man sehen Es ist ausgeschaltet und ich wusste auch warum.
Nachdem es ausgeschaltet. Ich wusste nach Europa ich habe mich ankleiden oder Tweets.
Ich habe gestern wieder angeschaltet und seitdem ist meine Pinnwand Liste voller Tweets weil ich zu viel twittere.
Ich komme nicht mehr. Ich kann über die Texte immer noch zu meinen anderen Sachen die ich mir so weggepackt habe kommen.
Die Liste ist voller Tweets aber ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal an für den Fall.
Ich bin aber gespannt wie du jetzt mit der neuen Errungenschaft umgehen wirst. Wir hören vielleicht mal rein also Twitter hab da was verkündet.
In dem Blog haben Sie verkündet was sie jetzt uns Neues anbieten wollen.
Ich habe das mal eingelesen aus diesem Statement.
Twitter ist der Ort an den man sich begibt um über das Geschehen zu sprechen.
Aber manchmal reichen 280 Zeichen nicht aus und einige Nuancen der Konversationen gehen in der übersetzung verloren.
Es gibt vieles was mit Text ungesagt oder interpretierbar bleiben kann.
Daher hoffen wir dass das twitterten mit der Stimme eine menschlichere Erfahrung für Zuhörer und Geschichtenerzähler gleichermaßen schafft.
Ganz gleich ob es sich um Story Time über ihre Begegnung mit Wild Gänsen in ihrer Nachbarschaft,
um einen Journalisten der Eilmeldungen austauscht oder um einen Bericht aus erster Hand von einem Protest handelt.
Wir hoffen dass Beust Whiting ihnen die Möglichkeit gibt ihre Sichtweise schnell und einfach mit ihrer Stimme zu teilen.
Wir sind gespannt wie die Menschen dies nutzen werden um ihrer Stimme Gehör zu verschaffen und die öffentliche Diskussion zu bereichern.
Ist es eine Bereicherung.
Ich bin noch unschlüssig. Ehrlich gesagt ich habe auch noch wenig gesehen in meiner Timeline scheinen noch nicht viele machen zu können ich zum Beispiel auch nicht. Eine.
Ich auch nicht. Ich habe dir aber gleich eine mitgebracht um mal zu sehen und vielleicht schon mal ein bisschen das Spektrum zu zeigen was uns da drohen könnte.
Ich wollte uns auch mal eine vorspielen.
Denn es ist tatsächlich so dass selbstverständlich erst einmal die prominenten Twitterer in aller Welt haben jetzt diesen Zugang bekommen und du hast jetzt einen Politiker. Ich vermute das wird ein bisschen seriöser sein als das was ich dir.
Vergleichen.
Jetzt gibt's ja neues zu vergleichen. Wenn man plötzlich so viel da ist wird ja sehr viel mehr transportiert als einfach nur so ein Text Buchstaben.
Es gab einen da. Da habe ich gedacht dafür ist vielleicht ganz gut den habe ich leider nicht mehr gefunden um jetzt vorzuspielen hat nämlich eine Journalistin die Chance genutzt um mal alle darauf hinzuweisen wie ihr Name ausgesprochen wird weil das immer falsch ist.
Da geht es schon los das ist ein echter Nutzwert weil man dann oben an und dann ist gut. Ich hab hier noch einen anderen gefunden.
Bei Twitter Community Social Media Team hat mir gerade erzählt dass ich jetzt hier auch direkt zu Ihnen sprechen kann.
Darüber denke ich noch nach. Es geht auf alle Fälle schneller als schreiben mir miteinander. Auf jeden Fall ein tranchieren.
Van der Bellen der österreichische Bundespräsident weiß noch nicht genau ob es ein Vorteil gibt.
Aber es ist schon mal schneller als schreiben. Das finde ich interessant denn eine Klarsicht schreiben.
Welche Tipp denn bitte noch seine Tweets. Ich habe mich ganz häufig dabei dass ich einfach diktiere.
In der Hinsicht ist nämlich ja ist ja sozusagen die Sprache als Eingabe Methode schon recht etabliert.
Wir hören jetzt mal von HdB den ersten Tweet KDP ist eine sehr bekannte Popsängerin und hat selbstverständlich auch viele viele Follower bei,
Twitter und ist so ein Superstar eher für die jüngere Generation.
Aber da jetzt mal rein was uns mit diesen Tweets auch drohen kann.
Ein neues zurücklag.
Ist sehr Diskurs bereichert. Das wird glaube ich das sein was wir am meisten da erleben das wir schon ganz viel Unsinn da bekommen.
Man wird doch so schon bei Twitter extrem zugemüllt mit schrecklichsten Banalitäten das jeder gerade schreibt jetzt ist mir ein Glas Wasser umgefallen.
Jetzt hab ich dies und das gemacht. Wir werden ja wirklich mit diesen permanenten Alltäglichkeiten die ich überhaupt in meinem Alltag lebe das ist ja etwas was ich eigentlich abstreifen will.
Das finde ich aber dann alles bei Twitter wieder und werde permanent damit belästigt und ich glaube durch die Stimme und durch diesen Effekt dass man dann losschickt wird sich das vermutlich.
Bei dem Beispiel stellt sich schon die Frage Warum hat er das jetzt gemacht. Ich habe es noch nicht so ganz verstanden.
Irgendwie hat auch lange versucht so Videos zu machen haben sie über Periscope diese Möglichkeit dann wie bei Instagram.
Versucht so Videos zu machen.
Die bei.
Weniger erstaunlich. Man muss ja nur nach links also ins linke Feld nach rechts wischen und dann ist man auch in so einer Video-Aufnahmen Situation.
Und jetzt plötzlich was ja nun eigentlich total weit entfernt ist von dem was Twitter ausmacht dieses schnelle durchs scrollen nur auf Hashtags gucken und dann vielleicht mein Tweet lesen.
Haben Sie auch angefangen mit dem Hinweis wird es ja nicht nochmal den Link erst einmal anklicken bevor der Tweet ist.
Also eigentlich ist Text schon zu viel für Twitter-Nutzer. Denkt man sich manchmal wenn man so schaut und sich Sekunden lange Nachrichten anhören.
Eigentlich schon zu viel.
Was ja gleich wieder passiert ist dass Twitter Text auf Instagram Bild geworden funktioniert.
Stimmt.
Man hat ja jetzt das Phänomen dass Leute ihre Tweets spiegeln bei Instagram und bei Instagram wesentlich erfolgreicher als bei Twitter sind.
Also ich hatte ja selbst schon mal überlegt ob ich vielleicht doch noch zu Instagram gehen soll denn es ist ja nun mal so dass Instagram 20 Millionen.
Nutzer.
Nutzer hat in Deutschland Twitter hat glaube ich 1,4 Millionen weniger Aktive.
Weniger aktive.
Und das frage ich mich ob das durch diese Geschichten besser wird.
Und das in doppelter Geschwindigkeit abzuspielen,
habe ich die Möglichkeit dann auch über Hashtags mit mir in irgendeiner Weise organisieren zu können oder folge ich dann wieder nur den Leuten die ich denen ich ohnehin deren Nachrichten mit.
Denn das ist ja der große Vorteil bei Twitter dass ich schnell unter einem speziellen Hashtag mal etwas nachschauen kann wenn es nicht gerade zu den zehn Trends gehört.
Das ist aber eigentlich wieder eine neue Unübersichtlichkeit die dadurch entsteht.
Nun ja es ist auch ein bisschen verrückt denn Twitter ist ja super langsam mit der neuen Entwicklung von irgendwas.
Diese Ausdehnung von 140 auf 280 Zeichen hat ja fünf Jahre gedauert und ewige Diskussionen und so weiter.
Und wenn du jetzt sagst du nutzt das so sehr Hashtag getrieben so Hashtags weil der,
Jack Dorsey wollte ja eigentlich schon immer dass man auch bei Instagram geht das Hashtags folgen kann man einfach den Hashtag Niente sagt dir folge ich jetzt wie einer Person.
Aber man kann weiterhin immer nur Personen folgen selbst wenn so Sachen mit denen sie wirklich lange schwanger gehen und das auch gut begründen wo die Funktionalität ist.
Das kommt einfach nicht auf die Plattform. Und dieses Ding irgendwie von heute auf morgen. Das wurde gar nicht groß angekündigt diskutiert.
Vielleicht verschwindet es auch wieder. Ich habe es noch nicht groß jetzt gesehen dass es genutzt wird und ich frage mich auch wie soll man es konsumieren doppelte Geschwindigkeit wäre schon einmal sehr gut.
Das ist ja bei Telegram zum Beispiel eingebaut wenn man da so Gruppen ist.
Bei Telekom.
Weil Telegram. Ich bin wirklich erstaunt spektakulär guter Messenger ist.
Nutzt es als Messenger-App privat finde ich eine Möglichkeit nochmal publizistisch zu sein oder.
Schon mehr für die Gruppen Ne ne,
gar nicht sondern einfach nur so um Kontakt zu halten mit dem ein oder anderen auch ganz witzig ich habe,
gestern auch nochmal mich dann nur mit der Podcast Audio Kommentar Nummer nochmal bei Telegram angemeldet da ploppen sofort 80 90 Anfragen und so weiter war sofort voll.
Nicht denn nur mit der Audio. Kommentar Nr.
80 90 so weiter verfolgen.
Meine Kontakte mit irgendwelchen Sachen und so weiter.
Mit irgendwelchen.
Da ist schon ganz schön viel Leben insgesamt und es macht wirklich Spaß ihn zu benutzen weil einfach sehr viel besser. WhatsApp ist ein scheiß dagegen.
Es macht wirklich Spaß. Sehr viel besser als.
Man fragt sich wirklich warum WhatsApp weil Lattmann Sprachnachrichten wird man oben auf der Geschwindigkeit rauschen ja in doppelter Geschwindigkeit durch und das ist auch genau so wie man es braucht.
Und das heißt es ist nicht nur der Hort für vegane kochst die durchgedreht sind.
Nee nee nee nee nee nee nee also klar auch solche Gruppen gibt es auch.
Aber ich hab das auch lange assoziiert Telegram ist ja die Schmuddelecke und so weiter.
Ich habe ja.
Es ist tatsächlich ein sehr funktionaler App bei der sehr viele Hörer dich so ein bisschen Lose aus was ich höre dass beide alle gleich irgendwie cool und so was ja und dann kann es ja so einstellen.
Sehr viele Lose aus Wasser sind doch alle gleich irgendwie so einstellen.
Jeder darf mich dann gleich so einzubilden auch aus.
Jeder darf mich in alle Gruppen hinzufügen. So habe ich dann selber wieder aus.
Dadurch bleibt es dann gleich so als so eine Kommunikations Blase auf fast wie Twitter eigentlich ja wo immer was los ist.
Und wer weiß von welcher Seite Aussicht da jetzt bedroht fühlt man weiß es nicht.
Na
ja wir machen gerade etwas was man auch hört und was länger als 140 Sekunden gehen wird.
Vermutlich deshalb kann man sich jetzt schon fragen Wie verändert denn auch das jetzt vielleicht nur in einem kleinen Maße das Internet.
Hat sich das ja schon extrem verändert. Nochmal ganz kurz zurück und überlegen mal was überhaupt die Stimme so bewirken kann was die Stimme eigentlich ist.
Ich hab hier mal einen kurzen Auszug aus einer Rede von Hitler die er gehalten hat für ihn war selbstverständlich die Stimme auch etwas ganz Entscheidendes um politisch erfolgreich zu sein.
Ich habe schon überlegt wenn Hitler in der Liste steht also Hitler ist jetzt 75 Jahre tot wenn er tot ist.
Wenn er damals wirklich tot ist und es gibt ja.
Da merkt man nur was schon so lange auf Telegraf.
Diese 8 Jahre. Ich habe Moritz dem Professor hier im Süden Manheim glaube ich Sorry Moritz an der Stelle Ich habe in Mannheim auch.
Moritz Klenk.
Moritz Klenk genau hier gut bekannte Wort Gasblase auch schon mal vor einer Weile gefragt Was hat jetzt mit Stimme aufsich Was kann man kulturell dazu sagen. Ich meine Hitler liegt dann wirklich auf der Hand.
Ok Irgendwas ist mit der Stimme und er hat mir ein paar Sachen geschickt und ich wollte mal eins das Handbuch interkulturelle Germanistik,
herausgegeben von so und so ist es doch hier ganz interessant wie wenig man eigentlich über die Stimme weiß Hier steht z.B.
Als Instrument der Selbstdarstellung und Kontaktaufnahme stellt die Stimme einen entscheidenden Faktor aller Realität Ebenen von Verständigungen Prozessen dar.
Das ist schon mal ein wahnsinniger Satz weil die Stimme Selbstdarstellung.
Wie präsentiere ich mich und Contact Name wie ich nehme ich Kontakt auf.
Und es betrifft alle realitätsfernen. Das ist ein Satz der deckt einfach alles ab stellt also unglaubliche Forschungsfragen in den Raum.
Also auch realitätsnäher von Verständigungen Prozessen da denn Wirkung und überzeugungskraft eines Menschen hängen in hohem Maße von seiner Stimme ab.
Okay dann blättert man weiter in einem anderen Text steht dann drin.
Die Stimme als Trägerin und Vermittlerin emotionaler Schattierungen wurde zwar emotional durch Literaturen Literaten und Wissenschaftler des 19.
Jahrhunderts erkannt und gewürdigt doch wurde gerade das Emotionale das rührende das wissenschaftliches Interesse anlockte,
in einer zunehmend positivistisch dominierten Wissenschafts Produktion Wissensproduktion mehr und mehr ausgeblendet,
in einer sich kommen kompatibler zentralisieren denn jeder macht sein eigenes Department.
Wissenschaftslandschaft ist es außerdem besonders schwierig ein Phänomen wie Emotionen empirisch analytisch anzusiedeln.
Man weiß Stimme ist super wichtig und man weiß auch so richtig was darüber sagen kann wann ich eine richtige Wissenschaft dazu gibt's nicht.
Es gibt dann machen wir vielleicht doch noch mit dem Hitler Zitat Es gibt tatsächlich in den Theaterwissenschaften sehr viele überlegungen schon zu stimmen denn man spricht ja da auch sehr viel über Liwni.
Das sind die Momente in denen die Stimme dann sofort im Raum erklingt und wir aber auch die Präsenz eines Körpers haben.
Zugleich haben wir sehr viele Theaterformen die mit Mikroprozessor arbeiten.
Das ist ja auch etwas was früher beim Theater wiederum tabu war dass man dort mit einem Mikrofon arbeitete.
Das hat sich jetzt wieder gewandelt mit Stimme wird dann noch einmal auf eine andere Weise gearbeitet und man hat auch erkannt dass man eben mit dieser Stimme auch eine performativ produziert.
Das heißt also die Stimme selbst ist auch wiederum etwas was etwas verändert im Raum.
Es ist nicht einfach nur hier Text wird gesprochen und es gibt einen Band der ist bei Suhrkamp erschienen vor 15 Jahren.
Der heißt einfach Stimme herausgegeben von Doris Kolek und Sibylle Krämer und die haben diesen Band eben so konzipiert dass sie aus ganz verschiedenen Blickrichtungen.
Drauf schauen was eigentlich die Stimme ist z.B.
In der Oper die Stimme Charakterisierungen aus linguistischer Perspektive Es geht um Tierstimmen Es geht aber eben auch um Stimmen ohne Körper.
Thomas Macho hat da einen Aufsatz zugeschrieben das laut werdender Stimme die Präsenz der Stimme was sie auf jeden Fall sagen ist dass es so etwas gibt wie eine Rehabilitierung der Stimme in den Geisteswissenschaften.
Es gab ja einen sehr starken Fokus auf die Schrift in der Psychoanalyse Zwar wurde dort erzählt aber es gab doch auch einen ganz starken Fokus auf die auf die Schrift,
der Poststrukturalismus hat selbstverständlich die Schrift auch ganz ganz wichtig genommen.
Es gibt von Derrida auch so eine berühmte Schrift über die Stimme.
Und da kann man eben sagen Er unterscheidet zwischen dem literarischen und dem verbal geäußerten.
Und das ist sicherlich auch verknüpft mit dem was du da schon in deinem Zitat angesprochen hast.
Mit dem positivistischen dass man die Schrift anders auswertet.
Ja man kann es nicht Operationalisierung. Man kann es transkribieren und alles möglich damit machen was man so hört.
Aber darüber hinaus ist halt einfach Sense.
Gerade wenn man so Sozialwissenschaften studiert kriegt man ja schon mal diese Methoden Apparat wie transkribiert man eigentlich wenn es nicht nur auf das Gesprochene ankommt sondern auch darüber hinaus wie macht man so geht man mit Pausen um abgebrochenen Worten und so weiter.
Aber das kann man nicht sehr weit treiben.
Entweder man hat das Dokument da Hitler zum Beispiel Ja man hört ihn oder man kann nicht darüber reden um was es da geht.
Wir haben sind weil Wissen in Wahlkämpfen wo wir über Donald Trump auf der Bühne uns immer noch wundern.
Er möchte unbedingt zurück auf die Bühne diese große Rede halten und so weiter.
Und wir kennen von Obama auch dieses Reden vor Publikum leise aber pathetisch während das Publikum grölt.
Jeder normale Mensch wird der Anfang ins Mikro zu brüllen weil er glaubt er ist nicht er wird nicht verstanden.
Obama konnte das immer perfekt mit dieser Akustik insgesamt umgehen und seine Stimme eben auch darauf diese Pointen von solchen Reden dann wirklich präzise zu setzen.
Und es gibt nichts davon wenn man diese YouTube-Videos wie Donald Trump spricht dann hat man so einen Ausschnitt,
sehe ich Er sitzt irgendwie in so einer Talkshow oder so und da kommt so ein Zitat Dann wird das Zitat sofort schriftlich eingeblendet und dann läuft einfach somit im Text wo man gerade ist und das war's.
Diese inhaltliche O'Keefe benutzt Worte für Fünfjährige oder so..
Aber darüber hinaus kommt einfach nichts. Und es ist wirklich erstaunlich wie sehr ich würde auch sagen in der Sozialwissenschaft hat sich der Körper jetzt so richtig Raum verschafft da hat der Körper und der Raum so richtig präsent als Thema Stimme weiterhin,
nichts so Inspirator.
Aufarbeitung von irgendwas aber ansonsten.
In den Theaterwissenschaften und alles was da so mit dranhängt Musikwissenschaftler selbstverständlich immer schon die Stimme aber auch da ist es natürlich schwierig das Lexikon anzulegen gibt es inzwischen auch,
Sänger Lexika und so.
Aber es ist tatsächlich noch ein Feld wo noch viel zu tun ist und gerade mit Blick auf den Podcast wie sich unsere Wahrnehmung von Stimme verändert.
Auch dass wir nicht präsent sind trotzdem mit uns herumtragen Wir sind aber präsent hören aber andere Stimmen als die die uns gegenüberstehen weil wir die Kopfhörer drauf haben.
Es gab ja schon diesen Essay der Walkman Effekt von Hosokawa Das war aber eher darauf bezogen dass man Musik hört und dann in einem Raum sich befindet.
Aber jetzt haben wir eben ganz klar rein Hitler Rede die kein Original ist sondern ich habe mich angesprochen aber nicht als Parodie.
Ihr habt einst die Stimme eines Mannes vernommen und sie schlug an eure Herzen. Sie hat euch geweckt und ihr seid dieser Stimme gefolgt.
Ihr seid ihr Jahre lang nachgegangen ohne den Träger der Stimme auch nur gesehen zu haben. Ihr habt nur eine Stimme gehört und seid ihr gefolgt.
Hitler hat ja anfangs versucht es zu vermeiden fotografiert zu werden hat aber schon sehr viele Reden gehalten und diese Stimme war tatsächlich schon eher da bevor man das Gesicht dazu hatte das kann man sich heute gar nicht mehr so vorstellen.
Womit Hitler Probleme hatte war mit dem Radio.
Selbstverständlich wissen wir dass der Volksempfänger ganz entscheidend auch dafür war dass die Nazis sich eben auch ideologisch immer wieder an jeden einzelnen wenden konnten aber,
er hat keine Radio Aufzeichnungen gemacht man hat das einmal probiert es hat nicht richtig funktioniert.
Man brauchte man brauchte also die Resonanz des Publikums Man brauchte den brüllenden Hitler,
der dann auch sofort eine Resonanz bekommt und diese Resonanz ist dann eigentlich wieder Konserven lachen bei Sitcoms dass man schon weiß wie man sich dazu zu verhalten hat nämlich Lachen,
gibts dann auch dort schon vom Publikum dem Einzelnen zu Hause signalisiert wie er sich verhalten soll.
Deswegen hat man immer darauf gesetzt dass einige andere Politiker gemacht haben sich ins Studio begeben und dort angesprochen.
Das sieht man jetzt bei Trump wieder. Die Ansprache Medien vermittelt an ein Publikum zu Hause funktioniert gar nicht.
Der schlechteste Vorleser von irgendwelchen Teleprompter Texten.
Aber dieses live vor Publikum dargebotene und dann wiederum dokumentierte. Und da sitzt man dann sozusagen als Publikum auf zweiter Ebene dabei. Funktioniert wunderbar es ist da da sieht man wieder wie so eine Dynamik funktioniert.
Und das könnte man ja dann schon so sagen weil die Stimme in dem einen Fall anders benutzt wird als in dem anderen also wenn man einfach vor Publikum steht und mit jemandem spricht und dann auch reagiert dann ist das doch eine andere Nutzung von Stimme.
Also dieses bedächtige am Schreibtisch eigentlich ein Selbstgespräch mit einer Kamera und so.
Und es funktioniert einfach nicht es gibt wieder ganz andere Präsidenten da hat es wieder super funktioniert.
George Bush den Vater George Bush zum Beispiel vor die Kamera zu setzen.
Das war immer staatstragend ohne Ende. Wenn er so gesprochen hat das klappt dann halt bei.
Churchill Radioansprache gehalten hat das war auch ganz ganz fundamental aber da muss man auch die Stimme haben.
Wir sprechen immer von Inklusion. Man muss natürlich auch erkennen dass es ganz viele Dinge gibt die etwas was man nicht unterschätzen sollte.
Das hat sich sicherlich auch gewandelt. Radio taugliche Stimme ist auch sehr abhängig von kultureller Prägung was man gerne hört.
Es gab ja beispielsweise auch diese Studie von Maria Furtwängler darüber wie überhaupt Frauen im Fernsehen repräsentiert sind.
Dort hat man zum Beispiel gemerkt dass diese Kommentatoren Dokumentationen oder von irgendwelchen Beiträgen fast immer männlich oder dominant männlich sind.
Das war schon erstaunlich. Warum muss das eigentlich so sein warum ist das dann so.
Claus Kleber im Interview mit Furtwängler Ich habe aber auch gerne.
Man muss sich selbstverständlich fragen Warum ist das so. Welche Stimmen hören wir nicht mehr.
Ein Schauspieler der 50er 60er Jahre kommt uns heute derart affektiert vor.
Ich gebe nun mal den Hinweis bei YouTube ein Interview mit Elisabeth anzuhören eine ganz ganz große Schauspielerin aber würde man heute so sprechen würde man denken was ist da los.
Aber die Stimme die verrät ja sehr viel über uns haben wir ja schon einmal ganz kurz angetippt.
Ich habe dazu noch einen kleinen Auszug aus einem Buch von Dollar das ist ein Philosoph der hat auch im Suhrkamp Verlag publiziert das Buch heißt eine Philosophie.
Die Stimme ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert Sie hat Macht über den anderen und ist dem anderen ausgesetzt.
Sie ist ein Appell ein Gesuch. Ein Versuch den anderen gefügig zu machen.
Sie schneidet unmittelbar ins Innere und zwar so sehr dass der Status des äußeren selbst ungewiss wird und sie legt das Innere unmittelbar bloß.
Und zwar so sehr dass die Annahme eines inneren Selbst von der Stimme abhängt,
eine Stimme zu hören und eine Stimme von sich zu geben ist also gleichermaßen ein Exzess ein übermaß an Autorität auf der einen Seite und ein übermaß an ausgesetzt sein Auf der anderen,
wegen des direkten schutzlosen übergangs ins Innere.
Gibt es ein Zuviel an Stimme im Außen und es gibt ein Zuviel an Stimme die aus dem Inneren stammt.
Sie bringt mehr und anderes an den Tag als einem lieb ist.
Man ist der Stimme zu sehr ausgeliefert und die Stimme liefert zu sehr aus.
Man verleibt sich zu viel ein und stößt zu viel aus.
Also ich sagen Ja und nein.
Es gibt auf der einen Seite sehr viel auf einer Stimme zu lesen was ja auch gemacht wird. Bei was weiß ich dass,
Telephonzelle da wo irgendwelche Leute anrufen und wollen dann schnell Kontakt zu einer echten Person um irgendein Problem in Ihrer Bank oder sonstwas zu klären.
Da kann man natürlich eine Auswertung machen Wie aufgeregt sind denn die Menschen gerade die Situation herauslesen Das glaube ich dass Wut Freude.
Das kann man schon ganz gut unterscheiden auch maschinell.
Allerdings Dass die Stimme jetzt so viel über eine Person verrät.
Man merkt es an sich selber auch Reaktion von anderen wenn irgendwann mal sehr viel später in der Höhe Erfahrung mit einer visuellen Erfahrung gekoppelt werden muss.
Ach so sieht die Person aus die zu der Stimme gehört.
Dann ist es doch häufig so Kulturschock. Und dann stellt man so fest.
Also Entweder bleibe ich jetzt dabei mir vorzustellen was sich hinter der gehörten Stimme vermute oder ich bleibe dabei mir vorzustellen was sich hinter diesem Antlitz der Person vermute aber beides zusammen passt irgendwie nicht ganz. Z.B.
Bei Synchronsprecherin ist das immer ganz erschreckend wenn die den jugendlichen Liebhaber gesprochen hat aber derjenige nicht unbedingt den Körper eines jugendlichen Liebhabers hat.
Genau da gibt es ganz wenige Manfred Lehmann zum Beispiel. Der sieht halt aus wie man sich vorstellt.
Christian Brückner auch der etwas zurückhaltender etwas kaputter.
Zurück etwas. Robert De Niro Stimme hervorgezogen aber.
Robert De Niro Stimme. Da steckt halt wirklich ein bisschen die Figur dahinter.
Aber ganz häufig ist das halt so. Diese deutsche Stimme von Leonardo DiCaprio zum Beispiel das ist kein Womanizer der irgendwie und so sondern schon da fällt man ja wirklich aus allen Wolken weil man das so zusammenbringen muss ohne Urteil über die Person zu sagen aber man ist halt doch irgendwie anderes gewohnt.
Man ist natürlich auch abgelenkt von der Person die man sieht dem Schauspieler aber.
Sie verrät ja schon die Stimme recht viel über Tagesform auch Emotionen die man so noch transportiert.
Genau über Tagesform schon.
Ist man ein bisschen angefressen vom Gegenüber ist man ein bisschen eingeschnappt. So etwas schwingt ja auch mit.
Selbstverständlich gibt es jetzt professionelle Leute Tagesschau-Sprecher einen schlechten Tag hatte er schon,
am Telefon oder auch in vielen vielen Podcast die man so hört merkt man schon manchmal dass da jemand eigentlich nicht so gut geschlafen hat.
Mal Podcast wird's schon schwierig. Da wird glaube ich schon viel unterstellt was am Ende dann doch vielleicht anders ist.
Und wenn du dir jetzt mal vorstelle unser Bundeskabinett Franziska Giffey z.B. der nun immer Probleme mit ihrer Stimme hatte was sie auch offen sagt Ich war immer zu zaghaft es klang immer nicht so richtig Karriere gemacht.
Man ist halt jetzt wirklich eine mächtige Politikerin. Helge Braun der Kanzleramtsminister.
Das Schlimmste ist Du kannst dir nicht vorstellen dass der irgendwie Milliarden und Milliarden Mal verschied mit so einer Unterschrift auf dem Papier aber das passt überhaupt nicht auch nicht zur Figur selbst wenn man sie sieht Stimme erst recht nicht.
Das ist das Langweiligste undifferenziertes der Bürokratie. Inhaltlich abgelten Node von irgendwelchen Themen und so weiter bringt man es so gar nicht auf die Kette.
Es kommt dann erst wieder bei Politikern die dann wirklich auf der Vorderbühne Karriere gemacht haben.
Gerhard Schröder oder so.. Da hat man es ja wieder diese Präsenz. Da passt das wieder zusammen.
Aber ansonsten es stimme doch immer wieder so ein sehr überraschendes Ding wenn man dann die Figur die Person mal dazu.
Ökonomisch. Weg von diesen philosophischen Fragen.
Dann ist es ja so dass Google hauptsächlich Geld damit verdient dass sie Werbung,
schalten und so weiter aber das ist ja ganz stark daran gebunden dass sie eine Suchmaschine sind die Texte erfindet.
Und wenn wir jetzt hier irgendeinen Satz sprechen,
würde diesen Satz jemand der den Podcast hört eingeben bei Google dann kommt er nicht auf unseren Podcast wenn er Stefan Schulz oder Wolfgang Schmidt. Dann kommt er zu unserem Podcast.
Aber das ganze inhaltliche was wir hier besprechen das wird man nicht finden,
Schlagworte aber sonst wird ja.
Wir haben auch ein Transkript das wird von Sprache mittags gemacht automatisch.
Das findet zumindest Substantive relativ sicher.
Aber man kann es nicht nach ganzen Sätzen oder so suchen Google ist ja reingegangen ins Podcasting mit einer eigenen App von Anfang gesagt Hier wird transkribiert.
Diese Skripte stehen aber nicht zur Verfügung sondern die sind wirklich nur in Suchergebnissen wie so das Buch Man kann das Buch nirgendwo verfügbar haben aber ein paar Bilder gibt es dann doch einmal zu sehen und in der Hinsicht,
klar bei Google muss man sich schon fragen wie sie sich eine Zukunft vorstellen in der eigentlich alle großen Tech-Unternehmen gerade versuchen deine Wohnung zu automatisieren und zwar rein über Sprache.
Denn das was Google Gewinn gebracht hat ist die Werbung der man nunmal leicht ausweichen kann.
Also die Hälfte aller Werbe Dinge die Google bisher eingeblendet hat wurde niemals von einem Menschen gesehen weil entweder irgendwelche anderen Fenster drüber hinweg oder sonst irgendwas.
Man kann natürlich nicht so einer gesprochenen Werbung plötzlich ausweichen sei es über den Lautsprecher zu Hause oder über den Kopfhörer unterwegs weil wenn da jetzt Werbung da würde die wirklich stören.
Da braucht man ein neues Geschäftsmodell weil die Werbung mit der Stimme transportiert ist. Das geht dann zu nah.
Und es ist ja auch eine Frage. Wir haben ein Geschäftsmodell das ein bisschen ins Schwimmen gerät durch die vielen Podcasts weil dann vieles nicht mehr so leicht gefunden werden kann.
Aber es ist ja schon etwas anderes ob ich jetzt alle geschriebenen Blogs Artikel und sonst was,
in meine Suchmaschine oder ob ich dann sagen kann Gut ein bisschen was aus dem Podcast,
damit ja auch wiederrum wissen schwerer auffindbar ist denn wir haben es jetzt selbstverständlich leicht zu irgendwelchen Themen die wir besprechen wollen oder zu denen man selbst irgendetwas schreiben möchte gerade mal zu googeln.
Aber ich kann jetzt ganz schwer googeln in welchem Podcast wird das besprochen es sei denn es ist dort gleich Topic aufgeführt.
Aber wenn ich jetzt gerade hier diesen Schlenker zum Laden Dollar gemacht habe der wird nicht in unserer Beschreibung auftauchen der wird nirgends auftauchen und niemand wird wissen dass ich mich dazu geäußert hat.
Zufällig gehört kann es also nicht nochmal nachvollziehen. Das ist ja schon interessant dass jetzt wieder sehr viel Wissen verborgen ist und ausgegraben werden muss.
Das ist ja sowieso ein grundsätzliches Problem. Da kann ich auch mal kurz anführen also unter dem Framing jetzt wird man auch verstehen worum es geht.
Ich habe gestern auf Twitter Streit mit Maja Goebel gehabt.
Maja Goebel ist ja jetzt bekannt Göpel die wissenschaftliche und so weiter.
Transformation.
Auch bei den Pressekonferenzen auf Youtube und so weiter einen Aufschlag gemacht und auch für Aufmerksamkeit gesorgt.
Und sie hatte so einen Ausschnitt geteilt aus so einer Fernsehsendung in der sie war und ich hab das dann kommentiert mit Herr H.
Das ist mal wieder so dieses Gequassel halt.
Aber man weiß dann einfach so eine Fernsehsendung auch nicht was man jetzt tun soll.
Es ist weder groß politisch noch Handlungs leidend und dann hat sie darauf verwiesen dass ja in Ihren Büchern sehr wohl sehr viele konkrete Sachen stehen und hab ich wieder angefügt.
Aber warum gehen Sie dann nicht mit einem Notizzettel in eine Fernsehsendung und wollen egal was als Frage kommt einfach mal ein paar Sachen auch wirklich mal nennen so weil das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen.
Man findet viel in Podcasts. Aber wenn man die Podcasts sowie hört wie ich dass man immer versucht so einen Clip zusammen zu schneiden um die dann später wieder zu reproduzieren dann,
verschwindet das immer so weil wir grundsätzlich das Problem haben dass gesprochene Sprache sehr viel unstrukturierte vorliegt als wenn man jetzt einfach sagen Wir schreiben den Text dann ist einfach klar Da hört der Satz auf da fängt er an und dann nimmt man den und dann steht er auch für sich,
und das ist eben mit gesprochenem Zeug sehr viel schwieriger weil Wo sollte so ein klirrt beginnen wo enden dann ist der Satzbau grammatikalisch irgendwie,
völlig Banane und im Kontext des vor drei Minuten Gesagten spielt da eine ganz andere Rolle oder man ist in gar keinem Zusammenhang mehr.
Und es fällt mir dann immer wieder auf und eben auch mit diesem Wunsch verbunden auch z.B.
Erfahrungen aus dem Studium.
Wenn André Kiessling in den Raum kam und eine Vorlesung zu halten war immer so ein bisschen Daumendrücken hat er seine Notizen dabei manchmal da seine Notizen auch einfach rumliegen lassen.
Wenn er seine Notizen dabei hatte es war kein großer Zettel aber da war klar Okay alle zehn Minuten wird hier ein neues Thema durch gackert und das ist die Reihenfolge und die Dramaturgie überlegt den Notizzettel nicht dabei hatte.
Dann war das halt einfach 90 Minuten nochmal die alten Klassiker die Evergreens und danke für die Vorlesung aber es gab jetzt nichts zum Mitschreiben Das waren nochmal die Allgemeinplätze an diesen Unterschied.
Der ist so gewaltig bei gesprochener Sprache.
Sie ist so leicht und wird deswegen auch so leicht genommen obwohl sie so viel mehr könnte.
Das wir jetzt eine Limitierung bei Twitter 140 Sekunden haben ist ja schon mal so was könnte es schon mal.
Das können schon mal die Hürden sein über die man springt und die auch wirklich mehr Mehrwert schaffen.
Aber diese 50 Minuten Fernsehsendungen sind halt häufig einfach nur da ist egal was man für ein tolles Buch vorher geschrieben hat da schlägt sich fast nichts nieder Man muss entweder sein Notizzettel mitnehmen oder nicht.
Das Programm durchziehen manche Intellektuelle die in Talkshows gehen die Antworten unabhängig von der Frage was Sie jetzt sagen wollen und dann kümmert man sich dann als Moderator darum dass man irgendwie einen Anschluss findet.
Hinzu kommt Bei Podcasts ja nicht die Möglichkeit dass man es leicht zitieren kann sondern man müsste es abtippen.
Und dann würde es wieder irgendwo zitiert Wenn das passiert aber in der Regel nicht.
Da sind wir schon noch extrem fixiert. Wenn jemand auch nur einen kleinen Artikel irgendwo schreibt ist die Chance sehr viel größer dass der zitiert wird dass er dann im Diskurs stattfindet wenn das Podcast stattfindet.
Podcast bleibt es dann in der Podcast Blase der jeweiligen Podcast Blase.
Darüber hinaus ist es sehr sehr schwierig.
Ich glaube dass es schon interessant ist dass wir mit Google wirklich diese Entwicklung hatten.
Alle Bücher der Welt um verfügbar zu haben dass man jetzt doch wieder sieht dass so viel im Unsichtbaren stattfindet was vielleicht auch manchmal ganz gut ist.
Damit meine ich nicht gut dass manches verschütt geht sondern auch wenn das eben nicht so gerade runter gedämpft werden kann auf zwei Sätze die dann rausgenommen werden das ist etwas was man doch häufig erlebt bei Twitter.
Man schreibt einen langen Artikel 8 000 Zeichen für eine große Zeitung und dann ist da ein böser Satz drin den man sich erlaubt hat und der wird dann bei Twitter kann man sich im Podcast auch erlauben.
Twitter und all das.
Das ist ja genau die Diskussion die wir gerade haben mit den Virologen die sich natürlich ihre Stunde im Podcast nehmen und sich über jedes Zitat das da ausgenommen wird aufregen selbst im Wortlaut richtig ist weil es einfach keinen Sinn macht das so zu machen.
Wer weiß. Klar man Podcast zerhacken Das ist wie ein Film zerhacken ich folge zum Beispiel auf Instagram 007 dem Account 007.
Da werden einfach aus allen möglichen James-Bond-Filmen mal zwei Minuten mal drei Minuten herausgeschnitten und einzeln publiziert.
Macht nur Sinn wenn man den Film im Grunde so kennt und man ihn kurz vorher nochmal so abspielen lässt im Inneren dann sich auf die drei Minuten einlässt oder so.
Macht nur Sinn wenn man die Gründe so kennt und kurz vorher nochmal so agieren lässt.
Aber man kann auch mit Filmen eigentlich nicht umgehen.
Es sei denn man macht es so out of context mäßig das gibt's ja jetzt auch sehr viel bei Twitter.
Marcel Reich-Ranicki Context oder es gibt auch einen Kanal von meiner Person Kontext gesehen.
Aber dann,
aber dann eben wirklich explizit da heißt ja wirklich out of context.
Dann kann man es wieder einfangen und so zeigen ich meine Filme werden auch Szenen produziert.
Zeigen.
Wir werden auch sehen.
Es ist nicht immer so dieses Gesamtkunstwerk und so weiter Man kann ja ein klassisches Ding habe könne man in der Mitte einfach durchschneiden.
Und nicht chronologisch.
Man hätte zwei gute Filme Paul Hava und das andere ist dieser Rachefeldzug.
Man kann jedenfalls sagen gute Filme zeichnen sich dadurch aus dass man sich so ein bisschen zerhacken kann.
Du hast vor ein paar Jahren,
für die FAZ einen Artikel geschrieben.
2013er.
Unser großer Podcast Kuru.
Berühmter Podcaster. Sehr zu empfehlen sein.
Wer sich für Weltraum interessiert der.
Alle Forschergeist.
Doch sehr regelmäßig und der hat ja da so eine Vision gehabt vielleicht kannst du das mal.
Vom Audio Web gesprochen im Sinne von Wie wir Text mit Verlinkungen so aufeinander.
Das hat einfach Audio in den Mittelpunkt stellt. Ich finde wir sind dem schon ziemlich nahe.
Stichwort Sprachunterricht in sozialen Netzwerken und so weiter. Das ist gar nicht so weit entfernt wie man immer glaubt.
Die Frage ist nur nach kriegt man es nochmal so strukturiert wie Text.
Oder ist es eigentlich egal. Merkt man in dem Prozess ist eigentlich egal ist.
Du hast mich gestern gefragt nach diesem Tweet vom Anfang Juni hab ich da nicht gefunden und mir fiel auch auf dass ich für eigentlich so ein Archiv in dem Falle gerade nicht durch Zufall.
Aber das war das erste Mal dass eine Frage kam was ist eigentlich mit diesem Tweet der länger als eine Woche alt ist.
Hat mich noch nie jemand nachgefragt nach dem alten Tweet wozu eigentlich dieser ganze alte Ja es ist doch alles nur so situations getrieben.
So wie er auch bei Instagram die Chefrolle dann wirklich meinte.
Klar wenn jetzt alte Leute sagen wir mal so 50 plus zu Facebook kommen und zu Instagram für diesen Foto halt ein Foto gucken auf jedes Foto und denken,
wäre es nicht schön wenn ich mir das Ausdrucke auf den Tisch stelle und für die Kinder alle unter 30 ist ein Foto halt so das Kürzel des Gottes Nippel das man so als Kommunikations Happen rüber wirft der,
überhaupt nicht aufgeladen mit irgendwas sondern verfliegt halt sofort Snapchat nicht ohne Grund.
Man guckt sich das Bild einmal an und dann ist es weg und man sieht es auch nie wieder sondern.
Auch hier eine große Chance dass man quasi immer jeden Tag einen Neuanfang starten kann was dann Instagram übernommen hat.
Genau genau genau diese Story ist jetzt bei Instagram sind auf jeden 20 Stunden Weg an der Einsicht wandelt sich das ja sowieso und wir können uns halt wirklich fragen.
Wandelt sich das ja so.
Der Gedanke der wird schwierig weil ganz viel verschwindet.
Wieviel Struktur wollen wir erhalten. Nur weil wir es von Texten gewohnt sind.
Und das andere lässt sich zwar archivieren alle Podcasting werden in der Regel ja auch nicht gelöscht aber sie können ganz schwer archiviert werden.
Wer zum Beispiel in diesem Podcast auch so eine Entscheidung getroffen. Beim Aufwachen zum Beispiel ist ja jeder Titel immer so ein bisschen Haltung was soll das bedeuten.
So ein Wort eigentlich eine neue ist ja schon wir schreiben wir schon in den Titel so rein worum es geht die Themen Klima mäßig getrennt also schon recht strukturiert damit man es zügig findet,
schlägt sich natürlich dann nicht sozusagen nieder in dem Podcast Ja es ist sozusagen das offene Gespräch.
Aber man findet dann halt so Wege irgendwie um es so weit zu strukturieren dass es ausreicht fürs Stichwort suchen oder so. Aber man muss es halt wirklich nicht übertreiben.
Und inwieweit wir in Redaktionsschluss schon dieses Argument mal der,
Gutenberg Parent These gebracht wo er schon das Argument ist wie folgt man so Literaturwissenschaftlern aus Schweden.
Bis vor fünfhundert Jahren also bis zur Erfindung der Druckerpresse war das im Grunde eine situative Sprache Stimme Gesellschaft Man ist halt vor die Tür getreten und da war irgendjemand dann hat man die Situation bewältigt durch Humor Befehle oder sonst irgendwas und dann war's vorbei.
Und dann kam plötzlich dieses Buch Und plötzlich stand das immer für immer und dann hat man es so ins Regal gestellt und es war auch ein Jahr später noch da und man wusste ja gar nicht für wen schreibt man das eigentlich.
Am Ende hat man es für eine Reihe Harry Potter zum Beispiel Ja das ist Literatur die ist geschrieben für Menschen die sich noch gar nicht geboren.
Also wenn wir hundert Jahre warten wir haben das zu 99 Prozent Leute gelesen die wir noch gar nicht geboren hattest geschrieben worden ist völlig ohne adressiert das Buch einfach mal so in die Welt gesetzt,
und setzt natürlich voraus dass man sehr strukturiert vorgeht ein Kapitel ein Teil das die Sprache bekannt ist.
So wie die Bibel damals begonnen wurde Wir schauen die Menschen mal auf den Mund und machen es mal genau so wie er es gewohnt ist irgendwie.
Dann kam Grammatik Vorstellung Rechtschreibung war das in der Schule plötzlich ganz wichtig. Schreiben lernen ganz wichtig.
Und jetzt kommen wir zurück. Das waren eigentlich fünf tolle Jahre da konnte man archivieren und Hierarchisierung organisieren und verwalten und so weiter.
Den Nationalstaat begründen und jetzt stürzen wir wieder zurück in dieses Mittelalter und fragen uns was ging eigentlich verloren und was will man noch erhalten.
Aber alles fragen im Fluss irgendwie.
Aber wir erleben auf jeden Fall dass diese ganzen Tools die man durch das Smartphone einfach bedienen kann immer mehr werden jetzt auf den Plattformen,
wegbewegt auch davon dass man sagt Das Internet ist nichts weiter als Text oder viele Zeitungen haben ja eigentlich nur,
ihre Internetauftritte als Zeitungen digital verstanden aber jetzt ändert sich ja auch sehr erheblich.
Bei Instagram gibts ja auch eine neue Möglichkeit. Real heißt das jetzt und wenn man sich anschaut,
bedenkt das ja Snapchat auch,
ein bisschen beklaut wurde kann man so sagen mit der Story zumindest hat man sich sehr stark inspirieren lassen so inspiriert man sich jetzt wohl gerade bei tick tack,
denn real ermöglicht ja auch solche Funktionen dass man da mit Musik ein bisschen arbeiten kann das man lustige Videos nicht nur in der Story macht sondern als Posth dann auch nochmal.
Man versucht jetzt doch irgendwie entgegenzuwirken diesem nach wie vor ungebrochenen tickte komme ich da jetzt bei zwei Milliarden Downloads oder so.
Es ist eine ungeheure Summe zumindest.
Wir kommen ja darauf nachher auch zurück.
Social-Media heißt Die Kommunikation muss irgendwie attraktiv sein sie muss gefällig sein.
Attraktiv sein ja.
Man muss sie gut finden und gleichzeitig fragt man sich wie viele der alten Regeln wollen wir denn beibehalten oder darf jetzt Trump einfach alles was technisch möglich ist.
Fragt man sich wie viele der alten Regeln beibehalten oder darf jetzt einfach alles technisch.
Intro/Outro
Harley.
Josh Rowley ist ein Republikaner den man aber sonst nicht so kennt.
Hätte man eigentlich nicht. Denn der Wahlkampf hat sich jetzt gedreht und es tauchen neue Protagonisten auf und wir müssen mal reden denn es zeigt sich dass Trump nun doch die eine oder anderen Wählerschaft abhanden kommen.
Ich habe zum Beispiel mit Erstaunen gelesen.
Üblicherweise ist es so Man ist verteidigen. Der Präsident hat also eine erhebliche Chance wiedergewählt zu werden allein durch Medien Aufmerksamkeit und so weiter und nimmt deswegen auch besonders viel Geld ein.
Und bei diesem Wahlkampf jetzt stellt sich heraus Hey Joe Biden hat in einem Monat nämlich im Mai 81 Millionen Dollar eingenommen und setzt damit sogar Donald Trump Schachmatt,
der ja seinerseits nicht nur Wahlkampfspenden annimmt sondern damit auch dieses Wenn du mir jetzt Geld gibt dann kannst du später da Botschafter werden oder sonst irgendwas.
Also eigentlich ist das immer ein Geben und Nehmen deswegen gibt es eigentlich immer sehr viel mehr Geld für diejenigen die nicht den großen Wahlkampf macht.
Aber Joe Biden hat den Rekord geknackt und 15 Millionen.
Am 15. Juni sechs Millionen in einer einzigen Veranstaltung eingenommen also Trump sehen wir hier kommt unter Druck die.
Da wird die working class wieder ordentlich zusammengelegt haben diejenigen die die working class eigentlich anführen.
Genau diejenigen die die working class eigentlich anführen. Big Money Big Business.
Die kaufen sich jetzt schon bei Joe Biden ein und das machen sie auch nicht ohne Grund.
Die kaufen sich jetzt schon bei beiden das macht sie auch nicht ohne Grund. Also wir wissen ja welche Wählerschichten eigentlich verloren.
Die wissen da irgendwas und man fragt sich ja Welche Wählerschicht geht denn Trump jetzt eigentlich verloren.
Ich habe so ein paar Clips das kann man aber ganz zum Schluss spielen falls es noch Zeit bleibt.
Es sind die alten vor allem Es sind sehr viele so weiße Sparten Schichten die im Darts verloren gehen auch in den Staaten denen er wirklich gewonnen hat.
Sind die Alten. Vor allem sehr viele weiße Sparten Schichten verloren gehen auch in den Staat. Das ist natürlich eine große Gruppe.
Und es gibt natürlich eine große Gruppe und das sind die religiösen Konservativen die sozusagen als Adressat von Bildern wie wir sie vom 1.
Die sozusagen als Adressat von Bildern wie wir sie von dieser Kirche aus der Bibel in der Hand Paul ein tolles Geräusch.
Juni vor dieser Kirche in Washington und so weiter auftauchten mit der Bibel in der Hand im Hintergrund hören.
Die sind auch wahnsinnig laut. Es ist leider immer ein Geräusch das sie nur machen wenn sie sich bedroht fühlen.
Ich hoffe er fühlt sich nicht wirklich bedroht sondern es sind ja nur so Hühner die da mit rumrennen Josh Harley ist einer dieser religiösen Konservativen entsandt in den amerikanischen Senat und das ist eine ganz interessante Karriere die er gemacht hat.
Jahrgang 1979 Sohn eines Bankers und einer Lehrerin.
Wie man als Republikaner so aufwächst dann Geschichtsstudium in Stanford mit Bestnote danach Internatsleiter in London zurück nach Amerika an die Yale School dort Vorsitzender der Föderalisten Society,
das sind diejenigen die,
verfassungs Orthodoxie treiben indem sie nämlich sagen Wir möchten hier eine Textur und eine original Auslegung der Verfassung so wie sie die Verfassungsväter vor 200 Jahren erdacht haben.
So müssen wir die heute auch interpretieren.
Alles Moderne wird erst mal raus gestrichen und negiert.
Wie bei konservativen Bible Exegeten die sagen so steht's geschrieben und das können wir jetzt nicht einfach mal anpassen.
Genau da hat man sich was dabei gedacht. Und nur weil jetzt irgendwie Internet erfunden hat heißt das ja noch lange nicht dass wir da Zugeständnisse machen genau so 2006.
Ich nehme mal an der Jurist Dr. ist so vergleichbar mit dem ersten Staatsexamen auch gut abgeschlossen und hat dann 2007 wie man das so macht als Republikaner erst einmal eine Biografie über Theodore Roosevelt geschrieben.
Also Der Präsident 1901 bis 1909 und dann erste Arbeitsstelle am Supreme Court.
Man kennt das ja so als aufstrebender Jurist arbeitet man natürlich erst mal hospitieren zu.
Und das hat er tatsächlich im Stab von John Roberts gemacht.
Das ist der Verfassungsrichter der Supreme Court Richter der 2005 von George W.
Bush ernannt wurde seitdem auch Vorsitzender ist und häufig als der Swing gilt.
Nicht ganz unbedeutend. Es ist ja auch Wie soll man sagen Da kommst du nach Washington hast eine tolle Bildungskarriere hinter deren Arbeit ist dann für den,
Verfassungsrichter der alle Präsidenten seit Obama eingeschworen hat ins Amt und er hat natürlich auch tolle Termine die man insgesamt hat.
In dieser Rolle dort als Assistent hat er auch seine Frau kennengelernt.
Persönlich emotional beruflich komplett in diesem republikanischen Washington verhaftet.
Und nun hat er sich angelegt als Senator,
mit seiner Partei und das Verfassungsgericht das er so gut aus dem Inneren kennt.
Ganz interessant ist nach Josh Hawley war unzufrieden mit Trumps Coruna Politik.
Es gibt eine grundsätzliche Es gibt sowieso The Daily eine ganze wunderbare Aufarbeitung.
Selbst in Bundesstaaten in denen die Republikaner eigentlich für Trump gewonnen hat die Leute sagen lieber erst mal Coruña bekämpfen bevor wir hier wieder und so weiter.
Dieses was Trump immer macht wenn eine Maske aufsetzt ist ein Idiot und schlägt sich gar nicht so nieder im Volk da ist er irgendwie auf das falsche Pferd gesetzt und es zeigt sich also Leuten wie Charlie plädierte z.B.
Für eine Strategie nach dem deutschen Vorbild erst lock down Arbeitsverträge beibehalten in dem Sinne Kurzarbeiter Strategie und so weiter fahren,
und dann wenn Coruna besiegt ist sozusagen wieder auftauchen und es ordentlich machen.
Unser Charly hat noch eine zweite. Zweites großes politisches Anliegen gerade er ist nämlich vom Weißen Haus beauftragt. Darauf kann man noch einmal zurück.
Diese Gesetzesvorlage auszuarbeiten die,
Donald Trump erlaubt auf Twitter und Facebook wieder ein bisschen mehr zu machen was eigentlich machen will nämlich gegen die Content Moderation dort vorzugehen also gegen diese ganzen Labels.
Zuckerberg hat jetzt nachgelegt Es gibt ja auch Labels auf Facebook für Botschaften von Trump die man nicht löschen will weil sie ja noch von dem bekannten Politiker sind und die eigentlich gelöscht gehören.
Er soll jetzt Trumps Freifahrtschein ausarbeiten da geht es konkret um die Sektion die Communications,
Act von 596 wo drinsteht kein Provider soll als Publisher oder Speaker behandelt werden im Sinne von,
mit dem Ziel die politische Handhabe gegen Serviceprovider die sich via Content Moderation in die inhaltliche Angelegenheiten einmischen beispielsweise in Botschaften von Trump und so dagegen soll vorgegangen werden.
Und Trump ist ja sehr genervt Bisher wie gesagt von den Twitter Facebook ging da immer stattfinden und hat ja bis jetzt nur mit Executive Order dagegen vorgehen können.
Das ist aber eine irreführende Praktik wenn Twitter einfach meiner Free Speech widerspricht. Und genau das droht ihm jetzt bei Facebook.
Naja Charley legt sich jetzt mit dem Weißen Haus für das er da arbeitet eigentlich aber er sagt Hier geht es nicht weiter.
Und beim Supreme Court denn das ist eine ganz ganz wichtige Sache am 15.
Juni gab es eine große Entscheidung am Supreme Court sechs zu drei gegen sie aus für Chevrolet Postdoc.
Das ist der Fall Booster gegen Clayton da fragt man sich Was hat es damit auf sich. Wir lesen in der Wikipedia.
Der Kläger Jared Postdoc wurde gefeuert nachdem er am Arbeitsplatz Interesse an einer schwulen Softball Liga bekundet hatte.
Also jemand zeigt eine homo sexuelle Tendenz und wird deswegen gefeuert.
Und dann klagte er dagegen und sagte Aber das geht ja nicht dass ich hier wegen diskriminiert werde aufgrund meiner sexuellen Vorliebe alle Gerichte haben gesagt,
dass zu recht gefeuert und dann kam das vor den großen Supreme Court und dort hat man den Artikel,
7 des Civil Rights Act noch einmal neu ausgelegt neu interpretiert also gesagt aber irgendwann mal geschrieben aber wir legen jetzt mal den Text neu aus.
Zusammengefasst kann man sagen die Diskriminierung wegen Geschlecht erstreckt sich auch auf die Diskriminierung wegen sexueller Orientierung.
Denn wenn jemand gefeuert wird weil er Männer liebt oder sexuell anziehend findet dann müsste man ja eigentlich alle Frauen entlassen die Männer sexuell anziehend finden. Es geht aber nicht.
Wir können die Geschlechter nicht gleich behandeln.
Wenn eine Frau einen Mann lieben darf darf auch ein Mann ein Mann lieben. Das war die Argumentation eigentlich nicht sehr raffiniert und nicht besonders.
Man liegt ja auf der Hand für Amerika aber das Ende einer 60 jährigen Geschichte.
Was Rechtssprechung angeht deren Sicht eine 56 Jahre währende Rechtstradition von diesem Civil Rights Act 1064 und am 16.
Juni einen Tag später tritt Schorsch Hawley in seiner Rolle als Abgeordnete der Republikaner im amerikanischen Senat auf.
Ich glaube das Setting ist so eine freie Rede Stunde oder so aktuelle Sachen ist im Grunde auch egal er kriegt eine Redezeit die nicht sehr lang ist.
Wir hören sich fast erschöpfend in der Rede und er beschwert sich und er beginnt dabei nochmal die orthodoxe Auslegung der Verfassung zu fordern.
Basta.
Während wählende,
Projekt,
Bastürk werden erfüllt Sexist.
Als Seles because of Textiles.
En vogue Textor oder,
ein auskamen Changes Scoop eine Applikation.
Wenn Textilfasern.
Das ist eine ziemliche Bombe gewesen denn wer hier sagt Wenn die orthodoxe Auslegung der Verfassung die ist nun mal mehrheitlich republikanisch besetztes Verfassungsgericht Kaverne und,
Trump hat ja zwei benannt. Wenn das dazu führt dass plötzlich schwule Menschen Schutz vor Diskriminierung bekommen dann widerspricht das der ursprünglichen Verfassungs Auslegung der Verfassungsgebung.
Und dann heißt das dass hier ein Gefüge zerstört wurde und er hat Scots genannt.
Ihm geht es um das liege Conservative Projekt. Man fragt sich ein bisschen was ist das eigentlich.
Man kann sich das vorstellen. Wir alle in Deutschland vor allem in Europa haben immer Angst vor Trumps Bake weil da gibt's irgendwie so Leute und zwar gar nicht wenige die wählen gegen ihre eigenen ökonomischen Zwänge.
Für die Republikaner die ganze Zeit da sind arme Menschen,
die brauchen eigentlich eine Gesundheitsvorsorge und die brauchen eigentlich eine Lohnfortzahlung im Krankheitsfall und die brauchen eigentlich Kinderbetreuung und die brauchen eigentlich all das was ein guter Sozialstaat liefert,
und wohl wissend dass sie das nur bei den Demokraten bekommen bleiben die bei den Republikanern über Jahrzehnte.
Man fragt sich warum eigentlich. Die Antwort.
Auch zugleich. Wie kann das sein dass das so entscheidend ist.
Fragen der Ehe für alle Fragen der Abtreibung und solche Dinge dass das dann auf einmal alles ist,
und dass die Republikaner es dann auch jedes Mal wieder verstehen damit Wahlkampf zu machen und man bekommt hier wirklich jetzt,
die letzte des Rätsels Lösung.
Genau das ist nämlich der Kniff diese Menschen wählen gegen ihre ökonomischen Interessen wohlwissend dass sie das tun weil sie dafür ihre religiösen Gefühle in politische Gesetze in Gesetzestexte gegossen kriegen.
Die Republikaner stehen sozusagen als Schutz Front gegen die moderne Welt bereit um parlamentarisch durchzuboxen dass diese Menschen ihre religiöse Freiheit behalten dürfen und dazu gehört,
ich muss mich nicht mit Homosexuellen umgeben und wenn irgendwer irgendwelche Vorlieben hat die nicht in der Bibel stehen dann kann ich auch einfach diskriminieren bis hin zu Tod. schießen und so weiter.
Ging. Also es geht wenn man die Jahrzehnte zurückblickt auch sehr brutal zu.
Und dieses Projekt wird jetzt hier von Josh Harley aufgekündigt weil es nämlich von der anderen Seite wie er sagt aufgekündigt wurde hier beschreibt er nochmal diesen Lifestyle Schutz auf den man sich berufen hat.
Herr Pendl.
Kerry,
legte.
Auf.
Sah.
Es
der Vater ist die Garantie.
Für.
Den.
Sort of.
Und jetzt genießen Sie diesen Schutz nicht mehr und kriegen das auch mit dass sie da ja auch so ein bisschen veralbert werden von der Republikanischen Partei die sozusagen ihren Teil der Abmachung nicht mehr nachkommt und zulässt dass,
die höchsten Richter da einfach Politik machen indem sie einfach sagen Hey das ist jetzt Diskriminierung wenn sowas stattfindet.
Niemand darf aufgrund seiner sexuellen Orientierung da anders behandelt werden als andere Menschen und jetzt wagt man sich.
Trump ist auch nicht der richtige Präsident für diese Leute das muss man auch immer sagen er ist kein Mensch der besonders religiös ist.
Auf die Frage Was ist das für eine Bibel keine Antwort zu geben weiß religiös sind egal ob Katholik Protestant oder irgendwelche anderen.
Egal ob.
Man.
Übelnehmen dass man nicht weiß,
wie man.
Eigentlich zu bieten hat und auch.
Auch was.
Kein Problem hat.
Man kann davon ausgehen dass der.
Eine Krankenversicherung für alle.
Fundamentalismus.
Ja wenn man sich dieses Foto-App vom 1.
Juni da vor dieser Kirche in Washington nochmal anschaut Da steht ein Präsident der kommt aus New York aus Manhattan fährt dann nach Washington und hält eine Bibel hoch und wird gefragt Was ist das für eine Bibel.
Das ist Bibel irgendeine wurde mir Halt gegeben.
Und wenn man so ein Foto für solche religiösen Konservativen erfolgreich machen will dann kommt es wirklich auf die Nuancen an. Ansonsten erkennen Sie das.
Und es war vielleicht auch wirklich kontraproduktiv das so durchzuziehen weil es nicht sehr überzeugend ist.
Es gibt diese ganzen Fotos aus dem Oval Office wo es alle beten sich gemeinsam die Hände auf die Schulter und so weiter so als Standbild irgendwie mag das überzeugend sein aber diese Foto-App.
Da muss man echt noch mal gucken ob man da vielleicht nicht so einer falschen Magie aufsetzt also dass man da zuviel Mystik rein lässt sondern das scheint dann mehr so zu sein.
Text Dual und Organizer Original die Texte ranzugehen bedeuteten schon ein bisschen mehr als einfach nur die Bibel hochzuhalten und dann eben ein Foto zu machen und ich frage Sie immer noch aber wieso waren die Kräfte so stark.
Irgendwelche Milliardäre zu wählen damit sie eine religiöse beschützende ist doch völlig hanebüchen eigentlich beschreibt es hier mal was man jetzt alles bedroht sieht.
Auf Apennin.
Er hält hier so eine Lesung auch das ist ganz bemerkenswert wie er das tut und er malt zugleich ein Horrorszenario aus.
Was glaubt ihr was dort formuliert ist dass für die künftigen Fälle dann wird man sehen was daraus Schlüsse zu ziehen sind.
Man darf nicht unterschätzen In Amerika gilt dieses Präzedenzfall. Wenn einmal ein Richter eine Entscheidung getroffen hat dann wird so kommentiert und herumgereicht und ist dann irgendwann tatsächlich einfach von Bedeutung für vorbildhaft für weitere Fälle.
Und wenn die Richter selbst nicht reinschreiben und was die Zukunft Anbetracht müssen wir mal schauen dann ist das natürlich die Gefahr die da für diese Leute droht.
Denn das kann man vielleicht jetzt mal so sagen Amerika ist jetzt wieder ein Schritt moderner geworden denn mit dieser Entscheidung wurde von den Richtern die Religion dem Recht untergeordnet,
und bisher haben die gedacht und wahrscheinlich auch zu Recht. Es gibt also einen gleichrangigen.
Wir wissen es ist Religion es ist spirituell da kommt es auf irgendwas an aber nicht auf ihn sagen die Richter.
Na ja wir gucken uns den Rechtstexte an. Und wenn Frauen Männer lieben dürfen dürfen das halt auch Männer. Da gibts jetzt.
Wie sieht denn das Gegenargument aus wenn da nur so ein Religionsunterricht kommt dann wird das halt,
künftig heruntergestuft das ist dann auf einer Ebene der Geltung niedriger als es die rechtliche Interpretation der Ansicht Schulen Organisationen Unternehmen und die ganze Zukunft ist davon bedroht von diesen Leuten.
Und es gibt viele Unternehmen die das jetzt begrüßt haben. Es gibt ja dort auch so eine Ficus irgendwie so dass man sich als Unternehmen quasi,
dieser Rechtsprechung mit freundschaftlich erweist und da hat sich dann beispielsweise auch die Deutsche Bank,
in Statements genau zu diesem Beschluss geäußert und das begrüßt und dann verweist man gerne auch nochmal auf die eigene Firmengeschichte Wir machen das ja schon seit 2002 oder so steht dann da aber das gibt's,
unendlich viel im Internet zu finden Statements von Unternehmen die das gut finden.
Genau das Wandertour zu wollen die Unternehmenskultur in die Satzung irgendwelche Präambel und so weiter das ist.
Man muss sagen es ist ein Stück Modernität jetzt hat sich einfach mal Bahn gebrochen und gut das waren jetzt sozusagen.
Man fragt sich Was hat das jetzt alles mit den Richtern zu tun außer dass sie Auslöser sind.
Und hier nimmt er jetzt mal die eigenen Parteikollegen aus der Republikanischen Partei so richtig ins Blickfeld und in die Kritik denn wie konnte es dazu kommen dass,
es passiert ist dass so eine Entscheidung fällen konnte treffen.
Es regiert gerade der republikanische Präsident und die haben im Senat eigentlich eine republikanische Mehrheit.
Bis vor einem Jahr hatten die eigentlich auch im Repräsentantenhaus eine Mehrheit.
Wie konnte das eigentlich dazu kommen wie die Mehrheitsverhältnisse so sind wie sie sind. Und das erzürnt ihnen richtig.
Präsident.
Wismarer.
Und das ist natürlich eine Gemengelage die Trump besonders interessant denn üblicherweise zu Checks and Balances gehört auch Geben und Nehmen.
Üblicherweise sind die Mehrheitsverhältnisse nun mal wie Sie sind spätestens nach zwei Jahren bekommt.
Der Präsident immer aus einer anderen Partei die Mehrheiten vorgesetzt sondern,
er hin und her und es macht extrem kompliziert Gesetzesvorhaben durchzubringen weil die müssen irgendwo im Repräsentantenhaus entstehen und dann brauchen sie aber eine Mehrheit im Senat und der Präsident muss sich einverstanden erklären.
Also wird das gedealt der großen Masse da gebe ich dir all das und so weiter und über so eine ganze vierjährige sechsjährige Amtszeit jeweils hat man dann so ein irgendwie ausgeglichenes Geben und Nehmen.
Wenn jetzt aber die Republikaner den Demokraten alles aus der Hand schlagen und,
Mitch McConnell stolz darauf ist dass ein zwei Meter Papierberge hat über den noch nicht beschieden wurde weil er nämlich die Tagesordnung als Mehrheitsführer im Senat festlegt und sagt darüber stimmen wir heute nicht ab das Bleibt mal schön im Archiv dahinten.
Und nichts entsteht dann klar entsteht bei den Demokraten nichts weil alle alle Versuche aus dem Repräsentantenhaus aus dem Kongress zum Senat zu bringen sind scheitern.
Mitch McConnell damit scheitern allerdings auch alle republikanischen Sachen die auch mal durch die Mehrheit des Kongresses des Repräsentantenhauses und dadurch entsteht da,
absolut nichts politisch da wird nicht mehr entschieden und es regt Josh Hawley hier wahnsinnig auf denn er weiß genau wann wir diese Entscheidung den Richtern vorlegen.
Da zieht die Gesellschaft nicht einfach so vorbei da kann man nicht politisch argumentieren sondern die müssen dann halt mal mit der Zeit gehen und dann solche Entscheidungen treffen wie jetzt im Juni.
Eine Chance hätte man noch dieses legal konservative Projekt aufrecht zu erhalten wenn man es eben politisch macht.
Also wenn der Senat und die Repräsentanten die Republikaner im Senat wirklich handlungsfähig in der Lage sind mit den Demokraten so dieses Ja gut dann macht ihr mal eure Sanctuary City irgendwie in den Metropolen.
Aber dafür machen wir den ländlichen Räumen halt weiter was wir bisher gemacht haben und es funktioniert eben nicht wenn,
die Republikaner sich da selbst im Weg stehen den Demokraten keinen Meter Raumgewinn geben und dadurch aber auch keinen Zentimeter Raum mehr bekommen um irgendwas zu entscheiden und dann da greift in Amerika dann eben dieses Presidents recht dann machen es halt die Richter.
Da werden Fälle aufgeworfen und die Richter haben den Termin hinauszögern aber irgendwann steht dann,
dieses Urteil an und es stand halt jetzt an der Einsicht dass hier nochmal wunderschön aufgezeigt wie wie auch diese ganze Demokratie versagt wenn da einfach zu krasse Extremisten an irgendwelchen Orten sich da breitgemacht haben wie Trump im Weißen Haus.
So geht.
Ab jetzt muss man auch überlegen macht das jetzt taktisch bereitet er sich selbst auf eine Zeit nach Trump vor und vielleicht auch seine Partei und,
positioniert er sich so bei einer Wählerschicht bei der er weiß wie treu sie sein könnten wenn man nur ordentlich mit ihnen umgeht und so.
Und dass er das als Republikaner hier machte finde ich schon erstaunlich aber er legt sich halt wirklich mit seiner Partei an..
Paulus.
Servus.
Mit Focus Herning Kooperations multinational Hugo Boss,
American Giap der chat,
video.
Chat.
Ruhanis.
Tenzing.
Carlos.
Stöhnend,
Education expansiver Payback.
Postest.
Pokals.
Tagesschule.
Klingt jetzt fast wie ein demokratischer Sozialist wenn man das Religiöse mal weglässt spricht er all das an was Bernie Sanders anspricht.
Eigentlich ist das nicht nur ein Angriff gegen die eigene Partei beziehungsweise der Basis wird hier gesagt,
Wir müssen jetzt nicht mehr mit diesem Establishment das sich nur Steuererleichterungen verschafft während ihr nichts bekommt eure Kinder nichts bekommen keine vernünftige Ausbildung genießt und,
da hat er einen Angriffspunkt gegen die eigene Partei oder er mobilisiert die Basis dagegen.
Zugleich aber wird hier eine Tür nicht von ihm selbst aufgemacht aber die könnte man aufstoßen.
Für demokratische Sozialisten die sagen Hier ist eigentlich ein Wählerklientel Wir müssen jetzt nur vermitteln dass es in der Moderne ankommen muss dass es nicht mehr darauf beharren kann dass alles wie im 19. Jahrhundert ist.
Aber generell sind wir eher bei euch und ihr könnt auch immer noch in euren Kirchen tun und lassen was ihr wollt erst einmal bzw.
In dem Rahmen wie es jetzt geregelt ist. Aber wir sorgen zumindest dafür dass es euch sozial.
Er hat die sozialen Zwänge die auch eine Wahl entscheiden können klar benannt.
Menschen bezahlen hier für Studien ihr Studium ihre Kinder und wissen nicht wie sie es bezahlen soll.
Bisher haben wir immer die Fresse gehalten. Wer das so sagt.
Bisher waren wir einfach stumm und haben das mit uns machen lassen weil ihr uns zugesichert habt.
Die Richter die wir benennen werden es schon regeln. In dem Fall diese Entscheidung jetzt wirklich verantwortet von Neil Grossnigg dem ersten den Trump da vor zwei Jahren ins Amt gesetzt hat.
Er hat nun das einfach aufgekündigt und ich frage mich insgesamt was das jetzt auch für die nächsten Jahrzehnte bedeutet denn diese Wähler Klasse um die es da geht.
Diese religiösen Konservativen sind ja schon.
Die Hälfte aller republikanischen Wähler also irgendwie 40 50 60 Millionen Menschen die auch bisher immer im Block abgestimmt haben.
Also ob man denen einfach komplett stiften kann und dann natürlich die Gemengelage inwieweit auch die Demokraten damit taktisch umgehen.
Denn dass die plötzlich feststellen welche ökonomischen Ansprüche sie eigentlich haben und auch politisch formulieren können wurde ja auch geweckt von Wahlkampfreden wie von Yossi oder Bernie Sanders.
Und inwieweit die Demokratische Partei bereit ist hier wieder so einen Deal einzugehen.
Ein Leak legal liege aber nicht konservativ sondern irgendwas das man.
Diskriminieren dürft Ihr.
Lifestyle mit einer gewissen Herablassung auf die religiöse organisiert sind und das sollte man nicht tun.
Intellektuelle Konzepte sind auch aus strategischen Gründen.
Offenbar auch in anderen.
Katholischen Kreisen erzkonservativen Katholiken ganz gute Beziehungen zu Leuten aus der Linkspartei oder nur sehr sehr wenige muss man sagen.
Ja es gibt auf jeden Fall Anknüpfungspunkte denn ich denke auch man kann die Geschichte der Religion Man muss das nicht so aus dieser links versifften Blase immer irgendwie haben uns aufgehalten haben die moderne verhindert.
Die Universitäten der Neuzeit und so weiter und des späten Mittelalters waren die Klöster da wurde das Wissen geschaffen. Da wurde das Wissen organisiert. Archiviert da wurde verschriftlicht da ging es los.
Die moderne brauchte diese religiösen Rahmen.
Stolpern wir in so eine postmoderne Post Gutenberg These irgendwie Welt rein wo wieder alles durcheinander gerät.
Bergfahrer These irgendwelchem.
Aber das Religiöse wird ja auch wieder wichtiger. Das sieht man ja auch.
Man sieht ja auch wo es institutionell nicht so stark ist ist es keineswegs so dass das Religiöse verschwindet sondern es zeigt sich dann in Formen bis hin zu Verschwörungstheorien,
die dann wirklich nicht begrüßenswert sind da wäre das dann doch besser wenn die Bischofskonferenz ein bisschen mehr zu sagen hätte.
Ganz neue Glaubensfragen.
Z.B.. Wir hatten ja Margot Käßmann oder so.
Das sind ja alles Leute die sind ja total anschlussfähig für linke Diskurse irgendwie da ist ja nun steht ja nicht viel im Wege. Irgendwelche Polizeikontrollen in Hannover oder Orsoyer die dann solche Karrieren brechen. Aber ansonsten ist da einiges möglich.
Wie groß diese politische Schwungmasse ist die da jetzt in Bewegung gesetzt werden kann wenn man ihr nur ein gutes Angebot macht hört man noch einmal im Finale von dieser Rede.
Es sei es kostet.
Staab.
Des abkam.
Dadaab.
Ab
Vielleicht wegen des,
Genomics.
Rights.
Adig.
Pfuscht.
Ab
Kasein.
Jetzt stell dir mal so ein Prediger wie Obama oder so vor vier Jahren,
der keine großen Zugeständnisse macht aber auch noch mal,
mit entsprechenden Argumenten erklärt warum es wirklich keinen Grund gibt Diskriminierung wegen sexueller Orientierung noch länger zu dulden und dass man trotzdem ein gutes religiöses also vor allem religiös geprägtes Leben führen kann.
Also ich sehe da einiges in Bewegung irgendwie so insgesammt Man muss halt jetzt erst einmal Trump abschütteln und so ein bisschen Extremismus ablegen.
Aber dann ist da irgendwie einiges da.
Und es ist ja auch erst mal bemerkenswert. Das muss er tun aber das ist schon bemerkenswert wenn man,
jetzt aus der religiösen Warte ansieht dass hier eine Allianz geschmiedet werden soll zwischen all denen die fest im Glauben stehen die traditionell unterwegs sind wo man sagen kann Da gibt es ja,
erhebliche Unterschiede in der Auslegung zum Beispiel der Bibel.
Oder denken wir jetzt nur mal daran ein sehr konservativer Katholik und ein strenger Lutheraner trennt unendlich viel.
Aber wenn die sich jetzt zusammenschließen sollen um gegen das was da gerade vorgeht dann in Stellung zu bringen oder um jetzt gemeinschaftlich die ganzen anderen wichtigen Fragen anzusprechen das ja eigentlich das Entscheidende.
Wie sehr hat man das Soziale vernachlässigt. Dann besteht da doch auch wirklich eine große Chance und ich sehe die auch bei den Demokraten als bei den Republikanern.
Weil die können inhaltlich wenig aufbieten sind ja wirklich nur noch im Kopier Vorgang ob sie irgendwie hinkriegen Trump nochmals die duplizieren mit ein paar Sachen aber Trump hat jetzt auch ernste ganze,
Wahlniederlagen einstecken müssen. Wenn man sich das mal vor Augen führt.
Vielleicht würde ich doch mal einen von diesen Clip spielen denn es gab hier eine Vorwahl schlappe Wir hatten es mal bei Safe America.
Republican,
Carolina Mark Meadows,
Madison Cafe BE Meadows Smith Barney Huis außer Donald Trump himself.
Deren Cartoons wohin Marx Trump Orestes Seiko Brooklyn.
Ein bisschen kompliziert in der Kürze aber man muss sich Szenario vorstellen da gibts jetzt Vorwahlen für die nächsten ämter die zu besetzen sind,
und Trumps aktueller Chief of Staff hat einen Posten geräumt der natürlich neu zu besetzen war woraufhin Trump und sein Chief of Staff Wahlkampf für jemanden gemacht haben der als Nachfolger folgen sollte.
Und die haben verloren gegen einen 25 jährigen republikanischen Herausforderer für diesen Posten.
Und da sind natürlich schon das sind diese Niederlagen wo die Republikaner ankommen.
Bisher hatten wir Angst weil Trump eigentlich immer raus. Trump muss ja nur Empfehlungen sprechen wählt man den wählt man den haben die Leute eigentlich gemacht.
Und wenn jetzt die gesammelte weiße Hausmacht nicht mehr ausreicht um solche Posten solche Vorwahlen Entscheidungen zu treffen dann ist der Zauber gebrochen.
Wie John Fahrfreude meinte er und das bringt natürlich auch einige in der Republikanischen Partei ihn ins Nachdenken.
Insgesamt ob man sich nicht auch schon mal von Trump lossagen sollte anstatt das Pferd zu reiten bis November Wahl verloren ist und so weiter.
Da stehen jetzt wichtige Wahlen an. Also ich wichtige Vorwahlen in New York z.B.
Yukiya da 70 Prozent abgeräumt in der Vorwahl also das alte Ergebnis nochmal wirklich krass übertroffen und auch mit der neuen Bekanntheit.
Aber da ist schon einiges in Bewegung und ich würde auch mal auf die Demokraten tippen.
Klar wir sehen jetzt alle Joe Biden aber diese Zeit geht auch vorüber das sind vier Jahre da kommt jetzt auch sehr darauf an wen er als running mate nimmt weil es dann auch eine Entscheidung darüber wer wird denn vielleicht sogar innerhalb der nächsten vier Jahre noch Präsident,
und so muss jetzt alles mit rein nehmen die Rechnung aber für diese großen Linien was da aufgemalt hat könnte ich mir vorstellen dass es einige Argumente für einige Wähler gibt zu sagen Okay wenn die Republikaner das nicht machen.
Es gibt ja noch andere die dann zumindest unseren ökonomischen Zwängen inhaltlich entsprechende.
Intro/Outro
Diskriminierend ist etwas schwieriger geworden in den USA.
Wir sprechen aber jetzt mal über ein deutsches Phänomen zunächst um dann auch wieder nach Amerika zu blicken,
und das auch noch mal genereller theoretischer einzubetten Es geht ja auch hier seit Monaten Jahren kann man sagen nicht Trump sondern seit dem Aufkommen der AfD immer wieder um die Frage,
Was soll denn eigentlich noch als Meinungsfreiheit durchgehen wo geht das zu weit wo werden auch Grenzen des guten Geschmacks übertreten.
Brauchen wir mehr Political Correctness oder weniger.
All diese Debatten haben wir ja und die werden dann zum Teil auch in Gesetze gegossen und so ist es quasi noch ein kleiner Nachtrag aus dem Mai,
nun so dass man europäische Symbole unter anderem die EU-Flagge nicht mehr,
verunglimpfen darf man dürfte jetzt auch nicht die EU-Flagge verbrennen es gab dazu eine Bundestagsdebatte im Mai.
Wir hören jetzt nur mal weil wir schon viel von der positiven Seite dieses Gesetzes gehört haben hören wir jetzt mal gerade eine Gegenstimme kommt von dem linken Abgeordneten,
der sagt Na ja so toll ist das eigentlich nicht wenn das verboten ist dass man die EU-Flagge verbrämen nicht mehr verbrennen darf z.B. als Protestaktion.
Frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren je weiter diese Legislatur voranschreitet je mehr beschleicht mich das Gefühl dass die Koalition in ihrer Strafrechts Politik ein Walbeck hinlegen wird.
Sie wollen das Strafrecht bei immer mehr Verhaltensweisen eingreifen lassen.
Schon der Begründer der modernen deutschen Strafrechts Theorie Anselm von Feuerbach forderte dass nicht jedes anstößige Verhalten Gegenstand strafrechtlicher Verbote sein dürfe.
Das nennt man Ultima Ratio Prinzip. Das Strafrecht soll nur das letzte Mittel sein um unerwünschtes Verhalten zu verhindern.
Anselm Feuerbach das Feuerbachs Forderungen sind aus dem 19. Jahrhundert.
Er war damit weiter als es die Koalition im 21. Jahrhundert ist.
Jetzt soll die sogenannte Verunglimpfung der EU und ihrer Symbole und das Zerstören ausländischer Flaggen ein Straftatbestand werden.
Sie verleihen damit Staaten im Fall der EU einem Staatenverbund de facto ein Ehrgefühl ein Wir-Gefühl aber sprechen wir üblicherweise nur Menschen zu.
Mit der änderung im Strafgesetzbuch Mystifizierung und verabsolutieren sie den Staat.
Das ähnelt einem monarchistischen Staatsverständnis das können wir als Linke nur ablehnen.
Wir sind als Linke der Ansicht dass nicht jede Geschmacks und Geschmacklosigkeit und nicht jedes anstößige Verhalten in das Strafrecht gehört auch nicht die Verunglimpfung von Flaggen und Symbolen.
Wir selbst dulden in diesem Parlament Geschmacklosigkeiten und Menschenverachtung von Rechtsextremen.
Woche für Woche ertragen sie weil sie wohl größtenteils unter die Meinungsfreiheit fallen,
und wo man bei Demonstrationen eklige Bilder Rentner israelischer Fahnen sieht und verhindern will das kann man heute bereits über Versammlungsrecht Auflagen auch tun.
Wir lehnen ihren Gesetzentwurf auch ab weil er unvereinbar mit der Meinungsfreiheit ist.
Der Begriff des verunglimpften ist in dem Tatbestand zu unbestimmt.
Es ist bereits ein verunglimpften wenn etwa jemand hingehen würde und die Sterne der EU Fahne durch sinkende Rettungsboote im Mittelmeer ersetzt.
Das Sterben im Mittelmeer und die Ignoranz der EU aufmerksam zu machen zumindest verunsichern sie Menschen mit dem Gesetz und halten sie möglicherweise davon ab ihre Meinung kundzutun.
Was behandelt das Gesetz genau. Das Verbrennen der Fahne oder jede.
Das kann dann eben auch so etwas sein in einem gewissen Ermessensspielraum und selbstverständlich ist damit Meinungsfreiheit eingeschränkt und man kann auch.
Fragen stellen Ist das denn überhaupt sinnvoll einen Staat so zu behandeln. Wir hatten diese Debatte ja auch mit dem Schmähgedicht von Böhmermann. Ein fremdes Staatsoberhaupt darf man das.
Da ging es ja auch um die Frage ob das eingebettet ist in Satire und nochmal angesprochen wird ist etwas ganz Wichtiges das es erst einmal verunsichert dass man sich nicht mehr so sicher ist.
Rechtlich lasse ich es lieber ganz.
Deutlich erkennbar und da weiß man auch was man dann nicht zu tun hat.
Das ist dann schon wieder in so einem merkwürdigen Raum wo man sagt Gut Rechtsschutzversicherung.
Bei Verunglimpfung würde ich das auch so sehen. Bei dem verbrennen würde ich sagen Man sollte das als linke Protestsong ja auch begrüßen das ist so klar geregelt ist dann ist das Statement auch klar wenn man dann mal eine verbrennt.
Begrüßen das ist so klar geregelt ist dann ist das Statement auch klar wenn man Ja ja.
Bevor das so im Sinne von Polizist könnte auch hinüber gehen und sagen Ich habs nicht gesehen.
So ein bisschen nach der Frankfurter Schule also eine Demonstration die genehmigt wird die man eigentlich nicht machen die anderen diesen gut.
Er Genau weil durch das Verbrennen einer Fahne geht ja erstmal nichts materiell kaputt. Also eine Flagge die 100 Euro kostet oder.
Und wenn man es noch deutlicher Symbol mäßig aufladen kann durch so ein Gesetz finde ich sollte man das unter der Hand auch begrüßen.
Und wenn man es aber deutlich als Symbol mäßig aufladen kann. Mit so einem Gesetz sollte man das unter der Hand auch begrüßen.
Damit es dazu kommt dass das Symbol dann auch erkannt wird als solches also Verunglimpfung wieder anders.
Dazu kommt dass es dann auch erkannt wird.
Kann man glaube ich als Politiker nicht so gut im Bundestag.
Im Juni wurde sehr ausführlich debattiert. Es ging um Kriminalität im Netz und wie man damit umgeht.
Tagesschau.
Diesem.
Bericht.
Nicht zu vernachlässigen ist.
Mord oder Vergewaltigung Drohungen sollen mit bis zu drei Jahren Haft bestraft werden.
Bislang war es ein Jahr für Beleidigungen im Netz ist in Zukunft eine Freiheitsstrafe von bis zu zwei Jahren möglich.
Wer Kommunalpolitiker verleumdet dem drohen bis zu fünf Jahre Haft. Das galt bislang nur für Bundes oder Landespolitiker.
Die AfD lehnt das Gesetz ab. Die Linke hält es für wirkungslos weil sich Täter selten durch das Strafmaß von einer Tat abschrecken lassen.
Zu denken man könne Rechtsextremismus mit einem schärferen Strafrecht stoppen wie es die Koalition tut. Das ist reinste Augenwischerei.
Umstritten auch eine erweiterte Meldepflicht für die sozialen Netzwerke.
Sie müssen bestimmte Hasspostings etwa Volksverhetzung oder Morddrohungen nicht mehr nur löschen oder sperren sondern beim Bundeskriminalamt melden,
was massenhaft Benutzerdaten ohne vorherige rechtliche Prüfung nur auf Grund einer Entscheidung von privaten Diensten Anbieter ans BKA geben und da erst einmal bleiben. Das ist nicht in Ordnung.
Die Antwort der Regierung nur so seien schnellere Ermittlungen möglich.
Schwierig diese Weitergabe stattfinden.
Eigentlich war das ja auch selbstverständlich dass der Kronthaler ausgeben zu müssen.
Eigentlich selbstverständlich Konzerne.
Das hat sich ja inzwischen sehr verändert.
Das hat sich ja inzwischen sehr verändert. Wir werden da im Salon nochmal darauf eingehen den Microsoft Anwaltsverein der Regierung besser zusammengearbeitet hat.
Das Buch,
von dem Microsoft Anwalt irgendwann mit der Regierung besser zusammengearbeitet hat in Bezug auf Snowden und das ist sicherlich ein sehr sehr großes Problem.
Hinzukaufen Das ist sicherlich ein sehr großes Problem und dann auch diese Frage.
Ja es gibt ja ganz deutlich strafbar.
Es gibt ja ganz deutlich Dinge die sind auch schon strafbar.
Das sollten wir uns jetzt mal im Detail ansehen möchte ich aber noch in Erinnerung rufen ein Zitat von Horst Seehofer in Bezug auf die Kolumne Das war ja der Aufreger des Monats.
Mal.
Gelesen ich habe gesucht aber ich habe sie ja nicht mehr gefunden.
Ich habe sie gelesen. Jakobi in der taz geschrieben hat.
Sie ist ein satirischer Beitrag in dem überlegt wird wenn es den Kapitalismus noch gibt aber man keine Polizisten mehr braucht.
Was macht man eigentlich dann mit denen. Und dann steht da,
verschiedene Szenarien durch weil die Polizisten ja ohnehin faschistoid seien und Probleme haben ihre Gewalt unter Kontrolle zu haben und dann,
überlegt sie auf Bio Bauernhöfe kann man sie auch nicht bringen.
Es gibt dann die überlegung Man könnte sie auf Bio Bauernhöfe schaffen aber das ist dann auch nichts das sind ja eher so Szene Jobs ohnehin schon für Neonazis schreibt sie.
Und so weiter und so fort und dann endet diese Kolumne und das war dann eben der Stein des Anstoßes.
Sie schreibt Spontan fällt mir nur eine geeignete Option ein die Mülldeponie,
nicht als Müll Menschen mit Schlüsseln zu Häusern sondern auf der Halde wo sie wirklich nur von Abfall umgeben sind unter ihresgleichen fühlen Sie sich bestimmt auch selber am wohlsten.
Also werden Polizisten mit Müll verglichen und das ist etwas was dann auch für viel Wirbel gesorgt hat.
Im übrigen Wir wollen jetzt nicht diese ganze Debatte abbilden das ist glaube ich auch hinreichend getan..
Sagen dadurch dass es eine Beleidigung aller ist und nicht konkret auf eine Person kann man kaum rechtlich handhaben und es zeigt auch dem Leser,
es ist natürlich übertrieben weil wir wissen auch Man kann nicht so ein Urteil über 250 000 Menschen Fällen ist es eigentlich ein mitdenkende Leser. Alles ersichtlich und.
Hätte sie gesagt die Polizisten aus Koblenz.
Dann wäre es ganz anders dann hätte man auch strafrechtliche Möglichkeiten.
Ich will auf eine Parodie dieser Kolumne hinweisen.
Auf Facebook gefunden ein Linker Redakteur bei einer linken Zeitung beim Freitag,
mit Bezug auf die Autorin wo würde eigentlich Schifferer arbeiten wenn sie keine Kolumnen mehr schriebe und der Kapitalismus noch weiter besteht.
Dann geht das auch mal so durch Supermarktkasse geht ja nicht da würde sie wieder,
mit Dreadlocks über cultural appropriation aufklären obwohl sie wahrscheinlich nur eine Pizza Hawaii haben wollen und da bleiben wahrscheinlich auf Dauer die Kunden weg außer der Supermarkt steht irgendwo auf dem platten Land wo es keine.
Gibt und keine Pizza Hawaii natürlich tattoo artist ginge auch nicht wegen Trubels und so.
Siehe oben Müllhalde ginge halt auch nicht weil die Mitarbeiterinnen der städtischen Abfall Betriebe sicher streiken würden wenn sie eine Kollegin bekommen würden,
die über ihren Job als letzte Chance für rassistische Arschlöcher mit autoritärem Charakter witzelt.
Wäre schlecht fürs Arbeitsklima und der Betrieb würde ins Stocken geraten. Nicht gut.
Mir fällt eigentlich nur ein Job ein der passen würde. Jakobi Verra wird Polizistin als Polizistin muss man ja auch ständig Leuten sagen was die nicht hören wollen und die müssen rechtsstaatlich gegebenen Rahmen auch zuhören.
Aber leider scheint dieser Weg auch verbaut zu sein siehe Müllhalde mitten in einer Zeitungskrise.
Das ist sehr schön auf den Punkt gebracht aber deswegen hab ich das nochmal aufgegriffen.
Nochmal auf diese Debatte in einer anderen Weise kommen weil es von Seehofer ja diese überlegung gab.
Die Kolumnistin der taz anzuzeigen und er sagte dann folgendes,
eine Enthemmung der Worte führt unweigerlich zu einer Enthemmung der Taten und zu Gewaltexzessen genauso wie wir es jetzt in Stuttgart gesehen haben.
Das dürfen wir nicht weiter hinnehmen diese überlegung Aus Worten werden Taten die wir uns jetzt mal nach der Reihe an SPD-Abgeordneter Johannes Fechner da geht es jetzt um die,
Kriminalität im Netz.
Wir müssen feststellen dass sich Hass und Hetze gerade aus der rechtsradikalen Ecke immer mehr im Netz ausbreitet und dass wir allzu oft sehen dass aus diesen Worten dann Taten werden und dass Liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das dürfen wir nicht länger hinnehmen.
Wir müssen mehr dagegen tun dass sich Hass und Hetze im Netz ausbreitet und unsere Gesellschaft vergiftet. Liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Deswegen bin ich Justizministerin. Lamprecht sehr dankbar dass sie auch bei diesem Thema schnell einen guten Gesetzesentwurf vorgelegt hat mit ganz verschiedenen Maßnahmen und denen wir auch noch erweitert haben.
Meine Damen und Herren das ist also wie Sie sehen ein ganz wichtiges Gesetz ein starkes Signal für eine wehrhafte Demokratie für einen starken Rechtsstaat.
Ich fand das Wahnsinn als diese Diskussion in die Richtung ging weil wenn man sich vorstellt Zeitungskrise er Niemand liest mehr Zeitung,
und dann unterstellt man dass die Stuttgarter Partyszene 18 jährige besoffene männliche Jungs in Gruppen,
am Vortag nochmal die taz lesen und dann besonders motiviert zu sein hat das ist so hanebüchen.
Auch die taz. Ich glaube in ganz Koblenz gibt es nur an einem Ort die taz zu kaufen das ist der Koblenzer Hauptbahnhof.
Dort sind dann drei Ausgaben und wenn man abends dort ist dann liegen die drei noch da und manchmal Erbarme ich mich und kaufe schon mal um zu gucken ob die Zeitung noch gibt.
Wahnsinn.
Also unabhängig davon meine Worte Taten und so weiter aber dieses konkrete Szenario ist wirklich das zieht man die Schuhe aus.
Ja ja.
Ja Worte werden taten das meint auch der CDU-Abgeordnete Jan Marco Luczak.
In der Anonymität des Netzes. Da finden wir ganz oft den Nährboden für Hass und Hetze für Beleidigung Bedrohung und für andere ganz furchtbare Dinge wie.
In der Anonymität des Netzes den Nährboden für Hass und Hetze für Beleidigungen und für andere ganz furchtbare Dinge wie.
Für andere Dinge wie.
Kinderpornografie und die Worte die wir dort erleben die werden leider oftmals dann auch zu Taten und.
Die Worte die wir dort erleben die werden leider oftmals dann auch zu Taten ja auch alles rein. Ryan.
Die Worte die wir dort erleben Sie werden leider oftmals auch zu Taten,
Topf auf einmal durch Rühren dazu Dann servieren.
Genau jetzt FDP Was sagen die Benjamin Strasser liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen Was.
Liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen Hass und Gewalt sind die logische Konsequenz einer gewalttätigen Sprache und auswerten.
Sind die logische Konsequenz einer gewalttätigen Sprache.
Um auswerteten Worten werden leider taten. Deshalb kann man sich hier eben nicht hinstellen und.
Worten werden leider taten.
Deshalb kann man sich hier eben nicht hinstellen und sich wundern wenn man selber ein Klima der Angst vor Fremden schafft das sich dann Leute in Deutschland bemüßigt fühlen aufgrund dieses gesellschaftlichen Resonanzboden zu Taten zu.
Sich wundern wenn man selber ein Klima der Angst vor Fremden schafft dass sich dann Leute in Deutschland bemüßigt fühlen aufgrund dieses gesellschaftlichen Resonanzboden zu Taten zu schreiten.
Ich habe mich gefragt.
Eine Erinnerung dabei an Computerspiele Ballerspiele,
auch raus mit der Waffe in Schulen oder sonst irgendwo rein.
Es gibt eine sehr sehr lange Debatte genau darüber.
Diese Debatte kann Sprache verletzen.
Wörter wie.
In der Linguistik nachgegangen so nennen letzten 15 Jahren hat man das ziemlich ausführlich getan hat über verletzende Sprache gesprochen aber man hat auch immer gefragt ob Hassreden Taten folgen.
Das Ganze geht sehr stark zurück auf eine amerikanische Debatte die aber auch damals ins Deutsche übersetzt wurde und zwar auf die,
Pornografie Debatte die von Feministinnen von bestimmten Feministinnen losgetreten wurde weil,
Pornografie im Feminismus eine berühmte,
McKinnon gewesen hat ein Buch geschrieben auch auf Deutsch übersetzt nur Worte heißt das und eigentlich muss man da schon das Fragezeichen hinter.
Den Ausschnitt. Was sie da in ihrem Buch schreibt.
Früher oder später auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise wollen die Konsumenten die Pornografie in drei Dimensionen weiter ausleben.
Früher oder später auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise tun sie es.
Sie bringt sie dazu das zu wollen wenn sie glauben sie können es wenn sie glauben sie kommen damit unbehelligt davon.
Tun sie es je nach der von ihnen gewählten Sphäre der Umsetzung können sie die Macht benutzen die sie haben um die Welt einen pornografischen Ort bleiben zu lassen,
so dass sie weiterhin vom Alltag.
Ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr beliebtes Argument das allerdings sowohl bei den Kinder bei den Computerspielen als auch bei dieser Pornografie bei der es zur Sache geht ist die Studienlage,
so viel aussagen dass man gar keine Tendenz herauslesen kann und aus den etwas konkreteren Beratungsgesprächen hat man dann wieder dass die Jugendlichen sehr wohl ihre Sexualität unter Kontrolle haben und nicht nur,
Computerspiele vielleicht sogar komplett abstrahiert werden können von der Gewalt weil einfach mittlerweile Der Trend geht in die Richtung zu geselligen,
Beisammensein und so weiter und das sei derGewalt Aspekt im Grunde austauschbar ist da hat eine gewisse Attraktivität und Funktionalität aber spielt nicht eine prägende inhaltliche Rolle oder sowas.
Ich würde auch überlegen ob gerade jetzt bei den Computerspielen stattfindet eher eine Zähmung am Ende herstellt.
Ich muss mich fragen Wie ist denn das eigentlich bei Beleidigungen oder bei einem sprechen das in gewisser Weise verunglimpft.
Wir machen das ja im Privaten durchaus.
Wir telefonieren mit Freunden und uns über irgendetwas aufregen und dann eine Wortwahl wählen die wir jetzt nicht,
an den Tag legen würden. Ich erinnere mich bei der Sache auch an meine Großmutter die unglaublich viel Nachrichten guckte.
Aber das war ein sehr interessanter Effekt. Sie kommentierte immer dann diese Statements von Politikern die sie nicht mochte und sie war SPD-Wählern wusste man wie sie nicht mochte,
sagte sie dann immer wenn sie sprachen sagte sie dass ein alter Depp eine dumme Kuh.
So wurde das permanent einsortiert wenn CDU-Politiker auftraten Das Tolle war aber dass die Nachrichten vorbei waren oder bzw. wenn das Wetter schon kam war dieser Prozess abgeschlossen.
Man hat das einmal so ausgesprochen Man hat das ist eine dumme Kuh.
Und damit beendete man aber auch das politische und machte sich nach dem Wetter Gedanken darüber was man wohl morgen backen könnte oder ob man spazieren gehen.
Wir haben unten im Wohnzimmer verschiedene Bücher die Motz.
Da ist auch extra eine Motzkus dabei. Das ist ein kleines Kissen aus Stoff.
Das nimmt man in die Hand und dann wirft man es in die Ecke.
Dann gibt's natürlich den Dax der hat schlechte Laune begleitet man dann einmal durchs Buch.
Er hat nämlich immer schlechte Laune und sagt dass er auch jeden bis jeder schlechte Laune hat.
Dann stellt er am Ende fest die haben alle wegen mir schlechte Laune. Na gut dann kann ich das vielleicht auch steuern.
So wie du das geschildert hast so kann man Fernsehen gucken und so kriegt man ja auch gelehrt.
Es ist ja nicht so dass man in der Erziehung irgendwie den Kindern sagt Du darfst keine Emotionen zeigen oder so.
Sondern es heißt Emotions Regulierung und da werden natürlich Räume geschaffen.
Und das haben ja gerade jetzt alle gemerkt.
Wenn diese Räume plötzlich neu justiert werden müssen dann.
Hat es Effekte auf die Räume wo man bisher dachte dass man rausgehalten Separieren von Emotionen wie auch bei Star Trek übrigens ohne die ganzen Vulkanier die leben ja gar nicht ohne Emotionen.
Die haben nur die Emotionen in ihrer Geschichte unterdrückt.
Und dann kommen die aber in diese Phasen. Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau wie es heißt.
Wo sie dann auch auf Partnersuche sind und so weiter und da leben sie es dann komplett aus. Die ganzen aufgestauten Emotionen.
Sind keine Roboter sondern irgendwo immer. Deswegen würde ich da auch total sympathisieren mit so einer dass die Nachrichten auch die Funktion haben,
zu sagen Das sind jetzt die 30 Minuten Zeit die wir dir geben um die ganzen Idioten mal zu sehen mit ihren bescheuerten O-Tönen.
Dann regt man sich darüber auf und dann ist aber auch wieder gut.
Zurück in die Bundestagsdebatte hören jetzt mal es muss sein den Abgeordneten.
Hassreden meine Damen und Herren sind auch kein Rechtsbegriff und auch bestimmt keine Straftat.
Wäre dies anders hätte man heute Morgen bereits Martin Schulz für seine Hasstiraden im Rahmen der Europa-Debatte zur Rechenschaft ziehen sollen und es müssten sich auch Verfahren anschließen.
Das.
Wenn Frau Bayram oder Frau Hasselmann oder Herr Kahrs damals von vorne gesprochen hat denn das war und ist immer Hass pur.
Das muss man ertragen aber eine Straftat ist es nicht.
Zunächst kommt ja auch der Hass nicht aus einer Richtung. Einige Beispiele für linke Exponenten habe ich gerade genannt.
Ist.
Andere Beispiele finden sich in der Presse die taz beispielsweise die alle Polizisten auf Müllkippen entsorgen möchte wie an den Staatsfunk Stichwort Umweltzone.
Wir haben linke Parteien die reiche erschießen oder in Gulags stecken wollen.
Selbstverständlich alles ziemlich wahnsinnig. Und doch muss man unreguliert,
nicht immer nur nach einer Seite waren das Ganze auch so überschrieben dass man eben jetzt im Zuge von Hanau und all diesen Dingen möchte man jetzt,
mehr Rechtsklarheit schaffen oder strengere Regeln aufsetzen.
Aber man muss sich auch mal fragen bei solchen Maßnahmen wo beschneidet man dann auch auf anderer Seite weshalb so ein Applaus von links nicht sofort angebracht ist.
Ich erinnere auch daran dass es am 17.
August 1946 das KPD Verbot womit man auch etwas eingeschränkt hat man beruft sich in der Debatte auf die wehrhafte Demokratie.
Das ist ein sehr sehr schwieriger Begriff der von der einen Seite von Interesse und mal von der anderen.
Diese Einschränkungen sind wirklich mit Vorsicht zu genießen wenngleich ich noch gar nicht so genau weiß wie sich,
das für absolute,
Grenzen des Diskurses.
Wann war diese Auseinandersetzung über die Kolumne.
Weil diese Auseinandersetzung relativ spät,
genau das war jetzt acht Tage her glaube ich.
Genau am 18. 6. hatte der Bundestag tatsächlich beschlossen dass es jetzt ein Gesetz zur Bekämpfung des Rechtsextremismus und der Kriminalität gibt.
Doch.
Ja und die zielt nämlich gar nicht so sehr wie er sagte der Hass kriminalisiert gibt's ja gar nicht und so kann man irgendwie so sagen weil das läuft am Ende unter Beleidigungen nicht unter Hass und so irgendwie ein bisschen na ja gut branden.
Aber es hat ja auch noch so eine institutionelle Dimension bei der Ehe stand.
Es gibt jetzt die Pflicht für die Betreiber großer sozialer Netzwerke wie Facebook Twitter und so weiter.
Strafrechtlich relevante Inhalte wie Hass Beiträge Terrorismus Propaganda oder Bedrohungen und Darstellungen sexuellen Kindesmissbrauchs über die aktuelle Lage sei alles reingerutscht,
nicht mehr nur zu löschen sondern parallel unaufgefordert ebenfalls zusammen mit aussagekräftigen Internet Kennungen.
Also alles was man findet Namen PIN-Nummern und so weiter. Inklusive Porth Nummern. Selbst bei E-Mails,
ist das ein rauslaufen ans Bundeskriminalamt zu melden.
Und da kommt natürlich auch wieder die neutrale Plattform in Bedrängnis.
Inhaltlich tätig zu werden bzw. sich so zu verhalten dass dann die Polizei das Bundeskriminalamt tätig werden kann.
In der Hinsicht konnte brandneues zum letzten Mal so ein Spruch machen es gibt ja gar keine Kriminalität sondern hier sind schon Handlungsreisende Gesetze jetzt seit Juni auch am Start die sowas einfangen sollen.
Die auch in gewisser Weise den Konzernen erst einmal eine ganz eigenartige Macht einräumen nämlich dass die erst einmal da entscheiden.
Was ist jetzt da weiterzugeben und was nicht. Und wen werden die da beschäftigen die das dann entscheiden was da weitergegeben wird. Oder wird dann einfach auch mal pro Jahr besser gehen wir mal mehr weiter als zu wenig.
All diese Sachen und wenn es da um Passwörter und so weiter geht nochmal zum Schluss den Linken-Abgeordneten.
Zudem schießen sie schießen einige änderungen am Ziel vorbei.
Nehmen wir etwa die Ausweitung des Tatbestandes der Bedrohung in Paragraf 241 Strafgesetzbuch.
Geht es nach der Koalition soll es künftig strafbar sein jemanden mit einer einfachen Körperverletzung zu drohen.
Mit ihrer änderung werden Alltags Sprüche wie Ich klatscht ja gleich eine die öfter mal auf einem Schulhof gesagt wird direkt zur Straftat.
Es ist zweifellos nicht die feine Art solche Sprüche zu klopfen.
Aber es ist kein Fall für die Strafjustiz und zudem ändern Sie das Netzwerk Durchsetzung und Telemediengesetz.
Sie wollen dass Betreiber sozialer Netzwerke die IP-Adressen der Ersteller von Beiträgen an das Bundeskriminalamt BKA herausgeben und zwar immer dann wenn eventuell eine Straftat vorliegt.
Da Facebook und Co. kaum genau juristisch prüfen werden was eine Straftat ist und was nicht.
Wenn massenhaft Daten an das BKA übermittelt werden. Das ist eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung durch die Hintertür.
Und sie wollen auch noch die Koalition dass die Strafverfolgungsbehörden in Zukunft Passwörter für Online-Konten fragen dürfen wir als Linke lehnen diese Datensammelei.
Es ist ein bisschen zweischneidig weil erst einmal darf jeder der Polizei alle möglichen Verdachtsfälle so nennen.
Die Frage ist halt ob man für irgendwie eine Pflicht draus macht und dann den Rahmen so zieht dass man sagt Okay das war jetzt Pflicht dich zu melden und das ist nicht in Sicht.
Dieses herunterbrechen auf Klatsch gleich.
Ich glaube das werden die BKA Leute und spätestens die Richter dann schon entsprechend würdigen.
Auf der anderen Seite ist halt die Frage Wir haben es hier mit einem extrem unsichtbaren Raum zu tun.
Es ist ja nun seit 6 Jahren so dass Facebook diese Gruppen so voranbringen und das Telegram so erfolgreich ist über diese Gruppen und so weiter.
Es geht hier schon um große bisher in dem Falle dann wirklich rechtsfreie Räume weil Juristen da gar nicht hingucken konnten und weil auch die Dokumentation.
Man weiß ja gar nicht Wie dokumentiert man jetzt irgendwie Richard Gutjahr in irgendwelchen Streams dann nochmal erklärt.
Achtet darauf dass die Orell dabei ist und sowas das kann ja nun auch nicht die Lösung sein dass man so einen Verbraucherschutz Journalismus irgendwie zum Thema Wie dokumentiere eigentlich,
und dann ist Frage was denn eigentlich Wie dokumentiert man richtig wie ein Screenshot unserer Ansicht,
finde ich das gar nicht.
Also ich verstehe seine Haltung. Aber wer weiß vielleicht ist das wieder so ein Gesetz das sich erst mal bewähren muss und dann wieder ein bisschen zurechtgestutzt.
Ein bisschen Angst dass das Industrie noch weiter.
Wir haben ja jetzt schon das erfährt man ja auch ständig bei Twitter.
Auch wenn es um Influencer oder so geht. Alles in Bewegung setzen damit sie ja nicht irgendwo dargestellt werden und dort werden dann auch immer wieder,
versucht wird versucht jemand,
zu überführen.
Die leiseste Kritik wird als Beleidigung aufgefasst Einschüchterungsversuch und Redefreiheit.
Wenn man diesen Rahmen enger macht. Mir ist schon diese akute Bedrohung auch ganz bewusst.
Die ist ja nicht von der Hand zu weisen. Aber dennoch haben wir doch momentan so eine Tendenz dazu dass man tatsächlich dann in die Situation kommt ich das noch so hab ich dann schon wieder Probleme,
Klarheit geschaffen. Okay das kann man sagen.
Also kann ich jemanden auf Twitter als Idioten bezeichnen wenn er,
sage ich ein Idiot oder habe ich dann schon ein rechtliches Problem oder muss ich so die Harald Schmidt Strategie verfolgen der ja auch immer Angst hatte dass er irgendwie Dinge von sich gibt.
Zehntausende mussten ausgegeben werden für Anwaltskosten selbstverständlich.
Aber seine Strategie war dann immer wenn er wirklich jemanden eigentlich verunglimpfen wollte was er natürlich aus rechtlichen Gründen nicht konnte.
Er ist der klügste Minister den wir in Deutschland haben wir sind einfach glücklich dass er Kompetenz ausstrahlt.
Da gibt's natürlich die ganz den ganz einfachen Forrest Gump Ausweg.
Dumm ist der der Dummes tut und wenn man jemanden beleidigen oder kritisieren will dann muss man das in einen Wortteil Werturteil über ein Verhalten. Und damit ist man eigentlich immer fein raus.
Niemand ist ein Idiot aber ziemlich viele tun idiotische Sachen und das kann man dann auch so markieren.
Das bezieht sich dann immer auf etwas das man ohne die ganze Person in Beschlag zu nehmen ohne,
seine Person gegenüber zu sein Verhalten nicht gibt's also ein paar Auswege bei denen ich mir denke Da fehlt auch juristischer Druck damit solche kommunikativen Feinheiten mal zum Vorschein kommen.
Denn es wird ein bisschen zu viel beleidigt und es wird zu wenig raffiniert auf ein begründetes Urteil Warum ist irgendetwas wirklich idiotisch.
Das ist dann wieder zu selten zu viel an der Person und zu wenig am Verhalten festgemacht.
Was in Amerika absolut gang und gäbe ist. Ich schaue ja abends bei YouTube Shows von Joan Rivers die ja vor ein paar Jahren gestorben ist und.
Bezeichnet. Welche prominenten Leute Politiker Stars.
Irgendwelche Prominenten,
das ist Teil der.
Das ist doch einfach Teil der Kultur und sorgen dann hin und wieder wenn sie dann Post von einem Anwalt bekommen Sie bekommen zum Beispiel.
Spaßkultur und da macht man sich auch keine Sorgen und dann hin und wieder wenn sie dann Post von irgendeinem Anwalt bekommt sie bekommt z.B.
Arbeitsform Stuart benachrichtigte.
Kristen Stewart dann wird sie einmal richtig in die Mangel genommen.
Da kommt es darauf an ob man sowas gerne schaut oder so. Die Frage ist ob diejenigen die damit adressiert sind sich damit einverstanden erklären müssen.
Ich hatte ja schon tendierende um nicht so sehr.
Die 25 Millionen sollen den Mund halten.
Hier. Na ja klar Wenn dieses Argument wird auch immer der Satire ein bisschen nur nach oben.
Also ich muss auch sagen dass ich es finde bei Leuten die in der öffentlichkeit stehen ist es einfach etwas anderes wie wenn ich jetzt jemanden nehme bei Twitter ein privates,
Profil hat und eigentlich nicht in der öffentlichkeit steht vielleicht wirklich Kommunalpolitiker ist und nur für den kleinen Bereich was macht,
Sprecher eines Vereins der eigentlich nur ein Ruderverein ist.
Dann kann ich den nicht in der Art angreifen wie das dann auch geschieht und das geht nicht.
Ich muss jetzt für mich sagen wenn ich so präsent bin so kritisch gegenüber irgendwelchen Film oder sonst was zu sein das ich beschimpft werde in vielen Foren.
Das macht mir überhaupt nichts aus ich hab nie auch nur im Geringsten nachgedacht da irgendwo mal zu schauen ob ich da klagen könnte.
Da gibt es zuhauf zu finden. Ich war ja früher auch.
Einmal die Woche Video des Tages die Analyse und da gabs wirklich ganz viel runter und die haben glaub ich auch schon viel gelöscht.
Ich hab nichts löschen. Mir ist das vollkommen egal.
Also ich finde wenn man so in der öffentlichkeit steht dann muss man damit leben dass das so ist wenn das Privatleben wollen und die nicht diese öffentlichkeit wollen dann ist es schlimm.
Entweder die oder man hat noch Menschen die nicht Privatleben wollen aber ein öffentliches Leben wollen aber im bestimmten Rahmen.
Denn hier geht es ja erst einmal auch darum zu sagen Es ist jetzt ein Gesetz das die Dienste Betreiber in die Verantwortung nimmt.
Gastbeiträge Terrorismus Propaganda. Was dann an die Polizei zu melden. Da spielt er erstmal einen Anwalt der sich nochmal bereichert das man keine große Rolle.
Und dann hat man natürlich noch diesen großen politischen Bereich und,
was Winfried Kretschmann hat jetzt seine Facebook-Seite zugemacht nachdem es mal eine Auswertung gab 4000 Beleidigungen Drohungen und Falschaussagen und Verschwörungstheorien innerhalb von 20 Stunden.
Was Winfried Kretschmann hat jetzt seine Facebook-Seite zugemacht nachdem es mal eine Auswertung gab 4000 Beleidigungen Drohungen und Falschaussagen und Verschwörungstheorien innerhalb von 20 Stunden.
Das kann man zum einen nicht mehr moderieren und zum anderen übertönt das auch jede andere Kommunikation die man auf Facebook mit Wählern oder wem auch immer hat.
Das kann man auch nicht mehr alles zu Gericht bringen nämlich alle Gerichte.
Wahrscheinlich auch nicht genau. Man könnte das allerdings mit so einer etwas schneller verschaltet. Aber da wird es dann wieder heikel.
Dass das BKA da kurz drüber guckt und sagt Ja bitte löschen alles im Sinne von also wirklich mal gibts einen lustigen Spruch wie.
Krank der große deutsche Lets Player mal so meinte.
Also wenn auf Facebook oder bei YouTube einfach zu viel passiert in den Kommentaren einfach mal alles löschen. Weg damit.
Weil am Ende ist es auch wieder diese spontane Kommunikation. Wen stört es denn wirklich.
Selbst die Autoren wenn es da nicht mehr da sind dann würde es dann einfach mal alles löscht weil wenn die Alternative ist,
das nicht die Kommentare gelöscht werden sondern der Anlass Winfried Kretschmanns politische Kommunikation gerade jetzt in Stuttgart gewissen sozialen Notlagen.
Das kann ja auch keine Antwort sein. Wenn das aber die einzige ist die hier gewählt wurde ist das halt auch wieder ein Problem der Ansicht ist dass so eine,
Lage im Fluss bei der man immer gucken muss irgendwie ob man,
froh dass hier nicht wieder der Ausweg der AKP gewählt wurde sondern dass es jetzt erstmal ein Gesetz gibt das ist ja auch wieder was kommt noch in die AGB schreiben da muss sich doch der Bundestag nicht mit befassen.
Und dann sieht man zwar ein paar Defizite auf die man sich dann auch mal kritisieren kann.
Aber es fand wenigstens im Bundestag statt und ist am Ende ein Gesetz bei dem wir wissen wie wir damit institutionell umgehen.
Also wenn wir jetzt irgendwie wieder so eine halbgare keine Ahnung Zugeständnis von Mark Zuckerberg oder sowas haben wie man mit sowas umgeht und Content Moderation irgendwo.
Fachanwälte,
ein gutes Stichwort.
Grünen-Politiker Cem özdemir Der hat dem Springer-Verlag ein Interview gegeben.
Wir haben keinen politischen Hintergrund. Es ist erst kein Anlass zur Entwarnung im Gegenteil das macht es eher schwieriger denn bei dem politischen Hintergrund ist klar wohin man ermittelt.
Wir sind hier in Deutschland mit dem Maul halten.
Ich rede gerade mal zur Seite.
Özdemir und Gewalt liegt hier gar nicht so sehr bei.
Dem Satz Wir sind hier in Deutschland Wir haben hier zwar einen Politiker der einen Migrationshintergrund hat diesen jedoch immer wieder thematisiert.
Aber wir haben einen starken ausländischen Akzent sprechenden der von einer Polizei Diktatur redet was sicherlich ein wenig übertrieben ist.
Aber irgendetwas sagt dann noch etwas von 1200 Euro Strafe für irgendetwas.
Denken wir daran wie hart die Polizei gegen manche Coruña Verstöße vorgegangen ist und wo sie dann weg blickt wenn es zum Beispiel in einem Edelrestaurant in Berlin drunter und drüber geht.
Ein Anliegen das artikuliert der vielleicht nicht ganz so fein aber die Antwort darauf.
Wir sind hier in Deutschland das ist eigentlich ziemlich skandalös und man könnte sich denken ohne Migrationshintergrund gesagt hätte was daraus entstanden wäre.
Wieso hat er das überhaupt gesagt. Es fällt ja auch sehr aus dem Rahmen des zurückhaltendes dieser Personen. Wir sind hier in Deutschland. Wir haben hier Regeln die du noch nicht kennst du Hinterwäldler oder was.
Wir haben hier Regeln.
Ja
auch eine Form der sprachlichen Gewalt die man da erleben kann.
Und überhaupt Die sprachliche Gewalt ist ein Thema.
Selbstverständlich auch durch den Diskurs über Gender Theory jetzt wieder erneut oder eigentlich ständig im Gange ist.
Man muss aber jetzt hier nochmal einen Schritt zurücktreten. Wir haben wenn wir über Political Correctness.
Gender Theorie die Political Correctness haben will eigentlich die Sprache,
alle Ungleichheiten besiegt werden das geht ja zunächst einmal auf diese Anschauung zurück Von die Theorie sprechen ist auch handeln.
Es gibt performative Sprechakt.
Ich erkläre Sie hiermit zu Mann und Frau das Beamte und dann ist das so.
Aber man kann dieses performative des Sprechens auch weiterdenken und zum Beispiel sagen Wenn ich sage Stephan du bist ein Idiot dann mache ich damit eine Handlung die dich verletzt ich degradiere dich und all das,
ist immer auch Handlung.
Das hat die Sprachwissenschaftler umgetrieben aber auch Gender Theoretiker.
Es gibt ein Buch von Judith Butler die sicherlich die berühmteste Gender Theoretiker spricht in diesem Buch das sich wirklich jedem ans Herz legen kann auch jedem dem der Gender Theorie wenig anfangen kann.
In diesem Buch geht Judith Butler auf alle möglichen Fragen der Verletzung durch Sprache ein. Es geht um diese Sache.
Don't ask don't tell beim Militär ergab dass man Homosexuellen nicht fragen durfte ob sie homosexuell sind sie durften.
Dieses merkwürdige Agreement das dann aufgelöst wurde auch auf die Pornografie Debatte von McKinnon zu der sie Opposition geht.
Was ich jetzt mal rausgesucht habe ist eben die Frage Wie gehen wir eigentlich mit wem gehört die denn wem sie dann eigentlich noch gehören.
Ich habe das rausgesucht weil es vielleicht überraschen wird das aus der Theorie eine solche Position kommt.
Das Begehren keine offene Zukunft zu haben kann stark sein.
Bei politischen überlegungen darf die Kraft des Begehrens die Zukunft zu verwerfen nicht unterschätzt werden.
Es ist ein Grund dafür dass man es für gefährlich hält bestimmte Fragen zu stellen und das in der Zeit in der wir leben intellektuelle Arbeit in der öffentlichkeit so schlecht angesehen ist,
dafür dass das Klima an den Universitäten sich vor allem durch Antti Intellektualismus auszeichnet.
Man braucht sich nur vorzustellen was mir einer meiner Studenten erzählt hat der ein Buch las und sich dabei dachte,
ich kann mir die Fragen um die es hier geht nicht stellen denn damit würde ich anfangen an meinen politischen überzeugungen zu zweifeln und das könnte dazu führen dass sich diese überzeugungen verliere.
In so einer Situation wird die Angst vor dem Denken und die Angst vor dem Fragen zur Moralisten Verteidigung der Politik.
Politische und intellektuelle Arbeit werden auseinandergerissen.
Politik wird genau das was einen gewissen Antti Intellektualismus erfordert weigert man sich eine politische Position zu überdenken.
Wenn sich bestimmte Fragen stellen dann entscheidet man sich auf Kosten des Lebens und Denkens.
Für einen dogmatischen Standpunkt.
Sehr gute Definition von Dogma.
Und sie plädiert hier wirklich für eine Freiheit des Denkens ein Denken das nicht Moralist sein muss. Das ist etwas was man häufig von konservativen Publizisten liest. Fleischhauer,
sagt Ja es gibt hier an Universitäten in ganz eigenartige Eintrübung des Denkens und.
Aber.
Schlussfolgerungen.
Ob man mit so kleinen Salzstöcken negieren kann dass diese Diskussion von Seiten feministischer Vordenker auch in sehr moralische.
Regieren kann. Dass diese Diskussion von Seiten.
Der Neunzigerjahre.
Poststrukturalismus sehr philosophisch geprägt. Sie kann mit diesen Vereinfachungen vorgenommen werden. Gender Mainstreaming am Ende doch recht wenig anfangen.
Solcher Dogmatismus zeigt sich auch in dem Bestreben sprechen das verletzt erregt bedroht oder beleidigt einzuschränken.
Ob bestimmte Repräsentationen Formen zensiert werden sollen oder der Bereich des öffentlichen Diskurses selbst eingeschränkt werden soll,
immer dämpft der Versuch sprechen zu reglementieren den politischen Impuls den effektiven Widerstand des Sprechens zu nutzen,
die intellektuelle Ablehnung von Fragen die den geläufigen Wirklichkeiten Bezug Bedrohungen liefert dafür den banalen Beleg wenn man einen Begriff wie das Subjekt oder Universalität in Frage stellt.
Fragt man danach welche Funktionen der Begriff erfüllt was mit ihm auf dem Spiel steht und auf welche Ziele er sich richtet wie er sich verändert.
Das Veränderliche Leben des Begriffs bedeutet nicht dass er nicht zu gebrauchen ist.
Wenn ein Begriff fraglich ist soll das etwa heißen dass er nicht weiter zu verwenden ist.
Dass wir also nur diejenigen Begriffe verwenden können die wir bereits beherrschen.
Von Vanessas.
Zumindest.
Epigonen und Apologeten aus Kolumnen und vielleicht ganz anders sehen. Wie könnte man denn eigentlich mit diesem Begriff,
beleidigend findet. Wie könnte man damit umgehen. Da macht sie jetzt einen Vorschlag der auch der Kern dieses Buches ist.
Ich möchte sogar behaupten dass gerade darin dass der herrschende autorisierte Diskurs enteignet werden kann.
Eine Möglichkeit seiner subversiven resigniert Kationen liegt,
was passiert zum Beispiel wenn diejenigen die nicht die gesellschaftliche Macht haben Freiheit oder demokratische Rechte für sich in Anspruch zu nehmen,
sich diese eifersüchtig gehüteten Begriffe aus dem herrschenden Diskurs aneignen sie für eine neue politische Bewegung umarbeiten und resignieren,
oder was genauso wichtig ist welche performative macht liegt darin,
wenn man sich gerade die Begriffe aneignet von denen man verletzt wurde um ihnen ihre degradiere Bedeutung zu nehmen oder aus dieser degradieren Bedeutung.
Eine Affirmation abzuleiten.
Wenn man sich im Zeichen des schwul Seins zusammenschließt oder die Kategorien Schwarz oder Frau neu bewertet.
Totaler Fan von.
Ihr Beispiel ist quer quer war ein böses Schimpfwort für Schwule und inzwischen würde niemand in Amerika sagen dass queer ein Schimpfwort ist weil die Schwulen es sich angeeignet haben.
Ich finde auf allen Ebenen Patriotismus z.B.
Umgang mit den deutschen Farben Umgang mit der Geschichte Umgang mit allen möglichen.
Zum einen dann hat man das nächste Themenfeld Post Wachstums ökonomie Man fragt sich ein bisschen Wieso.
Wir wollen doch Wachstum von Zufriedenheit Lebenserwartung Gesundheit Wir wollen eigentlich die Wachstums Apologeten irgendwie sagen aber wir geben den Begriff gerne auf so.
Es gibt so viel Felder wo das alles zurückerobert werden muss und umgedeutet sodass man sozusagen diejenigen die schon seit 20 30 Jahren von Wachstum sprechen so Friedrich Merz.
Wenn der jetzt kommt und CDU-Chef werden will und es mit so einer Wachstums Debatte führen will dann finde ich sollte man mit ihm genau eine Wachstums Debatte führen und nicht sagen Ich bin aber gegen Wachstum übrigens und da eine Konfrontation aufmachen will das wäre alles verschenkt dann,
muss es dann die Chance nutzen und dann einfach klug in solchen Debatten einspringen.
Da bin ich großer großer Fan.
Man sieht also mit der Sprache sehr viel mehr möglich als einfach nur schlecht das müssen wir einhegen.
Da muss man schauen ob man nicht gerade auch etwas sich aneignen kann was,
wiederum ein sehr sehr progressiver Prozess den davon nicht vernachlässigen wenngleich wir es selbstverständlich bei diesen Debatten im Bundestag auch Morddrohungen oder so.
Da kann ich nicht sagen auch meine eigene hat da sicherlich selbstverständlich.
Aber wir merken das hier in den 90er Jahren ein offener Diskurs über das Thema Sprache geführt wurde im übrigen auch in der Linguistik.
Es gibt ja auch eine feministische Linguistik die aber auch viel diverser war. So kann ich das zumindest sagen.
Ich habe mir einen überblick darüber verschafft.
Es war keineswegs so dass alle immer sehr gut auch aus feministischer Perspektive gab es da durchaus andere Positionen zu,
all diesen sprachlichen Dingen eine enorme Kursveränderungen erlebt und auch in der Mitte angekommen ist was man dann sehen kann dass jetzt alle von CSU SPD CDU FDP sagen,
das ist etwas was noch nicht so selbstverständlich ist vor 20 Jahren oder vor 30 Jahren.
Naja man darf auch nie vergessen was Carl Schmitt,
meinte in der politischen Debatte ist jeder Begriff ein polemischer Begriff wie Demokratie.
Du hast jetzt gesagt Wachstum das kann man von der einen oder anderen Seite polemisieren mein Bruttoinlandsprodukt das muss schon so hoch sein dann haben wir Wachstum.
Die Menschen werden jetzt alle 95 Jahre alt.
Ein wunderbares Wachstum das zeigt sich polemisch aber mitunter ein bisschen schwierig gerade.
Von der New York Times.
Sinngemäß stand darin dass es jetzt gerade durch Black Lives Matter,
beschleunigte Entwicklungen in Zeitungen gibt dass eigentlich ein Generationenkonflikt Da ist von denen die sagen Wir wollen,
als Plattform für unterschiedliche sich widerstreitende Positionen sehen.
Und dann gibt es eine junge Generation die überwiegend sagt,
Es muss ein Ort sein an dem ich mich wohlfühle an dem ich nicht angegriffen werde in meiner Position und das sei jetzt gerade so ein Paradigmenwechsel der durch diese Bewegung beschleunigt werde.
Die Washington Post hat jetzt zwölf Stellen ausgeschrieben alle mit einem klaren Fokus Erstens,
Wie soll man sagen Die Themen von People of Color sollen behandelt werden aber auch von Betroffenen die selbst man macht.
Die Themen sollen behandelt werden aber auch von.
Man geht von einem Rekrutierung US-Modell. Da ist auch immer ein bisschen verlogen war aber das komplett auf Inhalte abstellte.
Man geht von einem Rekrutierung Modell das auch immer ein bisschen verloren war.
Aber das kommt jetzt auf Inhalte abstellte Atollen studiert hat und tolle Arbeitspunkt vorgelegt wurde und der war klar wen das erreicht hat.
Wer toll studiert hat und tolle Arbeitsproben vorgelegt hat der wurde und der war klar wen das erreicht hat und wer davon profitiert wer nicht und das will man jetzt radikal aufbrechen indem man.
Wenn man jetzt radikal aufbrechende indem man.
Polemisch würde man sagen Quoten Menschen in die Redaktion holt.
Identitätspolitik.
Genau das was auf Podiumsdiskussion zum Thema Was fehlt den Zeitungen eigentlich und warum ist Ihr Publikum weg weil ihr Publikum sich verändert hat die Redaktion nicht.
Jetzt muss man halt aggressiv Nacharbeiten also wirklich in die Stellenausschreibungen reinschreiben bisher stand ja immer drin.
Es entscheidet die Qualifikation und bei gleicher Qualifikation der Schwerbehindertenausweis an. Das war ja immer eine Lüge.
Da steht ja einfach nur drin weil es im Gesetz gefordert wird. Und jetzt geht man das aber bewusst an weil einem tatsächlich Publikum verloren geht und man holt.
Und das sind vor allem junge Menschen aus diversen Schichten zusammen die dann und das ist ja auch ein bisschen das Ziel von so einer Geschäftsführung auch intern erstmal,
soll man sagen auf den Redaktionen Frieden ein bisschen aufkündigen die mit ihren Maßstäben da reinkommen gleichzeitig.
Disruption.
Genau so eine Disruption veranstalten und sagen Na ja einfach nur aufschreiben was Sache ist.
Es reicht nicht und gleichzeitig hat man aber außerhalb im Publikum einen ganz großen Wunsch mittlerweile im angelsächsischen und im Deutschen in Deutschland extrem mit 80 Prozent Zustimmung geradezu dieser Aussage aber in den angelsächsischen eben auch zu sagen,
Medienhaus soll mir erst mal sagen was der Fall ist dann sollte da ein Strich drin sein.
Und dann kann man das von mir aus diskutieren was der Fall ist aber nicht in der ganzen Zeit über diese Gemengelage zusammen.
Auf der einen Seite hat man das natürlich nicht ohne Grund weil man eben die inhaltliche Berichterstattung.
Die Redaktion arbeitet und daneben dann Meinungen die auch eine Rolle spielen aber eben nicht aus der Redaktion herauskommen.
Das muss man jetzt irgendwie integrieren und gleichzeitig aber die Nachricht als Nachricht wieder mehr herausstellen.
Also genau wieder das nicht zulassen was da gefordert wird.
Und das ist natürlich eine Gemengelage die bringt Institutionen ins Wanken bringen. Sagen wir mal so.
Ja es ist auch eine heikle Sache die in gewisser Weise auch,
die jeweiligen immer für sich sprechen. Ich möchte nicht für irgendeine,
Identität sprechen.
Ich.
Muss das nicht nochmal markieren aber ich würde sagen da bin ich universalistische unterwegs und egal von wem vertreten werden.
Aber ich würde sagen es ist nicht universalistische unterwegs.
Es geht darum dass sie richtig vertreten werden dass sie richtig sind und bei der Identität eine Fokussierung auf die Identität vor allem auf die geschlechtliche Identität und die Herkunft,
haben das ist sehr interessanter sind auch Leute die für diese Identitätspolitik in den Medien treten immer sofort verschreckt wenn man das sagte ich entgegnen dann schon.
Mich würde auch interessieren wie die Identität die soziale zeigt man den Kontoauszug,
über Privilegien reden aber ich möchte schon wissen ob da jemand 25 000 im Monat.
Also ein bisschen so Ja stimmt die soziale Herkunft klar Der Habitus und das kann man den Leuten schon ablesen aber nicht so deutlich wie eine Hautfarbe oder sonstige Eigenschaften.
Wobei zu dem Punkt der Frage Macht. Da muss man noch mal sagen ja man kommt jetzt über diesen Weg in solche Redaktionen.
Das heißt aber nicht dass dieses Einfallstor auch thematisch dann Identitätspolitik zu arbeiten.
Dass das so bleiben muss sondern das große Ziel ist ja dann schon zu sagen okay du steigst erst mal ein als derjenige der die junge schwarze Stimme irgendwie repräsentiert.
Aber so nach zehn Jahren dann halt trotzdem Berichterstatter.
Und es gibt auch Leute die ja keine Lust drauf haben. Mangold hatte mit einer Kollegin jetzt in der ZEIT einen Artikel veröffentlicht.
In der Zeitung. Ich möchte eigentlich.
Er hat keine Lust. Ich habe den Artikel jetzt nicht hier aber er wollte eigentlich damit ausdrücken Es ist für ihn nicht relevant,
dass er das jetzt permanent thematisieren muss dass das Sein Unique Selling Point wird.
Ist.
Allerdings auch wieder eine sehr privilegierte Position wenn man angekommen ist plötzlich zu sagen Ich lese jetzt auch mal Stephen King.
Aber man muss sagen es war nie sein thematisches Programm.
Er hat nicht gesagt in erster Linie von Anfang an der Literaturkritiker der auch besonders Expertise in deutscher Literatur hat.
Ist ja auch gut zu sagen dass man Leute hat die schon angekommen sind und sich auch melden. Und das ist ja bei solchen Leuten.
Aber es entsteht dadurch in Redaktionen mitunter böses Blut oder es werden dann auch Leute gemaßregelt Man erwartet,
dass Redaktionen sich sofort positionieren wenn irgendein Redakteur sich etwas twittert bzw. als Zeitung twittert.
Wir haben das im übrigen auch in dem Video zur Presse erlebt das er dort anmahnte dass die FAZ,
distanziert hat nachdem er.
Der FAZ Redakteur Constantin von Linden zu Recht sagte Naja.
PassantInnen.
Wenn ein Redakteur der,
arbeitet.
Dann kommen wir natürlich.
Brandmarken ganz ganz schwierige Lage.
Aber das ist wirklich eine schwierige F.A.Z. macht sich damit richtig angreifbar denn von alten Bockum wird nirgendwo gemocht.
In Social Media überall gehasst.
Ich möchte hier auch nicht verteidigen welche mißversteht.
Das Problem ist aber die Aufgabe von alten Bockum ist das Innenressort zu leiten.
Das heißt er sitzt morgens da hat da so seine Schreiberlinge zugeschaltet und dann werden Themen geklärt werden dann bearbeitet und dann verbringt er die Zeit damit auf diese Texte zu warten und schon mal die Seiten vorzubereiten und dann wird das alles zusammengebaut.
Wir uns da Schreiberlinge,
bearbeitet,
diese Texte vorzubereiten.
Das Einzige was er tut ist ein Kommentar. Wir brauchen mehr Polizei.
Das Einzige was er schreiben tut ist noch einmal diesen kleinen Kommentar hinterher schieben 200 Worte 150 Worte genau so was so völlig Banane.
Wozu auch.
Warum schreibt die Zeitung dann nicht einfach F.A.Z. runter. Warum muss das nochmal von Bockum sein.
Weil das ist schon ein Problem das jetzt im Archiv Nachkriegs die letzten 300 Texte von alten Bockum sind diese kleinen Kommentare hat sonst nichts publiziert keine Reportagen keine Interviews nichts.
Wenn du immer nur so meinungsstark sind die Dinger raushaut und dann Twitter für dich ein Text um noch weiter zu provozieren und dann kriegst du die Kritik von außen.
Das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein dass da so ein Provokateur drin habt dessen Aufgabe nun mal eine andere ist nämlich die Texte.
Im Grunde ist er verantwortlich für vier fünf Seiten Zeitungen und nicht für das kleine wo dann auch noch sein arm dran steht.
Und das kann man aber von außen nicht so sehen und ich verstehe auch jedem der da so folgt und sagt erst mal irgendwie in Arsch und jetzt mal in so einem langen Video und so.
Das bringt nun mal Konstantin Linden der Lust hat dann so ein Video zu machen in die sich hinter die sich als Autor eines Videos hinter die Institution F.A.Z.
Stellen zu müssen ohne dass dem Medium Youtube gerecht auch eine irgendwie hinzukriegen sodass es verstanden wird sondern es ist einfach da gab es ja immer die alte Logik,
sogar als ich noch bei der FAZ war ja bis 2014 war so Kaube immer die Zeitung antwortet nicht,
die Zeitung publiziert kann man sie lesen dann kann man Leserbriefe schreiben aber dann auch gedruckt aber die Zeitung antwortet nicht und das mussten die jetzt halt komplett aufgeben. Diese Linie.
Die Antwort an sich souverän war sie sagen,
ausgewählt und rezipiert.
Doppelt so viele eigentlich hinter der Paywall ignoriert was ja dann auch eine vollkommen absurde Kategorisierung ist. Ich kann ja nicht,
schreiben das ist mir zu anstrengend. Lasse ich weg.
Es ist ja nicht so dass man damit irgendwie eine Gleichheit hergestellt hat denn manche Zeitungen haben mehr hinter der Paywall andere weniger. Das ist total absurd dass wir jetzt alle aufwachen Podcaster Auswerter.
Blaues T-Shirt anhat.
Ja genau diese mit dieser Umgang mit Methoden.
Auf der inhaltlichen Ebene thematisieren wollte führt leider nur dazu dass Sie sich da komplett disqualifiziert und dass auch jeder Gesprächs Abbruch von der F.A.Z. wieder völlig gerechtfertigt ist.
So kann man eine Auseinandersetzung nicht führen vor allem nicht wenn man sie über Wahrhaftigkeit und Wahrheit führen will.
Ich habe dann Hans im Podcast mal gefragt wie er die Sache einschätzt ist das jetzt eine Auseinandersetzung YouTube gegen F.A.Z. oder Rizzo gegen alten Bockum oder und dann wird es schwierig Rizzo gegen die FAZ oder Konstantin von Linden gegen YouTube oder sowas.
Und wenn man diese Ebene nicht klar zieht dann,
kann man solche Diskussionen nicht führen es ist dann nur noch Happening im Sinne von Das Video hat mir aber gut gefallen wenn ich übrigens gut so argumentieren ja auch 99 prozent unter dem Video ergeben dann Daumen hoch und irgendwie oder hat aber immer wieder zerstört.
Aber das führt genau zu gar nichts das ist ein reines Happening das ich dann irgendwann aus Ermüdung Tod. läuft.
Dann kommt keine Antwort mehr und dann kommt halt irgendwann mal das nächste und dann gehts halt wieder runter und ich konnte leider auch nur so diese Frage halt einfach stellen.
Ist das jetzt Personen gegen Institutionen und wenn ja wer gegen wen oder ist es doch auf persönlicher Ebene.
Man kriegt es nicht mehr zusammen und.
Ein sehr positivistische Geist dass man glaubt man könnte alles journalistische auch so abbilden und wir wissen ja gerade dass wir im Feuilleton ganz anders formulieren.
Wenn ich sage Steffan präsentiert sich als der Vorzeige Intellektuelle dann hast du mir das vielleicht nie gesagt aber ich kann dich so interpretieren.
Und zugleich gibt es aber auch Fehler die im Journalismus gemacht werden die mit ökonomischen Gründen zusammenhängen einfach weil alles ganz ganz schnell in kurzer Zeit gehen muss die Leute sehr wenig verdienen die meisten zumindest nicht alle die darunter arbeiten.
Die verdienen sehr schlecht und es kommt auch noch hinzu dass es auch lässliche Fehler gibt.
Wie oft wurde ich schon irgendwo angekündigt oder beschrieben Als Filmwissenschaftler. Es liegt nahe.
Man liest Filmkritiker Literaturwissenschaftler und Filmwissenschaftler daraus.
Ja ich dürfte mich so nicht nennen. Das tue ich ja auch nicht aber ich würde jetzt auch nicht bei den Zeitungen Stunk machen die Wahrheit schreiben.
Das Beste ist immer wie Reinhard Remmel vor Ort korrekt benannt wird.
Reinhard Rehm fort und mit allen D.s und T.S.
Alle Fehler wurden schon gemacht. Genau so was passiert dann einfach nur in dieser Auseinandersetzung mit wieso auch so interessant. Wieso also aus dem Nichts. Keiner kannte ihn außer YouTube Publikums Blase. Dann war er plötzlich da mit diesem Zerstörung der CDU.
Was passiert dann einfach nur in dieser Auseinandersetzung. Wieso auch.
Interessanteres wieso also aus dem Nichts. Keiner kannte ihn aus eine Publikums.
Dann war plötzlich da habe die Zerstörung der CDU was wie ich finde astreine Zerstörung der Presse mit Jehova vorgeführt.
Was wie ich finde astrein ist Zerstörung der Presse Video. Da hat er sie einfach vorgeführt. Und genauso ist er jetzt wieder zumindest bei mir abgestürzt einfach mit diesem F.A.Z. sinnlosem rum.
Und genauso ist jetzt wieder zumindest bei mir abgestürzt.
Irgendwie hätte er sich bei der Bild irgendwie bei der Bild belassen.
Ich.
Wobei die Leute auch nicht mal differenzieren.
Wäre interessant und sein Publikum hat aber auch noch nie eine gedruckte Bild gekauft.
Vielleicht mal bei Mutti auf dem Tisch gesehen in der Küche.
Na ja aber das war auch mal so eine Frage wieviel Stimmen hat jetzt die eigentlich der CDU gekostet.
Die Europawahl war das Video vielleicht zwei drei Prozent.
Gleich zwei drei Prozent. Die CDU hat sich seit diesem Jahr verdoppelt.
Nur die CDU hat sich seitdem in diesem Jahr verdoppelt. Die steht jetzt bei 38 Prozent.
38 Prozent der EU-Staaten.
Das fand keine Zerstörung der CDU statt und man muss sich wirklich immer fragen Wozu welche Effekte.
Ach so. Ich dachte Jetzt steigt die Auflage der FAZ bald.
Ja es kam ja tatsächlich dann die Frage.
Wie viel die Video Cocoa lesen jetzt keine F.A.Z. mehr.
Und wieviel F.A.Z. Leser haben überhaupt mitbekommen dass es ein Video gab weil die Zeitungsleser diesen 60+ warten morgens auf die Zeitungen wenn in einer Zeitung nicht drinsteht dass wir hier gerade in Bettwil gehen.
Dann wird es auch nicht statt bei denen genau wie bei YouTube.
Ich habe vor fünf Jahren schon mit Studenten bei so Termin gesprochen wo die meinten die FAZ hat auch eine Website wusste ich gar nicht.
Ich dachte das ist nur diese Zeitung da gibts keine überschneidungen. Das ist einfach nur Rizzo und die FAZ.
Und wenn die beiden miteinander Streit führen dann interessiert das 3000 4000 Kommentatoren die nochmal drunter schreiben für den Rest geht das so vorbei.
Hat die eigene inhaltliche Anmerkung zu seinem Video bei Google Docs publiziert nicht mal auf der eigenen Seite sondern hat den Google Doc verlinkt in dem Video.
Das sagt doch irgendwie schon alles über die Trennung der Welten die da einfach drin stecken. Grandios.
Das ist ein gutes Stichwort. Nochmal zu den Redaktionen Es gab da einen Text von Matt Tibi oder Tipp Talib Talib.
So wie man es am einfachsten sprechen will.
Der hat für Furore gesorgt und zwar sagt dass die Linken eigentlich den Verstand verloren haben dass die Redaktionen sich gerade selbst zerstören.
Ich habe mal zwei Auszüge aus diesem Text eingelesen auf Deutsch allerdings.
Manchmal scheint es dass das Leben in diesem Land nicht schlechter werden kann.
Unser Präsident Donald Trump ist ein Clown der einen großen Realityshow Bösewicht darstellt aber als Führer einer Supermacht einzigartig Werkzeug los ist.
Aber Polizeigewalt und Trumps tägliche Angriffe auf den Kompetenz Standard des Präsidenten sind nur ein Teil der Katastrophe auf der anderen Seite des politischen Spektrums unter den selbsternannten Liberalen.
Beobachten wir eine intellektuelle Revolution.
Es fühlt sich befreiend an nach Jahren der Umgehung dieser Tatsache zu sagen Die amerikanische Linke hat den Verstand verloren.
Sie ist zu einem feigen Mob von Social Media Süchtigen der Oberschicht geworden,
zu Twitter Robespierres die von Disziplin zu Disziplin wechseln und mit atemberaubender Lässigkeit Reputation und Arbeitsplätze abfackeln.
Eingelesen von Journalisten die,
nicht einfach nur,
Black Lives Matter haben sondern zum Beispiel,
bei Plünderungen.
Das sind in der Regel nicht reiche die davon betroffen sind.
Es werden verschiedene Dinge Tweets oder auch in Artikeln angesprochen im übrigen fast nur von Journalisten die sich mit Polizeigewalt auseinandergesetzt haben.
FORMAT sagen wir mal Julian Reichelt oder sowas sondern wir haben uns damit sehr angesehene Journalisten zu tun die sich ein bisschen kontroverser positioniert haben und die daraufhin,
keinen Rückhalt von der Redaktion bekommen haben also nicht so wie das bei der FAZ.
Entweder gehen mussten oder sich entschuldigen mussten. Das ist der Anlass für diesen Artikel und auch für diese Polemik.
Einfach abgeschossen werden und ein,
Fan der noch einmal,
fragte Wie ist das bei denen bei denen bei Gewalt bei der Gewalt wenn ein weißer Polizist einen Schwarzen tötet dann sind alle in Aufruhr und machen so ein großes eine,
soziale gesamt Gemengelage bei der jeden Tag schwarze schwarzer erschießen und das zu genau solchen,
wenn auch nicht in der Tat selbst aber dann zu den gleichen Wirkung.
In Familien kann man das auch mal beobachten und daraufhin gleich von den Kollegen hopps genommen weil du von der Agenda abweicht das natürlich erst mal die Gewalt zwischen Weißen und Schwarzen ein großes Problem ist,
bis hin zu dass man dann wegen sowas auch gefeuert wird weil die Redaktion dann einfach keinen Bock mehr haben sich mit sowas zu befassen und sich da groß einzumischen.
Wie soll man sagen diese Beispiele die er da nennt diese drei sind wirklich noch mal aufrüttelnd wenn man das so nüchtern nachliest.
Also sollte man wirklich mal komplett lesen ein sehr langer sehr guter Artikel,
den Schluss dieses Textes.
Die Medien haben in den letzten vier Jahren eine Reihe von moralischen Manien entwickelt.
Man sagt uns das Wichtigste was es je gegeben hat geschehe tage oder wochenlang bis Themen abrupt fallengelassen und vergessen werden.
Trotz all unserer berüchtigten Versäumnisse hatten Journalisten einst eine gewisse Härte an den Tag gelegt.
Es wurde auch einmal als eine Tugend angesehen sich über die Mißbilligung von Kollegen hinwegzusetzen um für Geschichten zu kämpfen an die wir glaubten. Zum Beispiel Watergate.
Heute wird sich niemand mit einem Gehalt für Kollegen wie Li Fang einsetzen.
Unsere tapferen wahrheits Erzähler zeigen unserem marodierenden Präsidenten großartige Shows mit zitternden Fäusten,
aber nicht einer von ihnen wird ehrlich über die Angst sprechen die durch ihre eigenen Nachrichtenredaktionen läuft.
Die Menschen verlassen sich darauf dass wir ihnen sagen was wir sehen und nicht was wir denken.
Wozu sind wir gut wenn wir Angst davor haben es zu tun.
Es gibt da so eine psychologische Dimension. Irgendwie hat Obama kürzlich mal wieder schön gefasst indem er eben auch immer eine Standardfrage an Obama.
Wie machen wir das jetzt mit dem Schwur kommt der Jantscher. Und dann hat er auch noch einmal eine Antwort darauf zu geben wo das herkommt da dürfen wir sagen wo er herkommt.
Und das ist wenn man Social-Media so als Selbstbeschäftigung benutzt und sich gut fühlt nachdem man nochmal jemand anderen kritisiert hat weil er irgendetwas nicht getan hat.
Ja ich erinnere mich an alles bringt zwar wieder auf den Punkt Das ist genauso.
Und es bringt es mal wieder auf den Punkt weil das ist genauso.
Man setzt so ein Tweet ab ernährt sich dann was die moralische Unterstützung angeht aus den Reaktionen die so kommen und hofft dass nicht allzu viele widersprechen wenn man gleichzeitig jemand anderen verurteilt hat.
Man setzt so ab nähert sich dann was die moralische Unterstützung angeht aus den Reaktionen die so kommen.
Man hofft dass nicht allzu viele widersprechen wenn man gleichzeitig jemand anderen verurteilt hat man hofft einfach auf der richtigen Seite der Beurteiler ist ja.
Man hofft einfach dass man immer auf der richtigen Seite der Verurteilung ist und man weiß es immer nicht so genau. Man muss immer erst mal den Tweet absetzen und.
Und manche sind ja hervorragend. Ich habe kürzlich mit Freunden die auch ein bisschen in der Medienwelt unterwegs sind darüber gesprochen sagte ich euch,
was.
Genau mit dem richtigen Ton diese Kolumne zu verurteilen zugleich aber auch die Petition zu unterschreiben gegen Seehofer der gegen die Kolumnistin vorgehen will.
Vielleicht im Fernsehen aufzutreten.
Das,
ist nicht meine Sache ich merke dass ich,
manchmal einfach nicht die Möglichkeit bei Twitter wirklich zu funktionieren weil es zu lang ist.
Da haben wir andere Chancen. Man kann nicht bei Twitter.
Naja es gibt Theoretiker die sind gar nicht.
Greift zu kurz da müssen wir hier schon mal 15 Minuten drüber reden damit man ich manchmal keine Lust mehr dazu.
So blöd dass ich dann irgendwie sage lieber woanders oder ich mache es.
Vom Winde verweht. Das muss man differenzierter sehen.
Dann brauche ich aber auch mal 20 Minuten um den Film zu analysieren und kann dann nicht sagen warum auch unsinnig ist ihn mal von der Plattform zu nehmen weil wir gerade Black Lives Matter haben.
Der Film ist zurück mit dem Hinweis dass er die Horror Sklaverei nicht mit dem Hinweis anscheinend erträglich.
Kann man das dann kann man es gucken. Irgendwie weiß man Bescheid.
Also wird das nicht vorher gewusst.
Man kann aber auch damit spielen. Ich mache das ja wirklich gern. Es gibt ja wirklich Twitterer die die sagen die sind so Rädelsführer von Political Correctness.
Die nimmt sich dann weiß ja nicht wo das so herkommt an so einer Laune.
Am Nachmittag nimmt sie sich plötzlich deutsche Kinder Hörspiele und schreibt dann auf Twitter muss das eigentlich sein dass wir niemals in deutschen Kinder spielen.
Junge Mädels haben einen schwierigen Fall lösen und so weiter geht's in die Richtung wo ich mir denke du bist wahrscheinlich auch bald keine Ahnung 35 40 oder sowas.
Und was wahrscheinlich auch bei Social Media noch nicht gesehen deswegen so wahrscheinlich vor 25 Jahren zuletzt gehört und das ist so die drei Ausrufezeichen.
Womit sich alle Mädels irgendwie rumschlagen und genau das rausholen was die Jungs aus den Drei Fragezeichen holt. Wobei die Mädels auch gerne drei Fragezeichen.
Es geht da drunter und drüber. Und dass man solche Tweets dann auch immer schon nehmen kann und sagen kann Ja,
das kann man auch auf Twitter mal kurz frech rapportieren irgendwie ja oder wenn die nächste Lauterbach Schlacht geschlagen wird mit ganz viele Coruña Fälle sind so und so.
Und dann setzt aber Hendrik Streeck so ein Ding drunter.
Mit Verlaub Herr Lauterbach Das sind nicht viele Fälle sondern es sind einzelne anekdotische Sachen die halt auch bei zehn Millionen Infektionen kann ich das schon.
Ich weiß also auch in meiner Blase gibt es viele die so kurz zögern.
Soll ich das jetzt oder lasse ich einfach durchfliegen weil ich mich da nicht einmischen will sich da kann man schon viel machen außerdem bin ich auch immer dafür,
sowieso Tweets automatisiert zu löschen aber man muss gar nicht immer 7 Tage warten sondern man kann auch einfach am Abend einfach löschen.
Ich habe.
Ich hätte gerne alles in den Mülleimer.
So gut wie nichts.
Ich glaube man muss,
diese Art der Sprachkritik ist immer so eine Kritik.
Zugleich aber ist diese Fokussierung auf einzelne Worte problematisch weil viele Leute einen sehr unreflektierten Sprachgebrauch haben auch weil sie es nie anders gelernt haben.
Dinge die nicht unbedingt darauf schließen lassen wie sie dazu stehen.
Foroutan,
Telefonumfrage.
Wenn es zum Beispiel um Migranten geht dann sei da schon ganz klar ableitbar. Da muss man sagen viele Leute reden unreflektiert und versuchen.
Begrifflichkeiten die sie haben gegenüber Ausländer.
Sie meinen aber nicht das die nicht dazugehören sondern dass das.
Vokabular um zu beschreiben was Menschen sind sehr vorsichtig und,
nicht die ganze Sprache auf die Summe der Sprache ist wichtig.
Und wenn wir nur mal schauen wie die Management Sprache funktioniert wie sie eben auch Political Correctness macht indem sie nicht mehr Leute sondern sie freistellt damit sie neue Chancen ergreifen können.
Dann können wir schon mal sehen wie Management Sprache funktioniert politische Sprache,
immer mit Hass und Gewalt um irgendwelche Schritte zu unternehmen sondern auch in ganz anderer perfider Weise furchtbar sein kann und auch gewaltsam sein kann. Jeder kennt das.
Vielleicht nochmal mitgebracht von der CDU zum Geburtstag gratuliert.
Es hat ein paar Jahre gedauert bis wir als Parteien hinter dem politischen Kulturkampf an der jeweils anderen Partei Eigenschaften wie Verbindlichkeit und guten Umgang miteinander als Tugenden im politischen Wettstreit anerkannt haben.
In guten Zeiten war die CDU immer ein Garant für Stabilität und Verlässlichkeit auch wenn uns diese Begriffe nicht so in die Wiege gelegt waren haben wir ihren Wert für die Politik zu schätzen gelernt.
Management.
Kindersprache Vorbereitung auf große Koalition schließt mit den Worten liebe CDU freuen wir uns auf die nächsten Jahre des fairen Wettstreits mit euch. Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Freuen wir uns auf die nächsten Jahre des fairen Wettstreits mit euch. Glückwunsch.
Muss ich jetzt auch sagen wenn ich mich dazu in einem Kommentar positionieren würde kann ich da nur aus strafrechtlichen Gründen die Harald Schmidt Methode anwenden und sagen Bernburg und Habeck haben sich intellektuell hier nochmal übertroffen.
Musste ich jetzt auch sagen wenn ich jetzt.
Naja ich sehe das nicht so kritisch. Das ist ja auch im Grunde CDU-Wähler geschrieben.
Ja ja das ist mir schon aufgefallen Stefan.
Da muss du halt. Da musst du dann halt sowohl die Plattform wählen zu der Lassing gehört als auch insgesamt.
Apropos Sprache Da kann ja ein bisschen ins schließen. übergehen oder.
Also gut ich will immer noch ein das war nicht gut.
Nicht nur der Bundestag hat ein neues Gesetz beschlossen sondern die EU-Kommission will auch ein neues Gesetz.
Sie haben eine interessante Begründung und ich lese Originaltext von EU-Seite das offizielle deutsch was da vorgelegt wurde es geht auch hier um die Frage Wie kriegt man jetzt fake news und so weiter.
Bei Facebook Google und Co. eingefangen hat die Kommission am 10.
Juni 2020 geschrieben Das ist so ein Action Plan irgendwie ein Fünf-Punkte-Plan in die covert 19. Pandemie geht mit einer beispiellosen Info einher.
Eine Flut von oftmals falschen oder ungenauen Informationen über das Coronavirus die sich rasch über die sozialen Medien verbreiten kann wie die Weltgesundheitsorganisation warnt.
Verwirrung und Misstrauen hervorrufen und wirksame gesundheitspolitische Maßnahmen untergraben.
Schon im allerersten Absatz komplett im Framing.
Virus Infektion Pandemie Epidemie eine Info die sich rasch in sozialen Medien verbreitet und die Weltgesundheitsorganisation warnt vor Verwirrung und Misstrauen.
Ich schreibe noch in Anführungszeichen aber trotzdem diese Info Demi nährt sich aus den elementarsten ängsten der Menschen.
Sie hat so richtig Rezeptoren Rezeptoren wo sie andockt wie ein Virus aufgrund der sozialen Kontakt Beschränkungen müssen Millionen von Menschen zuhause bleiben.
Die sozialen Medien werden verstärkt genutzt eine Folge von Physical Social dispensieren sondern,
neue soziale Formen die dann eben zu so etwas führen unter anderem um Informationen abzurufen während gleichzeitig Onlineplattformen Fakten Prüfer und Nutzer sozialer Medien Millionen falscher oder irreführender Posts melden.
Angesichts der Neuartigkeit des Virus fragt man sich jetzt sind Sie jetzt noch bei Corona fake news haben sich Wissenslücken als idealer Nährboden für die Verbreitung falscher und irreführender Narrative erwiesen.
Das ist Social Media so als Petrischale mit einem idealen Nährboden in dem das wächst.
Punkt Nummer eins Die covert 19 Info Demi erfordert eine rasche Reaktion der EU und ihrer Mitgliedsstaaten okay soweit.
Punkt Nummer fünf ist dann schon die Zusammenarbeit mit Social-Media-Plattform ist ein wesentliches Element sowohl für die Erstellung einer umfassenden Bewertung der Herausforderung als auch für eine wirksame Reaktion auf die Info Demi.
Darüber werden wir im Salon Zusammenarbeit.
Mit Mark Zuckerberg. Ja wir müssen sehen dass wir zusammenarbeiten.
Und es gibt noch eine zweite Verlautbarung hier eine Pressemitteilung.
Und seine zweite Frau aufbauen hier eine Pressemitteilung. Zitat Der Hohe Vertreter Vizepräsident Josep Borrell zu ganz oben angesiedelt erklärt dazu Zitat.
Zitat Der Hohe Vertreter Vizepräsident Josep Borrell ist institutionell ganz oben angesiedelt erklärt dazu Zitat Desinformation in Zeiten der Caron Coronavirus Pandemie kann töten.
Desinformation in Zeiten der Karoo Coronavirus Pandemien kann töten.
Wir haben die Pflicht unsere Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu schützen.
Wir sind hier ganz nah an Richard Dawkins Man hat die Chance genutzt zu sagen was funktioniert mit politischen Folgen. Wir können entscheiden und dann wird gemacht.
Wir sind hier ganz nahe an Richard Dawkins Man hat die Chance genutzt zu sagen,
wenn es bei Crooner so krass funktioniert mit politischen Folgen und wir können ja einfach entscheiden und dann wird gemacht dann sollten wir das mal mit Fake News rund um Corona genauso behandeln und man hat wirklich das ganze Ding einmal von Gene Kelly gilt auch für die Meme und so weiter und hat jetzt.
Dann sollten wir das mal mit Placebos rundum ohne genauso behandeln.
Man hat wirklich das ganze Ding eimerweise was wie die Gene gilt gilt auch für die Meme. Worte sind.
Genau das politische Programm komplett in dieses Ding rein gefragt.
Finde ich ehrlich gesagt auch ein bisschen so ein gewisser Kunstgriff steckt da drin.
Und hat natürlich zur Folge dass man dann politisch denn das ist ja wirklich beeindruckend.
Facebook hat sich lange gewehrt Verlautbarungen von Trump Fake News gehts ja nicht nur um Trump sondern grundsätzlich so zu behandeln wie Twitter oder shocking zu machen.
Und dann hat Unilever gesagt Wir streichen alle unsere Werbebudgets für Facebook und zack sieben Prozent Minus im Aktienkurs durch die Ankündigung am nächsten Tag kam dann gleich Coca-Cola dazu.
Fox News hat es genauso getroffen Tucker Carlson hat sechs Mal verloren.
Durch seine Kritik an Black Lives Matter.
Disney T-Mobil und so weiter. Das sind diese großen Millionen Budgets.
Da geht es richtig zur Sache Fake. Fox News hat selbst gefälschte Bilder benutzt da gab es in Seattle diese Ausschreitungen dann haben sie aus zwei Bildern und da lagen zehn Tage dazwischen so ein privat Mielitz Typ,
einen geplünderten Supermarkt gestellt.
Das stimmt gar nicht. Das sind jetzt alles so Sachen die passieren den Medien bei Facebook hier bei Fox News und so weiter und dann sagen Werbetreibende aufgrund dessen was wir auch diskutiert haben.
Das ist nicht mehr der kommunikative Umschlagplatz in dem wir bereit sind unsere Werbegelder niederzulassen Hier wird jetzt gestrichen.
Kevin Rous den kennen wir als diesen Autor von diesem Robert Rabbit Tool Text den wir da sind sich auch schon gelesen haben.
Nochmal in einem Tweet am 26. Juni darauf hingewiesen Platz 3 des heute meist geknickten Inhalts auf Facebook mit 200 000 Shares und,
ein paar Kennziffern ist das ein Foto das Verschandeln Vietnam Warrant Denkmals durch Black Lives Matas Aktivisten stellt sich raus.
Das Denkmal ist zwar verschandelt wurde auch fotografiert aber das Bild war von 2016.
Und wenn Facebook das nicht in den Griff bekommt sowas sondern.
Der Aktivismus von Black Lives Matter Wo fand der Stadt ganz stark.
Man hat sich da sehr stark organisiert noch einmal hat man sich auf Think Tank organisiert um die erste große Wahlkampfveranstaltung zu sabotieren von Donald Trump man,
dazu aufgerufen dass sich alle reservieren die Tickets reservieren und dann waren die Ränge so leer wie kam das.
Ja das hat sich ein paar haben sich das auch Taktik einfallen lassen A.
Ein paar Leutchen sondern mit der Pointe können wir jetzt schließen weil es geht in den November.
Am Anfang hieß es und das hat Trump selbst sehr alberne Zitate von ihm wir haben eine Million Tickets verkauft und so weiter. Ein großer Ansturm.
Am Anfang hieß es. Und das hat Trump selbst sehr albern. Zitat von ihm eine Million Tickets verkauft. Der Ansporn.
Es gab noch eine zweite Bühne vor der Halle die konnte da gar nicht bespielt werden musste abgebaut werden ohne jemals bespielt worden sein in der Halle selbst war 90000 Sitzplätze und 7000 Badende drin.
Es gab noch eine zweite Bühne vor der Halle die konnte dann gar nicht bespielt werden musste abgebaut werden ohne jemals bespielt worden sein in der Halle selbst waren 19 000 Sitzplätze und 7000 waren nur drin. Und wie du sagst es geht auf diesen Tick Tack Aktion von Mary Lou Laub zurück.
Und du sagst es geht nach diesen Aktionen auch zurück.
Auch bekannt als die Zickzack Oma und der Nachtclub dazu.
Auch bekannt als die Zickzack Oma und dazu ihr altes Mastektomie wahrscheinlich 19 oder 5.
Das weiß ich nicht genau aber sie ist,
irgendwie.
Und dazu ist es jetzt vorbei.
Die abschließende Pointe dazu. Sie ist jetzt im Wahlkampfteam von Joe Biden engagiert.
Hat sie tatsächlich. Ach also mal gucken was dieser Wahlkampf bringt. Ja ich würde sagen.
Mal gucken was dieser Wahlkampf noch bringt. Ich werde sagen Im Juli wird es dann hochinteressant wenn wir da uns draufkommen.
Aber wenn sie sechzig ist dann ist sehr wahrscheinlich die jüngste.
Im Vergleich zu Kandidaten ein junger Hüpfer so wie das ganze Team da im Juli jetzt dann hier weiter.
Zum Kandidaten.
Im Juni hier weiter vorne ja alles die Wähler.
Mal gucken wir das sind ja alles Development.
Wir gucken und dann denk dran vielleicht ein paar Tage früher für Mitglieder.
Und wir sind gespannt ob Stefan schon erste Beuß Tweets veröffentlicht hat.
Wenn es bis dahin klappt bringe ich ein paar mit Ich mache.
Tschüss.
Intro/Outro